uh
um
[Music]
[Music]
this session of the joint committee
hearings on the waco matter is now
convened
good morning this morning you may have
your seats for the witnesses we have
very brief opening statements this
morning we have little time to deal with
for them today and really should not
because we have some exigency in trying
to conclude these matters this is a very
important panel this morning we started
earlier for convenience of our panelists
as well as because our schedule today
would probably dictate the house will
discontinue business somewhere around
three or four o'clock this afternoon
first of all i would just simply like to
open the comments by saying that
yesterday was a fruitful day in our
discussions of what happened at waco in
regard to the fbi's testimony and the
evidence that came in uh continuing to
give us a stream of what happened in the
planning of the use of the cs gas and
and why that plan was done
we also heard uh some disturbing
concerns that continue to come forth
with regard to whether or not
the attorney general in washington got
the kind of information on the
negotiations that
many of us were hearing indeed were
going on at the end
no question about the sincerity of our
federal bureau of investigation folks
negotiating on my judgment at least and
no question about their earnestness and
their belief and what they were doing
but there continues to be some
disturbing question as to what degree
the information they had
and the quality of that information in
dealing with the
the courage matter at the very end of
all of this was indeed passed on to
washington we also are left with
questions about the gas itself uh the
insertion plan and so forth today we're
here for the approval part of that and
we want to hear from you for that reason
i do want to comment that part of the
testimony yesterday also concerned the
situation with respect to the hostage
rescue team
we did hear a clarification that that
team probably had the ability to stay
on the ground in waco for about two more
weeks before they would have needed to
have been pulled back in order to get
retrained and in order to get some time
for their proficiency skills to be
rebuilt because they were stretched
pretty far
we also heard one comment that i think
was of some significance i do not know
what it means overall but we did hear uh
yesterday that mr jamar had a feeling
that 99 certainty that the davidians
would fire on the vehicles as they
approach to insert the gas
but apparently that was that feeling was
not conveyed to mr potts and perhaps not
on up the line whether that would have
made any difference in the judgment of
the attorney general or others on this
matter of use of the gas
is not all clear but nonetheless that
point was made yesterday
now i am not going to go further in an
opening statement today our objective is
to be very brief we want to announce the
schedule we are going to have two panels
today the panel that's before us which
is dealing with the question of the
approval of the use of the cs gas that
particular plan
later this afternoon hopefully early
this afternoon we will have a panel of
experts to discuss the fire itself what
caused the fire which i know has been
one of those things debated and
discussed and quite controversial
we anticipate that monday will be a
session that will involve
presentations of the military's role to
what degree were they involved in
support and what activities and advice
they gave as well as a very
comprehensive panel on the day of the
insertion of the gas itself that very
faithful day where the lies were lost it
is also anticipated now because of the
time that's been consumed in these
panels that it would be unfair to bring
the attorney general up here very late
in the day on monday and it probably
would be very very late and so we
anticipate having the final concluding
session of this hearing set on tuesday
with attorney general reno rather than
on monday as previously announced with
that in mind i would call on mrs thurman
for any opening comment she might have
mr chairman i have opening remarks but
i realize we have a time problem here
with one of our witnesses today and so
therefore i would like just just to have
unanimous consent to submit mine into
the record because i think it's more
important that we hear from these folks
without objection uh mr zela
thank you mr chairman uh today marks the
eighth day of fact finding hearings on
executive branch conduct into the waco
tragedy
today as with all other days questioning
will be vigorous it will be pointed and
motivated by our continuing twin aims to
discover the truth and then put things
right
i'm convinced
especially after reading my mail this
week and i've read almost all of it that
most americans recognize the real
importance of this constitutional
oversight process they also recognize
that it sometimes takes courage to raise
very probing and pointed questions
yesterday again a few of my colleagues
across the aisle questioned our support
of law enforcement so before turning to
the issues we face today i want to pause
and let's just let me be simple and
clear
first because someone asked hard
questions about waco and what happened
that does not mean that they somehow are
abandoning our law enforcement
second no supporter of law enforcement
enjoys scrutinizing the activities of
law enforcement community
people at the top and the bottom in law
enforcement deserve our respect and most
of them know that they they have it
many have already said that what we are
doing by having these hearings is good
good for america and good for them in
the long run i believe and i'm committed
to that process constitutional oversight
is the bedrock of this nation and if it
falls by the wayside if it can be run
off the road by distractions then we
really have a good deal to worry about
more so than just waco
third it is not just words when people
on this side of the aisle say that they
know and believe in law enforcement and
the men and women who daily put their
lives on the line to the white house it
is damage control a spin game a cabinet
secretary calling a member
asking him to not ask embarrassing
questions
a justice department press release
explaining away obstruction of justice
an epa denunciation of a witness who
comes to testify before us a white house
spokesman who claims that the
republicans on the panel are against law
enforcement well these are all the press
stories but let me tell you i need only
say at once that that is the kind of
thing that americans are sick of
the kind of conduct that this serves the
entire process
sitting on this side of the aisle today
sits more than 100 years of collective
law enforcement experience mr heineman
of north carolina has been in law
enforcement for 38 years he's been a
chief of police for 15 years mr barr of
georgia was the united states attorney
for four years mr bryant of tennessee
was a prosecutor for eight years mr
boyer of indiana mr shattuck of arizona
whose father is a deputy sheriff mr
schiff of new mexico
all former prosecutors and the rest
lifetime supporters all of us of law
enforcement so we need to stop about the
business of being against law
enforcement i think we're all for that
and we're we're all for making sure that
it's totally credible we're going to do
everything we can to see that stays that
way
on the issues i'll say just this our
aims are to find the truth one day at a
time to educate ourselves and those who
follow these hearings and to prevent
other tragedies by understanding the
many flawed decisions that produce this
one we're almost at the end of a set of
events that occurred 27 months ago and
ended in a deadly blaze we have all seen
it on television we'll see it again
today
reviewing everything we learned will be
impossible but we've learned an awful
lot a lot of new information in these
final three days i think we'll find out
still more information on three
untraveled topics first how is the cs
gas decision the final go-ahead really
made did it develop over weeks hours or
days was it made by the attorney general
reno alone or not
what was the role of mr hubble mr foster
or others close to the president and the
president himself who originated the
idea when and why was an 11th hour offer
of surrender an offer collaborated by
the texas rangers and and uh
and also confirmed by caress attorney in
detail rejected
we will then turn to the fire itself and
hear from an array of arson
investigators we will hear from the
justice department on their full theory
of how the fire started and we will
objectively try to answer lingering
questions we'll also hear from one of
the branch davidians who escaped mr
olive doyle
or mr clive doyle he will tell us what
it was like to survive the fire and what
he believes about those who did not
our day is a pulling but like
all of the last seven days this one
promises to deliver as much light as
heat as much truth as we are willing to
ask for and as much goodness for the
country's sake as we can squeeze into
eight or ten hours mr chairman thank you
i look forward to the testimony thank
you mr zelic mr schumer
thank you uh
mr chairman and i'd like to make three
points this morning the first is just as
my colleague bill zelif uh went into a
long litany of how the the people on the
panel are good friends of law
enforcement
just as every day
yesterday just about every member of the
other side before they asked questions
talked about what friends they are of
law enforcement well i would answer with
one line from shakespeare he thinks the
lady duck protested too much
next i would like to talk about the two
issues that are really before us today
the first involves uh what i call real
political politicization
of these hearings and that is not an
effort to find out what went wrong but
somehow an effort to link what happened
to the white house i found it very
interesting that my friend mr zelif
mentioned two people in the white house
only mr hubble who has troubles of his
own and mr foster who had even greater
troubles as the two people who might be
involved why didn't he mention all the
other people in the white house well we
know why and why is it that there is not
a shred of evidence i read the documents
that many on the majority side said they
had to have to see if white house was
involved the documents by their own
admission don't have one scintilla of
evidence that the white house influenced
this policy yes they were informed as it
would be in a good chain of command but
no influence but the majority seeks to
say over and over again was the white
house involved
that my friends is what is ruining these
hearings
not a desire to find the truth and go
over the mistakes but an effort to
politicize the hearings and bring in
extraneous issues
that have nothing
nothing to do with the avowed purpose of
these hearings but by smear by innuendo
by
exaggeration
to
uh bring a bring an untruth into
credibility the same problem of moral
relativism so again just think why in
the opening statement was just mr hubble
and mr foster mentioned as in the white
house but none of the other people
i think that shows something
the second question that we have to
answer today
is and this is a serious question
this is not like the other one this is
who's who set the fire
that it killed 80 people
and
again i would ask my colleagues here to
look at the evidence
not at wild theories
let's remember a few things
let's remember that the arson team
chosen by the texas rangers who both
sides of the aisle have praised as a
unbiased
capable law enforcement investig
investigators they conducted an
exhaustive investigation and concluded
deliberately that the fire was set
deliberately by one of the persons in
the compound
let us remember that one of the
majority's star witnesses
and one who has made some telling points
points i disagree with but his points
were telling and he was an expert dr
stone
even though he had a lot of criticism as
to how this thing came about and what
the fbi did
said that the davidians set the fire in
the compound and finally
proof positive although i'm sure we'll
hear innuendo in doubt from the other
side
tapes
tapes from the compound with quotes on
them that's are like these quote they
got some fuel around in here yeah they
even poured it already poured it already
yeah he got it poured
more quotes you got to put the fuel in
there too got to put the fuel in there
fuel is there a way to spread the fuel
in there there
quote so we only light them as soon as
they tell me last chance right
well that's the fuel we should get more
hay in here and finally
after all the fuel was poured
more quotes from these tapes tapes that
everyone agrees are true
have veracity
what are you going to do now we're
committed
i want a fire around the back
keep that fire going
these are tapes from inside the compound
they talk about people spreading fuel
they talk about people
lighting fires
this idea that the fire came some other
way
this idea that cs gas had anything to do
with some kind of
explosion unrelated to being said the
fire being said
is wrong
and i would ask my colleagues on the
other side of the aisle these this is
the most serious charge even more
important than who shot first
to examine in their hearts what the real
truth is
to step up to the plate if they really
want to give law enforcement an even
shot
if not even the benefit of the doubt
and come
to the conclusion at the end after they
hear the evidence which i have looked at
from top to bottom
that if they believe
that the fire was set
inside the compound by the davidians
that they say so
because the worst part of the conspiracy
theory that is running in parts of this
country
is
that the fire was deliberately left lit
by government agents who wanted to burn
these women and children
every reasonable person in america knows
that's not the truth
everyone who has studied this objective
people
knows that is not the truth
and we will be doing a horrible
disservice to the government and the
country we all believe in and love
if at the end of these hearings when the
evidence which i believe it will will
show
that is the case that we still try to
say
by innuendo by implication that we
haven't answered that very serious and
very important question
because we know from the evidence from
all objective observers that the fire
was lit by david porrish
thank you mr chairman uh i now want to
introduce our panel of witnesses for
today we will then have you sworn and
then begin the questioning uh i am only
going to read the introductions not
necessarily in the order in which you're
seated
judge william sessions is the former
director of the federal bureau of
investigations florida clark was deputy
director of the fbi
webster hubble was associate attorney
general
we have mark richard with us he was
deputy assistant attorney general for
the criminal division
he had supervised your responsibility
for terrorism and violent crime at the
time of the waco happening
larry potts who's with us again today as
well as with us yesterday was the
assistant director for the criminal
investigations at the fbi at the time of
of the waco involvement and dr harry
salem who's also back with us again
today is the chief of life sciences
department research and technology
directorate of the u.s army edgewood
research development engineering center
for the department of defense
he briefed the attorney general on the
cs gas question if all of you would
please stand
i'll swear you in
you raise your right hand do you swear
or affirm that the testimony you shall
give today will be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
please be seated let the record reflect
that all of the witnesses answered in
the affirmative we will begin our
questioning today with mr bryant you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman uh one disturbing
aspect of the fire as already has been
referenced today that has caused me
great concern over the uh night was a
statement made by the fbi sac mr jamar
yesterday concerning the monitoring
device the the listening device that had
been uh secretly planted in the davidian
compound
and the fact of the morning of the raid
beginning about six o'clock when the
fire was when the gas began to be
inserted into the
compound
that the
live monitoring
folks who sat there with the earphones
on to listen to what was going on in the
compound
and they assumed they had done that for
days and days and days before at this
particular crunch time when the chips
were on the table when it had to be
determined what was going on inside that
compound when your best intelligence was
needed
because mr jamar had said
as i recall his testimony that if
i had known they were spreading gasoline
i would have called off that
raid that morning yet at that critical
time in this entire investigation or
this entire siege
he candidly said yesterday that i don't
know why we didn't have that information
because as the truth has come out in
this hearing
what mr schumer read from that tape was
just that they didn't know about it
until they listened to the tape
afterwards
and at that critical crunch time when
they had to have this intelligence as to
what was going on inside
when the raid was started they didn't
have it and i hope we get some answers
as to why they're wanting somebody there
monitoring that at that time or why they
weren't able to hear which they
obviously heard it other times
and that that causes me great stress
because had they heard that according to
mr jamar they would not have continued
the insertion of the gas that morning
and i think that's a critical question
that the american public need to need to
have the answer to
mr salem briefly
we talked yesterday and i think we sort
of defined this issue of whether or not
to insert cs gas into the compound
on a children's level as to whether or
not it would kill them
and we've talked about studies and no
there's no studies out there as to the
effect of killing children or not and
and i think we've kind of overlooked
that in between area as to what effect
that gas would have on debilitating
disorienting
causing these children to be
dysfunctional
again during this critical time when
there was uh what appeared to them to be
a frontal assault on their home
at a critical time when very likely fire
could have broken out which i think the
fbi admits that that was a possibility
that fire could break out because they
were aware of the local fire departments
and what their arrival time would be
and i can just imagine i hope the agents
imagined ahead of time that if fire did
break out and we had inserted this gas
and these kids in there had become
debilitated and disoriented and
certainly panic stricken
and they were physically incapable of of
moving or doing what they typically
typically typically would do
wouldn't that have some kind of effect
on them in terms of disability uh
disorientation
physical incapacitation in a panic
situation
is this something is its own
sir the effects of the cs as as a
um
a sensory irritant it causes tearing
blinking
and it gives you the uh feeling of
trying to flee from that area and unless
there's an obstruction most people can
get away from that we're talking
children now five six seven years old
would it cause them not to be dis
debilitated disoriented according to
all of the evidence that is available
there is no difference in the
sensitivity for children adults or the
elderly okay thank you
now let me ask uh if i might uh
a question concerning i might ask judge
sessions or mr hubbell either one could
answer this question
back
i understand
attorney general reno declined initially
to approve this gas plan
and that was on the 16th which was a
friday
judge sessions i believe you asked for a
hearing
with
attorney general reno about this
and i understand she then came to mr
hubbell's office
i would like to know maybe what went on
there but i also find it somewhat
not disturbing but just a little out of
protocol that the attorney general of
the united states would be
summoned if you will to come to somebody
else's office and i see mr hubbell and
maybe that relationship existed but i i
didn't know the attorney general went
went to other people's office to discuss
because in fact she was both of your
bosses was she not
at that time
okay and i just wonder why she was
brought down to mr hubbell's office and
in essence what what the conversation
what convinced her
uh to begin to consider the cs gas
uh mr bryant the uh the meeting that
you're discussing
took place at the request of mr hubble
and we came to his office
which is adjoining the attorney
general's office
and after the discussion he announced to
us that she had decided not to
and he said would you like to appeal
and i said yes i would like to talk to
the attorney general
now the reasons for that
i'm sure you're aware
i wanted to be sure that there was no
political objective at all because i
knew that mr hubble was of course
connected with the white house
and the only way i could be sure of that
was by talking to attorney general and
he he asked it himself he said do you
want to appeal
i said i'd like to talk to the attorney
general and she walked across the hall
or down through the conference room and
came directly into his office i don't
think that was in front of the attorney
general i think it was a practical way
to deal with it
and when she came in then we begin those
discussions which continued of course
for a good while but that was the way
that it happened as i recall
exactly
my recollection was that we were meeting
in my office which is actually the
former chief of staff's office which is
just on the other side of where the
attorney general's conference room was
after they said they wanted to talk to
the attorney general i went down and
said they're in my office they would
like to appeal and she just said well
let's go talk to him and knowing the
attorney general's style that
was no affront we didn't summon her to
my office i can assure you that
mr thurman you recognize your guidance
dr salem um in yesterday's hearing there
was some comment made that you had not
published any articles or books on cs
gas would you like to comment on that i
you never got an opportunity to respond
to any of the allegations there thank
you
as i
mentioned yesterday i have done original
work research work and with the
microphone closer to you
i have done original research and
published and respiratory reflexes
respiratory irritants
and i have also
as i mentioned i'm on the
uh editorial board of inhalation
toxicology
i am the
chairman of the technical committee for
the inhalation specialty section for the
society of toxicology
so i have a lot of experience in
reviewing data and published literature
as well as research reports on various
chemicals
both in many fields in the
pharmaceutical field pesticide field
consumer products and this type of
dr salem and and going one step further
then did you feel there was any
misinformation that was given yesterday
that you would like to straighten out
for this panel
would you like to think about it and let
me come back to you thank you very much
jim sessions yesterday during the
testimony mr potts was asked whether on
april 14 letter from koresh which had
been called a surrender offer was passed
on to you he stated that he did pass
that letter on to you mr potts was then
asked whether he knew if you passed that
so-called surrender offer to president
clinton or hearing you mrs i am very
sorry thank you
well
during testimony yesterday mr potts was
asked whether an april 14th letter from
koresh which had been called a surrender
offer was passed on to you he stated
that he did pass that letter on to you
mr potts then asked whether he knew if
you passed that so-called surrender
offer to president clinton or anyone in
the white house can you clear up the
confusion surrounding this issue and
tell this committee a whether the april
14th letter was in fact a surrender
offer rather you forward the april 14th
letter to any linguist or psychologist
for analysis and rather you forwarded
the april 14th letter to anyone in the
white house
uh mrs thurman it may be that mr potts
recalls a surrender letter of april the
14th
i do not recall a surrender letter from
mr korish of that date
was did mr potts indicate that he passed
it on to mr clark or mr clark
uh to me
we'll ask mr potts
actually i don't remember saying i
passed a letter on the director sessions
either uh if i did i
i recall that the information concerning
the april 14th manuscript
was uh passed along from waco
to us to the command center
uh not a surrender letter but an
indication that he was going to work on
the the manuscript now for the seven
seals
that particular document was provided by
our command center in washington
to murray myron dr murray myron for an
out an analysis and i think jeff jamar
testified yesterday as to the results of
of that were essentially that dr myron
said
we don't uh and just i don't see
anything in this letter that would
indicate that he's coming out in the
near future i'm obviously paraphrasing
here
that information about the april 14th
manuscript was passed along
the line
but i don't know whether the letter
itself was or not
mr thurman that is correct okay in terms
of the
some of the contents apparently of the
manuscript i was aware that manuscript
was there but i was not aware of what
you term an offer of surrender
mr clark um it's my understanding that
you accompanied mr potts to waco and met
with on scene commander jamar and other
members of the crisis management team
can you tell us about this meeting
short answer of the line
um
there had been a
series of conversations and
with the department of justice and
inside of the fbi about activities
down in waco representatives from the
department of justice had made a prior
trip
down to waco to
look into a number of matters
coordination issues prosecution issues
and they were going to be making a
second trip
the fbi was invited to go along and
participate in these meetings and larry
potts and i
accompanied mark richard and others from
the department down for that meeting
while we were there we used that
opportunity to also meet with our field
commanders we went and looked at
all of the facilities talked with the
people that were doing the work in the
trenches
we actually got into
vehicles
went to the compound went to the
observation points
developed a
personal sense
of what the conditions were it is one
thing to sit in a command center
or in the environs of washington dc
and see pictures
or have things related to you it's an
entirely different thing to be sitting
in a facility
where people have had to operate for 51
days
you can't begin to imagine the kinds of
stress that
has to be there for these professional
people to endure day in and day out i
think there was some testimony about
that these vehicles provided protection
for the agents that protection was very
limited as we pulled up in front of that
compound and looked at that facility
and peered out that hole of that bradley
vehicle
i've been involved in law enforcement
for 30 years and i've done an awful lot
of firearms training and shooting
at a distance of 75 yards with a
telescopic rifle left-handed with one
eye closed you could put rounds through
that opening in that bradley vehicle
there is no leather upholstery there is
nothing to absorb a round coming into
that vehicle
if a round came into that vehicle it
would ricochet around and everyone in
that vehicle would be at jeopardy those
kinds of dimensions when you go out to
these observation points
300 yards away and you see this building
with not only windows and recessed
shooting positions
but areas where they had cut additional
shooting ports
and you have people looking through
telescopic sites for 24 hours a day
51 days
trying to observe all of the movements
you would occasionally see the glare of
sunlight reflecting off the telescope
sites of rifles from that building you
begin to understand the threat and the
and the danger to the agents that were
there
those are the kinds of things that we
wanted to understand as well as discuss
with those people
not only the sacs who were giving us
this information on a daily basis but
the people that were there working and
trying to understand what their thinking
was
and we came back with a
a renewed understanding
of the issues that were confronting the
people
we spent two days there uh came back and
and made our report
to mr sessions
on the uh on the ninth chairman just
asked me to ask what was the date of
that the 7th and 8th of april thank you
thank you very much mrs thurman i would
like to make everybody aware of the fact
who are up here asking the questions
that director
former director sessions has got to
leave here about 11 or a little before
that this morning so if you have
questions particularly you've got a
burning in your pocket that you want to
direct to him
either do it or let us know about it in
some ways that we might
reorganize the questioning in the
fashion that would allow that to occur
everybody else i think can be with us
throughout whatever the duration of this
panel is
uh with that in mind uh mr shabbat
you're recognized for five minutes thank
you mr chairman before i yield i'd just
like to respond to the gentleman from
new york's comment about the alleged
politicization of these hearings last
week
treasury secretary reuben
called a democrat member of this
committee
and asked him not to ask any questions
that might be embarrassing of the
clinton administration
now i think that is truly uh
politicizing these me these particular
hearings and and was uncalled for
i would like to at this time yield the
balance of my time to the gentleman from
tennessee mr bryant
thank you mr chapman
uh let's mr hobble let me ask you a
question if i could regarding
uh
some testimony that you have given
in may of 1993 which would have been
after
the standoff and after the fire at waco
in may of that year you testified at
your senate confirmation hearing
that you had spoken to the president
president clinton only about a supreme
court nominee
and that was in regard to the question
about doj activities that ruled out
personal contacts with him
uh but the question i think was had you
spoken to him about the department of
justice matters and your testimony at
that time was that i have spoken to him
only about a supreme court nomination
however an ap story of april 3 1993
reported you as saying that you gave the
president updates on the waco situation
in the early days of the crisis
my question is
based on
i know senator bumpers in your
confirmation hearing said you were best
friends with the president and first
lady
based on that relationship i'm wondering
what was the accurate situation in terms
of your communication with the president
regarding waco
with regard to waco i did not
communicate with the president until
after
uh april 19th in any regard stuart
gerson
uh
was the contact with the white house
until attorney general reno
was confirmed
and then the contact we had with the
white house would be through white house
counsel bernie nussbaum vince foster and
occasionally bruce
lindsay so in essence what you're saying
is that your testimony before the senate
committee was was accurate but that the
ap story which said that you had
provided the president with updates in
the early part of the crisis
particularly
uh in the early part of may in the early
part of march
that story
and what it alleges in there is
inaccurate it is inaccurate uh stuart
gerson
i was not even in washington the weekend
that the initial rate occurred
stewart is the one who talked to the
president and continued to do so until
attorney general reno was confirmed
i do believe that
on the sunday before the 19th the
attorney general spoke to the president
i know she did because i was in the room
and that was the only contact with the
president directly
prior to the 19th
and
obviously you had
personal contact with the president
i assume during that period of time due
to your relationship a personal
relationship that's absolutely correct
and the issue of waco did not come up in
any of these uh formats it did not
conditions
let me ask uh another question if i
could regarding the
question that
attorney general reno asked
i think a couple of times in terms of
the date of the 19th of april as to why
now and again director sessions judge
sessions it's good to see you again you
were the director when i was a u.s
attorney and many of you were in the fbi
and mr richard all of you
but why now mr sage testified yesterday
from the fbi that
the
their office their decisions the fbi's
decisions were not driven by fatigue or
frustration i think that was wednesday
he actually said that
but yet in reading
the attorney general's statement that
she gave to the fbi after this she
indicates mr hubble that uh
i'm quoting from the from the 302
statement hubble was convinced from his
conversation with the negotiator i
assume that's mr sage that david koresh
was not coming out quresh had not
fulfilled any of his promises at that
point to do anything he said he would
people were getting tired negotiators
were tired
and
tempers were fraying
at that point
i'm wondering if if this is the
justification the reasoning why
the fbi and i've heard child abuse but
you know those allegations have been
going on for years
and i've heard now health and sanitary
conditions which you know while that's
significant i can't imagine that being a
real reason to go in with the type of
force that they did it sounds like
something we thought of afterwards
and i've heard of the fact that maybe
negotiations had broken down and those
kind of things but
but i'm like the attorney general why
not wait and i i have some concern about
maybe it was as as you said mr clark and
i respect your opinion and your your
experience and the fbi but things were
stressful and i understand that i
appreciate that fact i'm not criticizing
it but when you look at all the factors
together why
was was that factor the fatigue
the stress the fraying
uh nerves the the temper even like i
said temperature frame
it was that the primary driving force
for that
decision being made bryant so far as i
can tell you've heard the earlier
reference to the quality of the hostage
rescue team
and its capabilities
there was discussion at that time
about their coming to the edge and
needing to go back retrain and to do
those things which kept them in the
state of preparedness the things they do
require practice and require constant
attention to it and that was one of the
factors
obviously fatigue on all those people
was very great
so there were a number of things that
were discussed about what was the
situation there at the time
and it was discussed on a continuing
basis
with certainly within the fbi and so far
as i know and believe with the attorney
general she was aware of those things
but anyway i think i've gotten one other
person one other person might ask
richard
thank you congressman brian
as i recall the question of why now uh
rose um
uh subsequent to the initial briefing of
the attorney general on i believe april
12
during a meeting after the briefing by
the fbi which was held in the attorney
general's office
and
it was a question
that we discussed what has changed
that would
suggest that we must move now
i think that was a question on the table
for several days uh and i i can't speak
for the attorney general in her thought
processes
but certainly i began to answer the
question for myself after um
participating in the uh discussion with
the
fbi negotiator sage
and
realized that
negotiations at least as uh uh viewed by
the fbi were now fruitless uh there was
an anticipation that they would not be
productive
uh and this did suggest that uh uh our
options were severely uh constricted but
that those are my views and i can't
speak for the attorney general
thank you mr bryant mr scott you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you um
thank you mr chairman
judge
sessoms over the weekend senator bradley
on a
morning
news show
related the story about an
african-american harvard law student who
was stopped
and
handcuffed for no apparent reason
he was released after he convinced the
police officers that he was a harvard
law student and wasn't doing anything
wrong
you're aware that the exclusionary rule
protects innocent people from these
kinds of indignities and i'm sure you're
aware of other examples because it
removes
all incentives that a law enforcement
officer may have to break the law
because if he stops someone without
probable cause without a warrant
he knows that he can't use whatever
evidence he may pick up
thus far in these hearings we've heard
that the exclusionary rule is the only
effective tool to deal with police
misconduct
and virtually the only forum in which
you can even discuss it we've heard from
law enforcement officers that they don't
need
relief from their duty to obey the law
they don't need to make illegal searches
and they don't need a watered down
exclusionary rule in order to perform
their duties
mr sessoms do you see any reason that
the exclusionary rules should be watered
down further to excuse and encourage
police misconduct
mr scott i heard the statements
that were made by the senator and i of
course had very direct contact for many
many years
with fourth amendment rights and the
exclusionary rule
and the impact on law enforcement
i can remember back in the 1960s
when messiah and escobedo and miranda
those great cases which established
constitutional principles were hammered
out
and what we found was that law
enforcement reacted positively
law enforcement react enough in a
fashion to make it even more competent
and make it more professional in every
respect to be able to abide the law and
to
perform their activities under the
constitution this is critical
law enforcement can meet that standard
and should be required to meet that
standard and it should be part and
parcel of everything they carry with
them
to not have to have a good faith
exception to not have to have an
exception in any way that would require
them to lessen their standard of
professionalism
so i believe very strongly
that the fourth amendment is what it
says
and that in fact we should not weaken it
and that we should bring up our law
enforcement standards to make the
highest standard that's required by the
constitution the law
thank you uh mr hubbell
earlier in these hearings we heard from
mr noble and mr maga
it's
clear from their testimony that the
atf ambush was the fault of
david koresh and and some of his
followers
but they also went to great lengths to
point out that mistakes had been made
and if they had to do it over again
they had pinpointed mistakes that they'd
made and there we have a
level of comfort that if they had to do
it again the chances that four law
enforcement officers would be killed in
the process is greatly diminished
mr
we heard earlier
that
we knew that there was a chance when we
went in the children would die as a
result of the
final in invasion
you saw what happened
what did you think would happen
and can we give the american public some
level of comfort that children don't
have to die when you're trying to
execute an arrest warrant and a search
warrant
if you're talking about the 19th i i
don't think there's a person on this
panel
that uh hasn't gone over
what we would do again if we we had to
do it over again the 19th is the final
the 19th is the final final
we were not involved in the initial
atf
service of the warrant i'm not that
familiar with what happened
i am aware that we had great concerns
because
there was a leak to the press
and ultimately a leak to to
to vernon howe or david koresh
but
certainly if we knew what we knew
was going to happen we would
try to find another way and we think
about it i know i do every day
mr um salem
it's my understanding that you if
children are exposed to cs gas that they
will be very much traumatized it's also
my
understanding that you have no citation
of any medical implications that would
last more than 30 days for someone
expo for a child exposed to
cs gas
even though the gas is used in a
widespread basis over many years
is that is that accurate
i'm sorry is that an accurate statement
yes sir uh your expect your expertise is
in physical irritation do you have any
expertise in the psychological reaction
to the gas so they know so that you
would be able to predict what someone
would do that is not your experience
uh is there anything else you wanted to
add in response to the question from the
gentlelady from florida and uh response
to misstatements that were made yes i
was hoping that she would be here can we
wait until she gets back or
she will um
she's probably looking at it on the
monitor so
okay some of the things that i would
like to
mention
uh
these hearings are in search of the
truth and the facts i can't recall from
yesterday's meeting about the
misinformation but
some of the
information that i heard from the
previous evening on the effects of
cs which i'd like to clarify
uh first of all i'd like to say that it
is the safest and most effective
alternative that we do know of
and i concur completely with what the
british expert said on the cs
the causes of
the reports that deaths have occurred
following the use of cs
on investigation
the facts show that other materials were
used
for
example
in one case that was mentioned
cn was used in combination with cs and
we know that deaths have occurred from
the use of cn
in that same case
uh when that case came to trial the
conclusion was that they felt that the
individual who died was actually
suffocated
uh in another case where they talked
about the deaths following cs
in the west bank
in israel
the gao did a report to congressman
dellums back in 1988
i believe it was
physicians for human rights
went there to do the investigation and
they could not find any confirmed deaths
following use
due to cs nor any miscarriages that were
reported
uh the gao said that perhaps there were
four deaths but that was due to tear gas
and they didn't specify which one it was
and then there's uh another report from
the director of the palestine
human rights campaign
who concluded that israel used two types
of riot control agents
cn and cs but they generally used cn
uh
the other
fact that i heard that occurred the
other night was that suffocation was
caused by the dust settling
these are very small
particulates and if they subtly settle
because these particles agglomerate
become bigger and then fall to the
ground they don't hover just above the
surface
the more more realistic
happening is probably that these
particles were blown out by the wind and
the circulation
we've heard that the
lungs blister following the use of cs cs
is an irritant
it causes
irritation and inflammation and possibly
pulmonary edema may result
however
in my experience i have not seen where
lungs actually blister internally
uh the other fact i'd like to clarify as
that is that children
are more likely to have a greater
capacity to breathe cs yes their
respiratory rate is higher than it is in
adults however as you inhale you also
exhale and as the if the particles don't
impact on the respiratory tract some of
them are blown out so if you're
breathing faster you're probably
breathing out
more of it the other important factor is
not the breathing rate but it's the
minute volume which is the volume times
the rate of breathing and children have
a smaller minute volume than adult
student
so that
they would probably breathe in less
thank you mr scott your time has expired
mr zelloff you're recognized for five
minutes thank you mr chairman uh
dr salem just a quick yes or no answer
uh is cs gas safer than waiting
is cs gas safer than waiting
that's okay
it depends on the definition of waiting
what would occur then okay thank you
mr sessions um
you were
the head of the fbi for both events that
took place on the 28th of february as
well as the 19th of april
that's correct
and uh
tell me about
your involvement with the gas plan
when it was it was presented initially
by the fbi internally from the bottom up
i guess dated march 27th at what point
did you connect at what point did you
get involved and what time at what point
did you make your decision when you
thought it was a good idea i don't
recall the precise date that came to me
mr zelda but it came
as an alternative possibility
uh you'll recall you
were mentioning back both at the first
date and the last eight
you'll remember that on february 16th
the world trade center went up
and on february 18th atf uh went into
the compound
with the resultant death from that point
on there were constant discussions about
things that could be done to bring it to
a conclusion
most most particularly
that related to negotiation and trying
to find ways that it could actually be
negotiated down and out right and some
of those some of those plans were
labeled as ridiculous
some of them were labeled as not
practical but they though we were
discussing all these people including
ultimately the use of gas who brought it
to you
i would presume that it came either
through mr potts or through mr
uh i do not recall precisely we met
repeatedly in the command center
and in the fbi daily so that uh for
precisely it came where precisely it was
first discussed i don't recall thank you
mr sessions um fbi agent smart
testified here under oath that he
changed his thinking
he changed his judgment
in a fifth and final memo and
based on the sense that he needed to
please you i believe this last memo was
april 9th and he he went from favoring
negotiation to shifting away
uh from negotiation to
to the gas plan just give me your
comment on
i mean is this i would have to
i had a real problem with that myself i
well i do not know that that's what he
said if he said it was to please me that
is one thing i don't know that he said
that okay if he said it was to please
others within the bureau that might well
have been my own belief stems from back
dealing with the the riots at oakdale
and atlanta and talladega and all these
things that we've we've dealt with
and patience
and and waiting as you mentioned is a
very important factor i can remember
mike quinlan the the director of the
bureau of prisons saying that he will
wait forever but negotiation
is an important part of it and you push
that uh i pushed it both personally
individually in discussions every time
we turn it around and in terms of the
actual operation on the ground just to
be clear in no way did you get mr uh
smarrick to change his writing of his
memo change his thinking so i would
agree with yours that could that could
not be well if he said that he believed
in continuing negotiation and work at
negotiation then he would reflect my
views he did not write that memo to
please me now there may have been others
that he did but certainly not me uh mr
sessions did you know that the texas
rangers and korash's lawyers had brought
to mr jamar's attention surrender plan
that they worked out with koresh on
april 14th
and uh
don't you think you should have known
about that plan did you know about that
plan uh are you referring to the the uh
the plan that relates to his writing on
the seven seals that's correct and the
completion of that i was aware of that
yes i was not aware you somebody phrased
it a surrender plan uh he had talked
many times about coming out we had
brought out many many people from the
beginning then those people stopped
coming
and there was there was a great
difficulty in relying on anything he
said but i was aware of course
that is that the lawyer was in the
compound this again was an effort to be
sure that we left no stone unturned to
bring those people out alive okay and
and uh the next day he spoke to you mr
hubble for two hours uh what did he tell
you about the surrender plan
or or the whatever kind of plan you want
to call it i don't know who i learned uh
about the fact that uh
vernon howell or david koresh
was saying that after he interpreted the
seven seals and wrote about the seven
seals that he was willing to come out i
don't know who told me that whether it
was
first heard from mr clark or mr potts or
mr sage or
there were constant discussions going on
i was aware that that was the latest
uh
discussion that was being had with the
people inside the camp compound
i can't tell you precisely when i
learned it but i was aware of it you
there there's three or four things that
are missing that you could be personally
helpful for
with us we're missing some of your
telephone logs particularly april
uh 17th 18th and 19th and our problem is
is that they've all been redacted
um and is there any chance that we could
get those um
and and then there's testimony in the
white water hearing that you kept
certain files in your basement
additionally the department of justice
has told you that you kept separate waco
files did you ever or did you know
if you have waco files in your basement
or in your possession anywhere that
could be helpful and could we get some
information on filling in these three
vital days that i mean what's happened
to us and trying to bring this
information out uh this is important for
us uh the the the missing tape uh on
february uh 28 is very important to us
uh that that atf doesn't have they got
all the rest but that one's missing i
mean there's just some of this stuff
that would be vital in terms of letting
us try to figure this all out can you be
helpful on this i can't be helpful
nobody's ever asked me but i have a copy
of these same logs and you're welcome to
them as far as i'm concerned
uh except i i have to tell you the 17th
and 18th
were saturday and sunday and so
therefore there wouldn't be any these
are basically logs of people who called
and left a message for me to call them
back
not not necessarily everybody i talked
to primarily what we're looking for is
any discussions you had prior to the
19th obviously in those three days
relative to anybody whether it be the
president whether it be
fbi or anybody else i have no trouble
giving you my logs for
for those days
thank you mr schumer your time is i mean
mr cell if your time has expired mr
schumer i'm going to recognize you
ahead a little bit there mr schumer
you're recognized
quit while you're ahead um
thank you mr chairman and uh i would
like to direct a few questions to you mr
hubble
aimed at what i consider the
charitably fishing expedition parts of
the allegations out there more like a
witch hunt i want to put to rest some
things because they're all sorts of
again conspiracy theories some
politically motivated to tie the
president or the white house
into pushing ahead
the formula for going in
uh prematurely for some for nefarious
reasons some because the president saw
it was day 49 day 50 day 51 and he was
anxious to get it over with
all of this in my i have not seen one
scrap of evidence one scrap
that indicates that so i want to ask you
clearly
mr hubble
did president clinton
convey to you in any way shape or form
that he wanted the siege at the branch
davidian compound ended
and to you
and that you or attorney general reno
should make that end happen in other
words ended before
she or the justice department officials
thought it was appropriate in other
words did the president impose pressure
on the decision-making process
about waco
yes or no no he did not either directly
or indirectly any at all anything that
might be even interpreted as that no he
didn't no winks of an eye or shimmy of
the hips or anything like that
no he did not okay let me ask you this
did you
now we've talked about the president did
you
convey on your own
now you were a justice but you're a good
friend of the president so maybe that
implicates him somehow so did you convey
on your own any desire to get the siege
at waco over in other words did you
pressure the attorney general to
prematurely move up the decision no i
did not and are you aware of any
official at the white house
who
would prima would pressure the attorney
general or the justice department to
move up that decision before it was
right before it was ready to happen no
they did not i am confident no one at
the white house attempted in any way to
influence the decision of the attorney
general okay now i would we have four
other jeff
four other gentlemen here who are at the
top levels of the fbi in the high
command of the decision-making process i
would like to ask each of the other
gentlemen the same question did
president clinton
or any other high official in the white
house pressure you gentlemen to make a
decision to move in before you thought
it was appropriate you could please
answer yes or no judge sessions mr
schumer i had no contact in the white
house at all
mr potts uh no sir
mr richard
mr clark
okay now i know what's going to happen
here
you're going to get lots of nitpicking
they're going to say phone logs they're
going to say some you know this or that
or the other thing
and make little implications that sort
of hang out there
with no factual basis
but again
please search your memories do any of
you
the people at the highest levels of
justice with the exception of the
attorney general and i'll ask her the
same question
have any feeling at all even a feeling
that happened to pop into your head
that the white house that president
clinton pushed you into making a
decision you didn't want to make
please just answer again no says mr
hubble no no says judge sessions
no shakes his head mr potts no sir no
says mr richard absolutely and
absolutely not says mr clark
you guys have
for one point of time i'm
out of questions here uh
gosh
no it's too precious
um
i think i will
in the interest of moving things ahead i
will yield back my time
well i've already recognized mr zelloff
who's next ileana ross layton mr miss
leighton
commander
mr hubbell
uh
i was in the process i we talked about
the phone logs and we appreciate it we
could get those fairly quick that would
be helpful if you would just have a
member of your staff let me know who
thank you
uh actually bobby charles would be good
and um the other thing is is that we
talked about
um relative to the white water hearing
uh that you kept files in your basement
and other places additionally department
of justice has told us that you keep
separate waco files
is there any chance that we could have
access to some of them
you can have access to any files that i
have
congressman i do have my own set of waco
files
and you're welcome to them or copies of
them
uh i thank you okay that's great um
let me let me ask you in in terms of the
gas plan yourself
when did you make your mind up that you
felt that this was a good plan
i was
we were discussing it up until the
saturday that the attorney general made
the final decision
there it was a very difficult
difficult decision to make
[Music]
we went through every option imaginable
even some crazy ones that i had
but uh
so i i probably made up my mind about
the same time the attorney general did
on on saturday
uh
although i i admit that
on that set i think it was saturday or
maybe friday
uh the decision was no go
uh
even even that late
what what pushed you over what what made
you what made it happen in your
mind i think it's a combination of
factors i think
uh the evaluation done by the military
of the plan what did the military say
military military evaluated the plan in
at length in front of the attorney
general and myself and others
and as well as floyd and others
and
and judge sessions
they only had one
slight disagreement uh with the plan
that was that they would go in
with the gas totally at first as opposed
to a partial insertion into one area i
believe they felt like that you should
go in totally all at once they also said
that their experience they weren't
limited by the rules of engagement that
the fbi had that they might were the
rules of engagement by the fbi what were
they yes they were that they would not
shoot unless someone's life was
endangered
and and uh
and the military would have done what
else that they probably would have taken
korres out
they didn't say that directly but you
certainly had that impression if if they
were on foreign soil and these people
were being held as hostage so on foreign
soil
uh we would have taken taking them out
i think you really need to ask the
military but i think that would be
something that they would certainly they
would have gone in and got rid of the
place real quick i mean that's kind of a
quick summation isn't it
i i i think you really that's a quick
summation of a long day
well
i guess the problem that i have is what
pushed you over what when did you make
the decision was it the military's
recommendations that pushed you over
i think it was a combination of what
pushed us all over it was not only the
military
saying that the plan was a good plan and
it would work
the military said
they will come out of that building i
mean i i looked i had a general and a
colonel
uh both look me in the eye and say they
can't stay in that building they will
come out immediately
uh that was part of it part of it was
the the factor that
uh
in the near future it was likely that we
would have to change the deployment of
the hostage rescue team not not
immediately but in the near future the
factor of that there were people trying
to get still try to get into the
compound and there was danger to the fbi
agents that was a factor let me ask you
one other question and i have one from
mr sessions
do you know whether there's any document
or conversation that would indicate to
the white house and not the attorney
general
would be the final entity that approved
any significant decision at waco
including the cs gas decision i have no
such document
mr i'm not aware of any document like
that no nothing at all that said the
president would have the final decision
uh nothing would be done
uh
you know without his without his
approval you know no documents no
document like that at all okay and and
and mr sessions same kind of questions
if you would
what what when did you make up your mind
that the gas plan is a good idea and and
what put you over the edge
probably not a good
craze to use but
what made what made you come to grips
with this is the right thing to do well
the whole plan was to be able to extract
those people and have them come out
safely
everybody's mind was the same on that
point the question was how to do it and
how to work it and you know and you can
see
that there was a constantly tightening
ring around that group
and the insertion of the gas
on the ends of the compounds was
perceived as a means by which you could
get them constricted even further and
ultimately they would know that they
were simply going to have to come out
but it was not an environment where they
could actually continue to live you'll
have to remember people had long since
ceased coming out and mr koresha no
longer allowed people to come out and
that's
i can see the chairman's getting nervous
with the flipper your time has expired
i'm not getting that nervous uh mr watt
you're recognized for five minutes thank
you mr chairman um and i thank these
members of the panel for being here
today um
to the extent that
[Music]
i have felt that these hearings have
served any useful or valuable
purpose i have tried to
do it in the context of what kind of
perspective
guidance
[Music]
what has happened in the past might
provide to us rather than
making an effort to
second-guess each and every aspect
[Music]
and we've
succeeded particularly mr scott and i in
[Music]
getting
some
educational benefit and perspective
value placed on
[Music]
personal and civil rights and
the value of the exclusionary rule and
the
fourth amendment rights that are
protected
um
and i think
some concessions have been made that the
atf probably
stepped across some lines
or were very close to lines in those
areas and and that there are some things
that we might be able to do
in the future
to
better safeguard individual rights and
and liberties
and i spent some time asking secretary
benson
about the
administrative
supervisory chain of command
guidelines and and
what
knowledge that this incident might bring
to bear on changes and i understand that
some administrative changes have been
made
to try to improve the supervisory lines
i'm interested particularly from judge
sessoms
and i think i may have asked this
question to mr potts on a prior panel so
i won't
[Music]
ask him to address it again but
i'm especially interested in
in
what kind of lessons
informed by what transpired at waco
what kind of changes
[Music]
you think need to be made
whether they have or have not been made
in the administrative
uh functionings uh that
the decision-making processes that lead
to to the decisions
in these kind of
settings such as waco
and whether there are any
uh personal rights individual
lessons individual rights lessons that
that you might bring to bear
and whether they are any other
other than individual
and administrative
lessons that we might gain from from
waco
my effort being to try to use this as
something to inform us to be a better
nation in the future rather than
simply trying to second guess
on monday morning the plays that took
place
on that
fateful day
mr watt in responding to mr scott's
question
i made it very clear about my strong
feeling that's compatible with what
you've expressed that is the certainty
that the fourth amendment of the
constitution the united states remain
intact
and in fact we do those things which are
compatible with being sure that it does
that means training that means
professionalism that means taking those
things which will assure
that all law enforcement people
understand the importance of those
rights and that right
patience is probably the greatest virtue
you could have in connection with this
kind of circumstance
i mentioned the circumstances that
oakdale louisiana when that prison had
the riots in atlanta when it had the
riots at talladega when it had the riots
everywhere we've been it's important to
have patience but also to negotiate
and to not leave unturned any possible
negotiating possibility and there were
negotiating possibilities from the
beginning down in waco everybody knows
that i had contact directly from people
associated with mr koresh
about the possibility of my going down
and negotiating with them
coming in down there now some people
played that as ridiculous and ridiculed
or as grandstanding but it's indicative
of what i felt and continue to feel you
can't discard any possibility
that you can resolve that kind of
circumstance
when you can take and apply
that negotiating capability so the
negotiation is obviously very very
important
pressure which is what you've seen
demonstrated so repeatedly in connection
with waco
is also important so pressure
negotiating and patience
are those three things now
administratively to translate those into
an active and effective function you
have to have continual negotiation you
have to have continual discussion and in
fact we had that day in and day out and
it went as high as the attorney general
where it went from there i do not know
but the point is that those elements
were there
i do not believe
that we were served well
by discarding any of those negotiating
possibilities
acting attorney general gerson discarded
those as being not appropriate for the
director to become involved in i can
understand why not you don't want any
person who is barricaded to know that
they can trigger
the arrival of the director of the fbi
to do that and yet this was no normal
circumstance this had the same
approximate number of people that were
captive down in atlanta
and there again the point was patience
and negotiate endlessly keep after it
and patiently keep after it it is
important before my time expires
secretary benson testified at the
hearings here about some administrative
chain of command changes that have been
made
to
to bring a closer level of supervision
from the department of treasury over
the atf agents are you familiar with
those and
do you care to comment on on whether
the
[Music]
chain of command was clear enough
in atf
to treasury
and the changes that took place in
response uh mr watt i am not familiar
with what secretary benson discussed or
the chain of command of bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms i am clear
on the chain of command within the
bureau
and know that it functions and functions
well you always have to have a clear
line channel and a willingness to
actually report those things are
happening and
it's very clear that that you must have
it and so atf would be well advised to
do whatever is necessary to get it if
they don't have it
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr white mr schiff you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman i would like to
yield all of my time to chairman zelif
please
thank you
um
i want to go back to you mr hubble if
you could uh we talked about uh written
correspondence any conversations verbal
written or verbal any discussions
anything you can remember
from february 28 to april 19th
indicating that the president had an
interest in being involved in what's
going on
any changes to the negotiation process
anything that you can remember
relative to
all the things that were happening from
february 28 to april 19.
i was aware chairman that the president
wanted to be advised if there was any
change
in the posture and wake up
from the
the decision to negotiate
uh and therefore when
the decision to insert the gas although
considered by some to be continued
negotiations we felt like we needed to
advise the president of the insertion of
the gap so if i understand you correctly
he wanted to be involved he wanted to
know if anything changed from the
negotiation process
and
whether it was you or mr lindsay mr
nussbaum mr mccarty or others um however
he got all that information formally or
informally uh he wanted to be included
in the loop am i correct
i was told by attorney general gerson
that he wanted the president wanted to
be advised if there was going to be in
any change right is that am i right and
and understanding then that
he wanted to be involved in the
decision-making process
i didn't consider it that i think he
wanted to be advised
if there was going to be a change and we
did so sounds like mr altman's letter to
mr benson
you know he wrote on april 15th that
something tragic was going to happen on
the 19th and we ought to you know in his
judgment somebody ought to stop it mr
benson said well that was the fbi's
problem that shifts me over to you mr
sessions are you
are you the guy that
really i mean you know bring it on down
if gina reno wanted to she can just say
well i was just following mr sessions
recommendation i mean at what point do
we assign responsibility for this thing
well you can assign it wherever you feel
it's appropriate mr chairman but the
discussions
uh with the attorney general were very
complete and she was very very
interested in every single phase and
step of it and question
how the decisions were made
she was particularly concerned about
children and that we all know that she
was concerned that if
i think i heard it discussed somewhere
that if a child was held up in a window
that anything that was being done should
immediately be stopped if there was any
indication of the child being endangered
she was very interested all the way
along i you can assign it where you want
my responsibility was to direct the fbi
the attorney general of course is the is
the director overseer of the director of
the fbi
but but you were the director of the fbi
that's right certainly as far as the fbi
is concerned in the plan itself you had
to be part of that responsibility that
is correct and then she at her level had
to be part of that responsibility that's
correct and probably someone above her
had to be part of that responsibility i
think that i think the attorney general
has the full authority to do exactly
what she did that is to to
approve and and and order
and direct me to proceed with the the
plan that had been presented to her
uh dr salem you mentioned uh
that the gao report on cs gas available
long before waco of course and and you
showed it
uh as one example that the cs gas was
not harmful
uh are you aware the state department
disagreed with you and let me just read
and insert this in the record if i can
as a chairman
according this is a
gao report
and that's
dated
april of 1989
according to state's human rights report
to congress figures compiled from press
palestinian and israeli government
sources indicate that 366 palestinians
were killed in 1988 as a result of the
uprising while exact figures are
unavailable and estimates vary state
department reported that at least four
deaths resulted from tear gas used by
the idf uh the israeli defense forces in
the enclosed areas
um
you are aware yes sir i stated that i
believe in my remarks that
there were four deaths
attributed to tear gas but they didn't
specify that that was cs
and the other report
said that the israelis were using both
cn and cs
okay so it was inconclusive at least
i can say that there's inconclusive
evidence but there's certainly some
evidence whether it was conclusive or
not that it could be harmful
uh yes sir okay and and also in in the
uh ruby ridge uh marshall's log
um and again i'd just like to bring this
up maybe mr potts would would comment on
this again
um they indicated we inserted in the
record yesterday
that the use of
cs gas would be harmful to children
particularly children
and uh
and i believe mr potts indicated that
that
they did not feel that this was credible
i guess my same question there uh
credible or not it certainly indicates
that there's a potential harm to
children
mr potts yes sir right and also dr salem
if you would afterwards all chemicals
are potentially harmful it depends on
the amount and the way it's used sir
okay mr potts yes sir a couple of things
one i understand that the marshal
out in idaho at that time has indicated
that he called that back and that
that's good judgment i guess
did you do you feel that was good
judgment
did he call it back
that's yes sir that's fine but he
indicated that he did not indicate that
it was a high risk that this is that
this that's not an accurate excuse me
reflect so on
he changed his mind
no sir he just indicated that's not that
he did not say it was a high risk he did
indicated that that it was a risk to
children
sir i think it's also important to note
in that in that log that it doesn't say
cs gas
it just says gas
uh
i understand i was i was not on the site
there but i understand that there were
other
types of gases that were discussed out
there now i can't tell you that this
that this comment does or does not refer
to cs but there were other types of gas
that were discussed
at ruby ridge
other than cs mr zelle if your time is
up mr conyers you're recognized for five
minutes
thank you mr chairman and uh
gentlemen
the question has been
raised more than once across the years
that alcohol tobacco and firearms
ought to be
folded into the federal bureau of
investigation
can i get a first of all can i find out
if there's anybody that's open to that
suggestion
on the panel mr clark mr richard mr
potts mr hubble judge
sessions okay uh
then who
did a two opens
uh mr clark you're open to that would
you give me a brief comment well
i think it it can't be a simple answer
whether you're open to it or not i do
think that there are issues of
coordination within federal law
enforcement
and that is an option but i think those
areas are viable discussion topics so i
i think those areas are open for
discussion what's your case
for after we open the discussion and
become viable
then we say let's put
the firearms responsibility of atf into
the fbi where do you come down there
well i think my concerns are a little
bit different than just where you place
the responsibility my concerns are
things like attorney general guidelines
for undercover operations
attorney general guidelines for the use
of title threes those kinds of things
vary from law enforcement agency to law
enforcement agency and i think that
there is a need for continuity in the
way that the federal government
exercises it's federal law enforcement
responsibility however that is done
uh i'm open to discussion consolidating
functions and responsibilities certainly
is one option well bringing them all
together it seems to me would increase
the likelihood of continuity
deputy assistant attorney general
richard uh
could you give me a brief observation on
this please yes and i i'll be only uh
speaking
on a personal basis because i
i don't uh necessarily reflect the views
of the department uh frankly uh
congressman i believe it's imperative
that uh
the attorney general be recognized not
just in name but in function as the
chief law enforcement officer
over all law enforcement agencies and in
that capacity have the ability
to ensure uniformity of procedures
and adequate coordination of all uh
functions to avoid inefficiencies
duplication uh and problems uh with
respect to uh
processes of critical importance uh so i
agree uh
that there is much that can be done but
on the other hand to bring the entire
agency within the department uh in the
context of you're suggesting i suspect
may be inappropriate given their vast
regulatory and administrative
responsibilities that
are also assigned to atf
uh judge sessions mr conyers there are
several aspects to that
that could take us many days to discuss
but briefly
two things have to be considered and
that is the gathering of a great deal of
law enforcement power
into one agency
there was discussion almost immediately
after the raid by atf
that they ought to be incorporated into
the fbi and i remember i i thought it
was almost uh accomplished it was one
time i was waiting for the press release
it was rife all over this town
the gathering of that powerhouse very
however is very difficult if you look at
what can happen
right now their responsibility is over
an area that is highly political
the bureau tries to maintain itself
apolitically and certainly i tried to
the best of my ability to keep political
considerations out of the bureau's
business
if you actually incorporate that atf
function into the department of justice
with all of the political concerns it
has and you have a political attorney
general who is a member of the cabinet
you have some problems that you might
not be able to deal with effectively
and to boot
you've got the problem of gathering so
much power into the fbi and i think
that's these will be looked at very very
carefully
well i i'll be cautious as we continue
to look at it but
you know examine with me the fact that
the attorney general
already has uh
95 of all law enforcement power in the
country anyway
and is attacked politically on a very
regular basis
so
you know what's new uh that that's
that's the way this business goes down
what i what i want to do
is stop having all of the fights that go
on between law enforcement agencies drug
enforcement agency
the
fbi
uh the secret service sometimes
ins all have
legal capacities that unless they're
really regulated
by
one central authority i think we have a
a problem
now
let me go on to the the question about
the president's involvement mr hubbell
was the president's
decision
to leave this to the experts and that he
wanted to be consulted or was he
involved in making the decisions to what
extent
where does the line come down in that
area it's my understanding that the
president wanted to be advised
if the strategy from pure negotiation
changed and the attorney general did
that
in a conversation on the 18th
and i kept the white house counsels
advised as
the week prior to that about the
possibility of the plan
uh i am not aware that the president
ever said i want to be involved in the
decision or that i have some ideas about
this he wanted to be advised finally uh
how come everybody here is for the
fourth amendment and exclusionary rule
and the administration isn't
can you explain that to me
i mean i i have
i have all of these great protestations
of support for for a constitutional
process
and and then when we get to the
administration
and the attorney general
uh we we
we have two sets of testimony here uh
uh you can only speak for yourselves but
we're having some serious erosions of
the exclusionary rule in the
anti-terrorism legislation
and
what does it mean we have everybody here
there hadn't been one witness
during these five or six days
that uh wasn't for strengthening the
exclusionary rule the attorneys the
government
all witnesses
but so so what what what does that leave
us with mr richard mr kanye's can i
respond and and take exception to at
least the portion of uh your remark and
that is
this this attorney general is department
of justice is very much committed to
defense of fourth amendment liberties
our positions as reflected in the
anti-terrorism bill and the like uh in
our judgment are consistent with with
fourth amendment obligations uh and we
strongly endorse eroding the
exclusionary rule is not consistent with
supporting the fourth amendment as you
know the the administration uh and the
department of justice has has a variety
of concerns in this area and has
expressed it during the course of this
legislation but i'm just suggesting that
with respect to other aspects that are
in the anti-terrorism bill and the like
uh
we do believe that they are consistent
and supportive of our concerns
regardless i'd like to just show you
some of the uh testimony that we've had
here that that i'm not
putting words in anybody's mouth or
making up anything
this is a very serious problem a
division of position within this
administration
that the at least we should do is
acknowledge the positions that are are
at opposition within the administration
and
and i'm putting nothing in anybody's
mouth that's what i'm trying to solve as
a matter of fact
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
conyers mr kobo you're recognized for
five minutes i'm not going to use them
all my time gentlemen good to have you
all here with us i want to just make a
brief statement chairman some folks have
questioned whether or not these hearings
have been useful and valuable
well use and value may be subject to
interpretation but i think there's no
doubt mr chairman that these hearings
will have been determined to have served
a good and useful purpose
now having said that mr chairman
mr chairman i think uh you have
questions you wanted to pursue so having
said that i will yield the balance of my
time to you thank you very much mr koble
uh mr hubbell a few minutes ago you
responded by saying it that in the
meeting with the military which i
believe took place in the 14th of april
with the attorney general that they
indicated or said very strongly that
they believed that if the tear gas the
cs gas was inserted that the people
would come out i mean you made that a
very forceful statement is that correct
that is correct did you know at that
time were you aware at that time that
the davidians in the compound had gas
masks
i believe we were aware they had gas
masks yes we assumed they had gas plants
and the military said they'd come out
anyway yes they did all right
were you aware of something that came up
yesterday mr jamar told us in testimony
yesterday that he was 99
certain in his own mind
that if these
cvs went up with the gas to insert it
that they would be fired upon and that
the plan called for the acceleration of
the gas
and not just over a lengthy period of
time at that juncture
and
in response to my question
to mr potts about that he indicated
yesterday he was unaware
of mr jamar's feelings about this
unaware that
that this was a likelihood and obviously
the
clear implication of that is that
probably you would accelerate that the
idea of a long extended period of
inserting this gas would not take place
were you aware uh through any source
obviously not mr potts that mr jamar
felt that there would be
a 99 likelihood that these vehicles
would be fired upon and that the
insertion of that gas would have to come
in an accelerated fashion
i was not aware that mr jamar felt like
there was a 99 chance it would happen i
think certainly
at least i did and i believe others did
believe that that was a possibility
because they prepared for that
contingency
saying that if it did happen they were
going to accelerate i understand that
but if you knew that it was going to
happen in all probability as supposing
to just a possibility would that have
affected your recommendation your
thoughts your discussions with the
attorney general or do you believe it
would have affected anybody else's
who met with her
with regard to this in the final day or
two
i i i believe it was being considered
during that entire time that that was i
believed
a likelihood that the the vehicles would
be fired upon
when they attempted to insert the gas
so i i believe that that was not only a
likelihood but was had to be taken into
consideration
as everybody made their individual
decisions let me ask you one other
question you talked to mr sage
on the telephone on a two-hour
conference call on april 15th the day
after this meeting with the military
according to the justice department
report
it also according to that report you
talked with him because the attorney
general asked you to
get more information i presume is that
not true
that is correct the attorney general
wanted me to talk personally with the
head negotiator
to go over everything that had happened
to get his opinion of whether koresh was
going to come out and anytime soon
whether he could be negotiated out and
what had happened and what what his
prediction was going to happen and what
did mr sage in general terms in two
hours say to you in general terms that
the negotiations had failed that he
could not negotiate
vernon howe david koresh out of the
building
or anyone else that the only people who
had left that building left because
david koresh wanted them to
did mr sage at any time during that
conversation mention the names
uh to you of daguerreon zimmerman or
arnold we did discuss
i can't tell you with the first time i
learned
i i think i knew before that
about the attorneys
uh but we did discuss
uh the attorneys uh the seven seals with
mr sage well what i want to know is did
he at any time say that mr degaran with
the help of religion experts was working
on a new approach with quresh that might
be fruitful
and that that approach was one which
involved the persuasion of quresh to
come out because
de garin believed that quresh uh had now
become convinced he was a messenger of
god rather than to be a martyr under the
seven seals and that indeed if uh given
about ten days in time de garan was
absolutely convinced
that koresh would indeed come out did
that explicitly get conveyed to you by
mr sage
he conveyed to me the conversations with
mr degaran
he did not convey to me that he thought
the plan would work
in fact he
indicated to me that it wouldn't that
the attorneys were being manipulated by
mr correct
he indicated they were being manipulated
by correction that therefore he did he
convey to you though the concept that
the attorneys presented
that the idea that
koresh
was now viewing himself as the messenger
rather than the martyr and that that was
a very important thing in the view of
the attorneys
as a big change in quresh and their
rationale for why koresh now they
believed would come out because he had
had a change of perspective under his
interpretation of these seals
did you get into that kind of detail i
got into a lot of detail but i certainly
didn't understand what you just said to
be the case i understood based on my
conversation with mr sage and i can't
recall everything that was said
that mr koresh was manipulating the
attorneys
to buy more time and that he wasn't
going to come out i don't i did not ever
get the impression that there had been a
shift in mr karesh's view of himself
at all thank you very much uh
am i who am i going to next on yourself
mr lantos you're recognized for five
minutes
thank you mr chairman
most of my colleagues quite properly
have been dealing with
the details and the particulars of this
episode i would like to deal with the
broad picture
i'd like to address you judge sessions
there are few people in american public
life in recent decades who have had
your experience and your integrity in
dealing with american society
i'd like to ask you to sit back a bit
and look at this episode in a broad
historic and conceptual framework
it has seemed to me all along
that
three approaches have emerged
concerning this
tragedy the first
to which the lunatic fringe still
adheres with great tenacity
is that
this whole
waco tragedy was the result of a
conspiratorial government
attempting to destroy
the american people's right to religious
freedom and the american people's right
to bear arms
i'd like to ask you to react to this
approach
mr lantos i think you're very perceptive
and going back to the very roots
of our society
from the very beginning we were a
different people
we had different drummers that we
marched to
the people on the mayflower were in
grave disagreement
with their church authorities and with
their government
america became in the whole world the
one place where people could disagree
with their government
and finally with our constitution we
nailed that down
and said it was the most important of
factors
in society in america so it is
tremendously important that the
government not be perceived as
conspiring against
its people and it must not do that and
it must keep an openness and it must
keep the dialogue going and in terms of
how the government performs what it does
so i i think you're very perceptive and
very correct well the second the second
broad approach to which in varying
degrees we all let here
is obviously that some mistakes were
made at various stages
and with the benefit of 2020 hindsight
everybody would have been able to do a
better job and i don't think this panel
is the right one for me to explore what
specific mistakes were made by whom but
i think it's reasonably uh clear to
assume
that even the most glorious exercise in
recent history
the landing at normandy on d-day had
mistakes
and
and i don't know how far we will get by
dealing with the
nuanced approach to
mistake hunting and i don't want to deal
with that at all because my colleagues
are doing
in varying degrees a good job of it
the third issue that i want to get to
is the analogy with jonestown
because at jonestown uh judge sessions
there was no fbi
there was no bureau of
alco tobacco and firearms
as a matter of fact jonestown was
basically removed
from the sovereign domain of the united
states government
it happened elsewhere it happened in
guyana
yet in jonestown we have parallels to
waco
which are more than striking
a criminally insane charismatic
religious cult leader
bringing about
the death
by murder or self-destruction
of some 900 american citizens
who
for whatever reasons
misguided religious beliefs
fear
timidity personal relationships what
have you
have followed jim jones
as a god
did what
he wanted them to do
almost identical things
and they all perished
is it reasonable to assume that perhaps
the koresh tragedy
is most analogous to the jim jones
guyana tragedy
and the death and the nightmare
was preordained by koresh and his
determination that these people will die
with him
now there's a strong suggestion of that
and a similarity
there is one factor that existed at waco
with the branch davidians that did not
exist in jonestown
and that is you had law enforcement
officers
carrying out what they perceived to be
their sworn duty
in connection with the gun laws the
united states and there were four
officers killed and 20 wounded
it was that action that prompted the fbi
prompted me to call the director
and say can we be of help and there were
other connections almost immediately to
the tragedy that was enacted by the
original raid
in connection with the atf function so
there are similarities and i i i can see
that it's extremely important that the
american people out of this understand
that law enforcement is not allied
against these people
quite the contrary there are many many
law-abiding sects i'm sure in this
united states there are many many people
who think differently and march to a
different drummer but law enforcement
must protect those people and not be
perceived nor ever become the enemy of
those people but rather protect them mr
lancaster has expired could one more
witness respond one more to your rules
may i call on mr hubble to respond to
the
jonestown
vehicle analogy that i developed
congressman i think there are a lot of
analogies that can be made
i think one of the one of the
unbelievable things to me is the hold
that vernon howe had on these people
uh when
when when
when the army told me that
that they've seen grown men run through
doors as soon as they've had were hit
with this cs gas
and then to see no one come out
you realize the stronghold i'll never
forget the scene of the woman who ran
back into the fire
and the man who was on top of the
building and who wouldn't come off the
roof
that he had that kind of hold
on human beings is is frightening
and i do think there are analogies
thank you very much thank you thank you
mr lantos mr micah you're recognized for
five minutes
thank you just an observation mr
sessions
we had witnesses from britain who were
testifying on the use of cs gas and you
talked about the history of the united
states and the perceptions
and
if you i don't know if you saw that but
if you saw it you'd see why we broke off
from england because of the cold
calculated manner in which they have no
compunction about using
cs gas on children and women
and that's one of the reasons in fact we
broke off as a difference of opinion
mr
mr hubbell
do you recall a meeting on or about
the 14th or 15th of april
that you attended with vince foster with
uh
mr newsbomb and i guess some others
in which was really a turning point um
in which uh the discussions were that
the fbi had changed their mind
and um
the the change in the mind was based on
two things one a change in the situation
they plan to insert gas some people were
saying
uh that's one and two that the there was
concern expressed that the fbi had only
one hostage rescue team and
and they were tiring
do you recall that uh conversation in
that meeting i i recall i believe i
asked for that meeting yes but
was that the was that the context of
that uh meeting uh i think that
i'm not sure i i i
racked my brain but i can't remember
whether that meeting was after we met
with the military but i believe it was
before the other
but i i believe
that meeting was before where i advised
them that the fbi
was proposing
to insert the cs gas
and and they were asking me the same
kind of questions the attorney general
was asking why now
that kind of decision was made at that
point or that was the turning point
and uh we see all of this leading to the
you know the attorney general's office
and pointing sort of the responsibility
up there that she made a flawed decision
based on flawed advice so this is sort
of the turning point where some of this
took place did
did you or others at that meeting
recommend or was there any discussion
about the use of military force or
equipment there was not any discussion
about use of military force there was
discussion of having the military
evaluate the fbi's plan
dr salem
who asked you to brief the attorney
general specifically
two of my colleagues at the edgewood
research development and engineering
center are you aware of any second
opinion now you know this
involved use of this gas where women and
children you were aware of that
situation
uh
and were you well aware of any second
opinion being sought by any other expert
no
um
there were other people at the meeting
when i was were there other experts
you're the expert on cs gas that was
retained there wasn't a second opinion
as i'm not aware of that sir
mr potts
uh miss
mr bryan made the point earlier that
your intelligence people had not told
jamar
that on the morning of the 19th the
davidians were overheard as they
evidently spread fuel and allegedly
started a fire jamar has said he would
not have proceeded
had he known
whose responsibility was to get this
information to jamar
yes sir we i think that's a i think
that's an excellent point that mr bryant
made this morning that whose
responsibility was it to get the
information to jamar
we have a we had a set up where we had
monitors listening to
the uh the conversations that were going
on
and they did not hear those
conversations it's not on the logs so
you would expect if the monitors didn't
hear the conversations there's no way it
can can get then up the chain to mr no
one is taking responsibility mr mr
richard
um
i guess you're one of the folks that are
there now this week
approximately half of a panel that we
had testified that some of the infants
and children
since they didn't have gas masks could
in fact have died from inhalation or
effects of cs gas at the very least the
department of justice decision in fact
resulted in the babies and children
being tortured for at least uh three to
four hours before according to autopsy
reports that we have that that most of
the two dozen children were suffocated
or burned to death we can't go back and
change what took place but do you
believe we should ha adopt a federal
policy with respect to the use of cs gas
where women and children or particular
children and infants are present i
believe that you you're really in the
final analysis going to have to take a
case-by-case assessment should we have
some policy well we should certainly uh
go with we're very hesitantly and very
thoughtfully in all such instances and
using the gas but i i would not simply
i'm based on my understanding of of of
the effects of the gas and its lethality
i wouldn't want to suggest that that we
just ban its conceivable use on policy
grounds
without taking a case-by-case assessment
mr chairman do i still have time nope
you've run out of time mr micah uh and i
recognize for five minutes miss jackson
lee
mr chairman i uh thank you very much and
gentlemen good morning to you and i
thank you for your presence here
please uh
bear with me as i just offered to you uh
two amendments
in the bill of rights
a second amendment talks about a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed judge
sessions you have mentioned the
politicizing
of the atf but might i get you to
comment
on whether or not the rights of
david koresh
might have been violated in the second
amendment
as we read this language uh our
americans still protected under the
second amendment uh in light of the need
that was perceived to go in and
investigate mr quresh
on the use of the word politicizing i
did not say
that the atf was politicized i said that
they are involved in an issue that is
guns which is very political in nature
by virtue of the second amendment
discussion and will you then get to my
question on the second amendment and mr
quresh uh with mr quresh the atf it's my
understanding believed that he was in
violation of gun laws the united states
and that because he was in violation he
was answerable to a warrant for both
arrest and for search
and therefore they did that unlawfully
keeping guns
uh for hunting or sport
um are in keeping with the second
amendment is that my understanding what
you're saying well it's clear
that there is no question that where you
keep weapons that are in violation the
law and are listed as being weapons that
are prohibited that you are in violation
of the law and subject to warrant either
for arrest or for search
and so it would be
based upon the facts that have come to
you it would be your assessment that
most americans are protected under the
second amendment in
the lawful manner of keeping weapons i
think all americans are protected by the
second amendment i think that the matter
of keeping weapons as long as they are
not in violation the law is well
described and well established
frankly then let me say what i think
many americans are thinking as these
hearings are unfolding
what they are perceiving or what their
apprehension is is the fear of
militaristic domination
and law enforcement domination
and so i'm i'm i've got to pursue again
uh this whole question of the fourth
amendment i asked you about the second
amendment because if we hold to
a high standard second amendment the
rights of people to bear arms
then it seems unlikely that a government
should then attempt
to remove from citizens the same right
of unreasonable search and seizures
which might be thought to be the case
under the weakening of the exclusionary
rule
and you being a former federal court
judge
and certainly
your
leadership of the fbi i again ask you
do we do ourselves well
in this nation and answer the question
of the fear of militaristic domination
and law enforcement domination by the
weakening of the exclusionary rule well
i have answered mr scott's original
question and mr watt's original question
and now yours very very clearly i have
no question in my mind that the fourth
amendment means exactly what it says and
it should be maintained
and that we should on the other side of
it insist that and provide for the
enhancement of the professionalism of
law all law enforcement so they know the
standards and they follow the standards
and they are trained and it's second
nature to them so that you do not have
any infringement or impairment of the
fourth amendment right
so you think that it is certainly
positive to have an independent
intervener
uh cooled heads cooled minds
to review whatever the
representations are being made by a law
enforcement officer for a viable
verifiable search warrant well that's
intended that a warrant be issued by the
authority having been properly informed
so the answer is yes and proper
information is certainly a key element
proper information is critical and it
always has been critical and always will
continue to be that's the integrity of
the warrant if it's on improper
information or deceptive information
then you weaken the warrant and uh you
should not do that
i noticed that some uh who are on the
panel this morning visited the site and
others did not
and judge sessions uh i too hold you in
high respect but let me query you on
this issue for
i think again apprehension is is
a government in control of itself
would you respond to the allegations
that the reason why we had a waco
is because the fbi was in disarray
the reason why we had a waco was the
ultimate results of the 51 day siege and
the ultimate going in is because the fbi
itself the organizational structure was
in disarray well how would you respond
to that well i would respond to it this
way it is obvious that from the time of
the change in the administration it was
very clear that there was great
discussion about the replacement of the
director of the fbi
uh that discussion was well
known by everybody the decisions had
been made probably earlier but i do not
believe that the discipline nor the the
ability of the fbi was impacted at all
now there may be others that disagree
uh i know this is a very political thing
and i agree that uh that
with your observation that it could be
that the fbi was impaired in its ability
certainly i was impaired in my ability
to be able to negotiate to be able to
actually go down
as we discussed with attorney general
gerson
the idea of the director ever becoming
directly involved in negotiation because
those were hometown folk was dismissed
as ridiculous and grandstanding
it was also discussed that it was not
appropriate it was not appropriate for
an fbi director to respond to a hostage
type or this type of circumstance so
there
there are elements of it and i i
continue and continue to this day my
strong belief you must negotiate you
must be patient and yet you must apply
the appropriate pressure and i think we
did those three things which indicate
that the government was not in disarray
know the bureau
judge sessions is going to have to leave
us when we go for these votes we're
going to have a series of three because
he is going to leave i'm going to
recognize mr blued who has a question
for you for whatever time he consumes
and he'll retain then the balance that
time because we're going to have to go
vote before he could use up five minutes
so mr blute
thank you mr chairman i want to thank
the panel for their testimony judge
sessions i want to get back to something
that you touched on briefly earlier but
i think is a very important point that's
mr smarrick's uh testimony that he
felt pressure from fbi hireups to change
his recommendations from a passive
approach uh to a more confrontational
approach i think this is a crucial issue
to understand how the pressure built
to move towards a confrontational
approach he mentioned you specifically a
number of times in relationship to this
and i wonder if you could again explain
how you relate to
uh mr smerrick your displeasure with his
recommendations i cannot i cannot ever
recall having a conversation with mr
sumeric nor being
indicating to him my displeasure about
his approach i suggest what you do is
you go down the line that you asked mr
clark if he had that you asked mr uh
what uh pots if he had that
i don't know where it came from but my i
was not displeased with the idea of
negotiating ever
nor the attempts to negotiate in fact as
i said it subjected me to some ridicule
there early on because i felt that the
discussions down there in waco early on
might have yielded fruit i talked with
steve higgins about it we talked
directly about the possibility of going
down together and and having a
circumstance where we could have some
negotiation there were many people
willing including mr guerin mister to
cope mr coker to be able to deal with
that negotiation phase so no i it just
is not a correct concept i don't know
where he got it but he didn't get it
from me so you didn't give a send any
signals that you were concerned about
his recommendations mr president mr
blood i'm a direct man and i know the
king's english and i know how to speak
uh about what i believe
and there if there's anybody here who
says i indicated that i had that belief
then they need to stand up and say so i
it just didn't happen thank you judge
and i'll reserve the balance of my time
thank you at this point you've used one
and a half minutes uh we are going to be
in recess until
five minutes after the last of a series
of three votes judge sessions and we
know you won't be back we want to thank
you for coming uh the rest of the panel
i we know we will convene i do not
expect us to break for lunch for this
panel so we will be back and go through
the lunch period thank you
you're watching the eighth of 10 days of
last month's hearings on the incident in
waco texas in 1993.
our coverage will continue in a few
moments first you'll hear from several
reporters who covered the waco hearings
we asked them about the most interesting
moments and witnesses
well i thought
there were a number of key witnesses uh
first day kerry jewell she was a 14 year
old girl who told of being sexually
abused by crash when she was 10 in a
hotel in a hotel room in texas
she told of beatings that took place and
and people being beaten by crash kids
with boat oars
she was uh she really set the tone for
the hearings and you couldn't walk away
without just being really struck by this
14 year old girl with her father there
kind of stroking her in the back and
and
supporting her and her doing what she
could to tell us as best she could that
story
but again i mean
what we saw there was the democrats were
just um i mean they were giddy at her
testimony the idea that she had
basically made karesh out to be this
beast and they used her day in and day
out afterwards to say well you know we
the attention is misplaced it shouldn't
be on law enforcement it should be on
david koresh and what a beast he is and
what a pervert and then the republicans
would continually come back and and say
that they were embarrassed that she had
to tell that testimony and she was
constantly the subject throughout of
this partisan wrangling but you walk
away with it it was really a brilliant
uh stroke on the democrats part to get
her on the first day and to tell that
story and all of a sudden kind of the
mistakes
and the errors made by
law enforcement which there were a
number of them made here and serious
ones were kind of put in perspective
um i think that hurt the republicans
very badly was there a moment in the
hearings that was particularly riveting
for you as a journalist
well for several for us in texas one was
the
testimony of former treasury secretary
lloyd benson former senator from our
state who was
heavily criticized by members of the
panel
for what they felt was a lack of
activity on his part for not getting as
involved as he should have
in the raid secretary benson of course
said that uh you know he was delegating
responsibility to the atf and and to
others so that was a particularly
interesting part of the hearings for us
and also janet reno's testimony on the
final day which kind of wrapped up
everything that had happened the nine
days previous and
it was a final opportunity for people to
to really say what was on their mind
about the waco incident and
the the exchanges between
uh
miss arena when members of the committee
particularly the republican members was
parts were quite interesting i think the
highlights it was quite exciting when
carrie jewell the 14 year old girl
testified that she had been molested by
david koresh and
when the undercover
agent testified mr rodriguez about the
scene
on the day of the february 28th raid we
had not heard a first person account of
that before and he had been in the room
when david koresh learned of the
impending raid and
that was quite exciting but the rest of
it was an awful lot of partisan
bickering hours and hours of it at a
time
tomorrow day nine of the waco hearings
the witnesses include a panel of fbi
special agents and on friday will air
the final day of the house hearings with
testimony from attorney general janet
reno
[Music]
we now return to coverage of day eight
of the house waco hearings today's
hearings run until about 6 p.m eastern
time
during this panel we'll hear more
testimony from fbi official larry potts
defense department toxicologist harry
salem and mark richard of the justice
department
the waco matter will convene reconvene i
should say we just had a break for votes
there were three votes on the floor of
the house and members have come back
when we took our break
mr blute had consumed one and a half
minutes of five minutes of time which he
had in order to ask judge sessions a
question before
mr sessions had to leave
which he knew and we knew in advance he
would have to do at around 11 o'clock
now i will recognize mr bloot for the
remaining three and a half minutes of
the time that he has mr blute
thank you mr chairman
uh i'd like to ask the fbi
representatives about some of the
questioning of that i asked judge
sessions about mr smarrick's
recommendations and whether there was
pressure generated from above
to change his recommendation to conform
with some type of pre-ordained outcome
which i think is very troubling and
indicates where the pressure built for
the final confrontation perhaps not in
waco texas but
perhaps in washington d.c and i judge
judge sessions said that he uh knew
nothing about that i i tend to believe
him but i also believe mr smarrick is
sincere in testifying that although he
thought it was judge sessions that there
were
some pressure
on him that there was some pressure on
him to change his recommendation i
wonder if mr clark would comment on that
did you
know of any or did you engage in any
pressure sending signals down the line
that this recommendation was not uh the
proper recommendation
i am unaware of
of any pressure and
i did not see
or hear or read of all of the mr
smarrick's uh testimony but one piece
that i did catch indicated to me that he
believed that the pressure was more
self-imposed as opposed to somebody
overtly uh imposing upon well but he did
say that he uh when asked uh where that
pressure was coming from he didn't refer
to it as pressure but i think we can
assume it was a form of pressure uh he
mentioned judge sessions in particular
i'm not aware of any
discussions that
mr sessions ever had with the peach
merrick i know i i never had any i
i so i i'm at a loss to explain that mr
potts yes sir
when i first
became aware that there was a concern
over uh
one of pete's merrick's memos and i
think it was i'm not sure the exact date
i think it was around the 5th or some
somewhere around there march 5th
jeff jamar expressed to me some concern
that
that
he believed that pete thought that we
were trying to go forward with something
tactically at that time
and that because of the the tone of the
memo
that it would leave them
with no flexibility at all down there
and i said well look all that's one
opinion and i think what you do is you
you what we have to do is listen to that
evaluate that opinion and you also have
to get other opinions and see
what how they feel about that
uh someone in washington
uh at the command center
contacted john douglas just to say john
douglas was pete's merrick supervisor to
say
we want you to sit down and evaluate
this also and we also want you to sit
down with pete and go through his
assessment and see if you concur with
his assessment
we actually i believe
pete's
assessment early on especially with
regard to the pull everything back
and
get get away from him don't show the
vehicles the way they are but his i
think that memo also said only do that
if if they will bring the children out
if they'll agree to bring some of the
children out and if at the same time
quresh will agree to come out not at
that time but that he'll say that he'll
eventually surrender and it was probably
a day or so thereafter that jeff jamar
made
that offer to
quresh that said we'll pull everything
back we'll pull all the bradleys back
we'll pull everything back and away if
you'll just send and he didn't even
limited children if you'll send four
people out
we'll pull everything back
and that was disregarded let me just
quickly ask mr hubbell you said the
military was to review the plan did the
military pass judgment on the plan what
was their opinion of the final plan
we wanted one of them to critique the
plan
and and give us any opinion they had the
thought
of how it could be improved now i didn't
sit in
in the meetings that maybe the fbi had
with the military before they both
jointly briefed the attorney general and
myself
and others
and so there may have been other
suggestions that made prior to that i
just don't know i know what
we discussed but they critiqued the plan
and they said this is they believed it
would work the butcher time has expired
ms lofgren you're recognized for five
minutes thank you mr chairman
you know one of the um
interesting aspects of this
hearing is that it's gone on long enough
that
our constituents back home
realize that there are hearings and
they're calling in with questions and
advice
it's amazing to me how many people in
america have been tear gassed uh
the
i i guess every soldier went through
basic training was tear gassed i've
heard from a lot of them
uh
now grown-ups who were undergraduates
who had their dorms tear gassed in the
late 60s and 70s and even people who
were celebrating the fourth of july on
the capitol mall in 1971 in the nixon
administration when i guess there were
some anti-war demonstrators and tear
grass was applied
on not only the demonstrators but all
the families with kids who were
picnicking on the fourth of july
one of the
inputs i've had is from someone i never
served in the military but someone who
did who suggested that if this were had
been a military um
endeavor rather than a law enforcement
endeavor that probably what would have
occurred would be not a gradual
insertion of gas but massive gassing
that would then have brought the people
out i don't know if that's true or not
but i'm wondering dr salem had that
happened would the risk to the people
inside have been greater were there
constraints in terms of their safety
that would have prevented the fbi from
taking a
more military assault gas
approach than was taken in this case
according to the evidence after you
reach the irritating point if you
increase the concentration
it does not really increase the symptoms
you get your profuse symptoms that occur
and
the use of
tear gas any type of tear gas in cs it
entails some degree of risk
but in my opinion cs does not cause
permanent injury
to adults or to children
and this is based on the best available
information
and based on that
cs is the best ride control agent
now the attorney general was extremely
sensitive
to the risks
and obviously had to balance them
and the final analysis
the question of the use of cs comes down
to balancing the risks against the
consequences even the consequences of
waiting
and that was a very tough decision that
they had to make
mr pot said did was there a
consideration of not gradual insertion
but a more
voluminous
insertion of gas
and why was that was it really just
hesitation or why was the decision made
that there absolutely was a
recommendation the hostage rescue team
and and most of the sacs felt very
strongly that it would be better to have
a full insertion
as well as you know the military said if
they were doing a military operation
that's the way they do it
uh our concern about doing that is that
we thought that we significantly reduced
the risk to the children
we also significantly reduce the
the the chance of them having a violent
reaction if we did it in a measured way
we increase the risk to our agents but
we decrease the risk of a violent
response we believe
as well as to the children
let me ask you this i had some uh
constituents or
in here uh in the capitol today really
on on a vacation and they
uh sort of well they asked me you know
why are we doing this i mean didn't this
happen
two and a half years ago and finally
said well i guess the only real value on
this in their view i'm quoting them was
if we could learn something for the
future that would make our country
better prepared to deal with such an
issue
and that has been very much a concern of
mine now i've read through the treasury
report as well as the
justice department reports not just what
happened but how could we do a better
job in the future and i'm particularly
interested in how we are organized to
understand
uh groups of people that might be
operating on a worldview that is
different than
average
now i was frankly very impressed by what
i heard
uh the other day about the number of
experts and the like but the question is
to mr mr potts
are you satisfied that we have done all
we could what if the next group
and that may happen as the millennium
approaches is a group that is
say animism that the average uh
officer really don't know much about do
we have experts set up and do we have
training for our law enforcement people
to really understand the information
they're getting and incorporate it so
that they can make
uh prudent decisions are you satisfied
with the recommendations that have been
made so far
i'm satisfied with the recommendations
and i think we've made good progress on
those i think we'll have better
coordination i think we have people who
are better trained
and i think that the component of of our
crisis intervention response group now
that puts our negotiators and our
hostage rescue team together within one
within one unit
uh i think that one component of that
element is set up to to really reach out
to places like the university of
michigan and others that have
uh behavioral science understandings and
and to develop a real core of people
that we can call on in these kind of
crises who could give us the best advice
possible i think we've made great
strides in that regard and if you could
just real quickly answer my question
have we trained the people within the
fbi to really understand the information
that is being given to them by the
experts well i think we're in the
process of doing that i i think that
that's underway
thank you mr chairman
mr heinemann you're recognized for five
minutes
thank you mr chairman
and i have to say for the past eight
days i've felt some degree of discomfort
sitting here and
on the opposite side of
the law enforcement officials as it
relates to that table
and that table only and certainly you
folks being in a high-ranking
administrative position
uh but that that discomfort is is is
rather
easy for me to take because i know that
what we're doing here is not really
second guessing but critiquing what
happened
on two issues that really need to be
critiqued so that we can understand what
happened we can place responsibility and
i don't want to say blame because i
think the people at the operating levels
really thought that they were doing the
right thing
and certainly i wasn't there
but as i see this information having
filtered up
up the line of responsibility
uh if it gets
fuzzy it gets hazy as to
as to um the attorney general who did
initially feel
a great deal of discomfort with what
happened and i believe mr langan and the
treasury department or someone of his
equal rank felt
discomfort too with with that february
28th raid
but but but those feelings of discomfort
really didn't last long
uh and and and i would just like if i
can and i don't have enough time five
minutes to find out
really what changed people's minds what
changed the attorney general's mind uh
from a feeling of discomfort what
changed um
mr langan if it was him his mind i know
mr higgins did prevail upon him to to
accept the plan and of course
uh of course we know what happened after
that but i think being a member of
congress i have a
as and as we all do
a strong obligation to let the people in
this country know that they get they're
getting a fair deal
that there is no cover-up that there was
no cover-up or if if that's a perception
that's out there then i think we need to
i think we need to throw cold water on
that fire because as it grows we can see
militias grow
because of a strong feeling against
government law enforcement
and and i'm not going to say that
there's a direct relationship but i
believe that there's an indirect
relationship to what happened in
oklahoma city by a mindset that's in
this country that feels government is
against them and needs to be retaliated
against so what we're doing is extremely
important
and congress itself is on trial here and
i've said that before so i
you know i don't make any apologies for
us asking hard questions
and certainly i'm not and i'm not
looking to throw cold water on witnesses
as we have here discrediting witnesses
even law enforcement because we didn't
agree with them
but but having said that mr potts um on
on april the 14th uh mr jamaat
related to you the conversation he had
with the lawyers mr livingston
um and mr um
livingston is that the right
uh mr uh de guerin de garan and
zimmerman i'm sorry i'm sorry uh and he
told you that information that he
thought that they thought they had a
deal
with karesh to come out with that with
that letter that he um i think that's
been i think the the whole plan to come
out was earlier in april
the whole the whole plan just the net
plan was the same as it was early in
march except it inserted the attorneys
into it the the issue of the manuscript
that now that
he's decided that passover's over oh can
i reclaim my time i'm i'm sorry i know
about that i may have my dates wrong but
the attorneys stated that
that mr jamar had told him you have all
the time you need
um
and
and i have a little problem with that
being changed if it was changed
apparently the the the the lawyers felt
devastated
but when they found out that that on the
19th there was an assault on a compound
did anybody have a feel that perhaps the
the chemistry has changed and this might
be an open end to pursue
a reason not to go in
and i can certainly understand law
enforcement's wanting to go in i was
part of that and and and i'm sympathetic
with their feelings on that
sir i don't i
i never got the impression from talking
to anyone
on site at waco from my position in
washington that anyone believed that
there had been any substantial change in
david gresh in fact it was clearly
stated to me
that they thought this was a continuing
manipulation
a continuing delaying tactic that he had
no intention of coming out
and they believe they continued to
monitor that
from the 14th up through the morning of
the 19th and saw nothing to convince
them any differently in between okay
could it not have been
handled differently as it related to
relieving your hrt teams and they
certainly should have been relieved and
replacing them with perhaps dps
department of public safety or another
agency
unless unless you can tell us here that
there was some imperative for
for the fbi being able to handle that
alone well i believe that the hostage
rescue team
by its nature and by its training is is
the finest law enforcement team of its
type in the nation so i do believe that
they are different from the other teams
they
they are a team that trains every day
they're they're a team that's full-time
tactical as opposed to our swat teams or
most other swat teams around the country
but
more importantly than that to me in
terms of waiting we had a a lot of
behavioralists at that time
who were looking at letters that were
koresh was sending out and who had been
evaluating him throughout some of them
throughout the course of this standoff
who said that they don't believe that
kresh is going to commit suicide they
don't believe that there's necessarily
going to be a mass suicide but they
think that if there is a suicide effort
that it would be
suicide as they call it suicide by cop
and that there might be some kind of a
breakout plan
and that quresh has his own time frame
the government has their time frame that
they're working on under and david has
his own separate one and so he might
decide at any time to come out
obviously thank you
thank you very much mr heinemann ms
collins you're recognized for five
minutes thank you mr chairman
during these hearings we've listened to
exhaustive academic discussion about cs
tear gas these issues will continue to
be debated as they should but for the
american public the basic question is
how carefully the fbi and the department
of justice consider the effect of cs
tear gas on children pregnant women and
the elderly before it was inserted into
the divinian compound
the testimony we have heard has made it
clear that the decision to use tear gas
had to be balanced to the with the risk
to these individuals against the risk of
allowing the standoff to continue so mr
clark i'm going to ask you what was your
involvement in the decision to use the
tear gas in the compound a what meetings
you personally participated in b and who
you consulted with about the possible
effects on the children see
that's a
very long question and i have to tell
you before i get started i would have a
long answer to it because there's a
number of factors and i know that you're
trying to condense
time
the issue of tear gas
came up fairly early on because
if
there were a problem
inside that we had to respond to how
would we respond and so the issue of
tear gas came up
fairly early on and the experts in the
criminal investigative division and on a
hostage rescue team
almost at the outset began to do
research and on a number of different
other alternatives somewhere in late
march
um
the
other options had been tried and failed
and and
the
recommendations were coming in from waco
that
they wanted to develop a a plan
to use gas and a plan was submitted
uh it was uh
deemed by
most of us at headquarters that
it was not the time yet to do that there
were other things that we were still
exploring
those discussions were ongoing when
mr potts and i accompanied mr richards
to waco
and that was on the 7th and 8th of april
i still at that point
did not
believe that
the use of gas was appropriate
at that time
after
the discussions that we had down there
we had the opportunity to talk to
our negotiators the hrt people the sacs
all of the people all of the components
that were involved
that on the night of april the eighth
after consulting with the four sacs
uh the hostage rescue team leader mr
potts and myself i became convinced that
there was an option that
could
bring about
a safe
resolution to this problem
we came back and briefed the director
that was done on the ninth
concluding that briefing the director
also agreed and contacted the attorney
general so i would say that my decision
in supporting it occurred on the evening
of the 8th and i discussed that on the
9th with the director did you
specifically consult
with anyone about the possible effects
on children of the cst experience
extensively extensively
with the people that you've already
talked about and tony betts who i
understand has already been a witness
here i had that time had not had direct
conversation with dr salem but i was
aware
that the
people that were actually doing the
research here had talked to a number of
experts we we had had an ongoing for
some time under director webster uh the
bureau had started a program looking at
less than lethal weapons we had held
symposia at at quantico looking for
different ways there was extensive
research that had been done in a number
of people within the bureau and outside
of the bureau that were consulted i
don't want to cut you off but i want to
hear what dr salem has to say about the
use of cs uh tear gas on children and
whatever he thought about this
when i was contacted we reviewed all of
the available literature
on the effects the toxicology and the
safety of cs in particular its effect on
children and pregnant women
and based on all the available
literature there that was a lot of
experiments done on adults and older
people no experiments were done on
children however there were several
cases reported in the literature
uh the one case of that young infant
that four-month-old infant who survived
after 28 days of hospitalization
following a massive
dose that it was exposed to
the other is
the actual occurrence in northern
ireland when cs was used in those uh
at that time
and the reports showed that they
investigated there were children that
were exposed none of the children
required hospitalization
they don't know what the dose was but it
was much less than the other one
uh those are the only published
literature on the effects of
cs on children and based on that
as a scientist we look at what the facts
are rather than anecdotal and even
though these were anecdotal they were
followed up by epidemiological studies
there were animal studies using young
animals and they did not find a
difference and it was concluded by many
researchers very competent
researchers that there was no difference
in sensitivity to the cs by
young people older people and the infirm
and
tear gas is really a generic term a cs
has been available
uh it is not a military unique chemical
it's been available to
law enforcement officers and even to the
public
as you know you can buy cs in
combination with other
uh
deterrents in the grocery stores well
let me ask you something before uh you
go any further if you had been in a
position of making a decision whether or
not to put cs gas into the divinian
compound knowing that there were
children there would you have done that
i was not asked to make that decision i
said if it's a hypothetical
based on your scientific knowledge if
chemicals have to be used that would be
the chemical of choice
why
pardon why because it is the most
extensively studied
agent of that type
and it is the safest there are no
authenticated deaths following its use
thank you mrs collins mr sauder you're
recognized for five minutes
i just want to make sure that the record
shows that
in fact mr abbett said that he was only
a tactical expert yesterday and he
referred to dr salem that the extent of
the research consists of
in ireland we don't know the dose we
don't know whether they were necessarily
confined but they were in one child who
recovered and that based on this
extensive
uh research a decision was made that dr
salem himself just said that if you had
to use a chemical apparently because at
least there was no evidence of death he
would have used this chemical hardly a
compelling argument but not one that
proves any deaths occurred or anything
bad happened but not exactly a
compelling argument i i earlier heard
director or judge sessions say that
the attorney general was kept briefed in
detail because of her concerns about the
children and yet we heard yesterday when
i
asked mr jamar he said 99 percent
likelihood that there would be fired
upon which seemed pretty logical
actually but that didn't get up the
system and i wanted to ask mr hubbell
whether he and
attorney general uh did you know that
the fbi didn't know where the children
would be located
uh in the compound when they gassed it
they did not
we were advised we asked where the
children would be located the likely
place that they would be located we're
told by the fa fbi where the likely
place they would be located
based on
interviews with people who had left the
compound so we did ask those questions
and and we were given those answers
because mr jamar said yesterday when i
asked him that he didn't know and in
fact when they had hoped that they would
be in the bus but they weren't there and
uh so i just wanted to make sure that
they they didn't they did express to you
that they didn't exactly know but they
made their best guess
they did not precisely know i think they
had hoped
that if the children didn't come out
that they would be put in the bus i
don't think i was told that that's where
they would sleep that night i think they
were supposed to more than likely be
sleeping with with their parents
when in the in the compound one other
question that i'm going to yield to mr
bryant and the similar vein when i asked
mr jamar about the
where they were pouring the fuel and
they he said that they couldn't hear
back that they were pouring the fuel did
the attorney general and you understand
that there wouldn't be a way to hear
what was going on in the compound to be
able to adjust because he said if he had
known that he would have adjusted did
you understand that there was an
equipment problem that there wasn't
going to be that exchange we we were
aware that there were surveillance
devices in the compound
we weren't
totally
uh
my understanding was and then on the day
uh they were some of them were not
working that there was some suspicion
that the people within the compound knew
there were surveillance devices and were
using that as part of the manipulation
and that they could you know terminate
their usefulness or destroy them at will
so we knew that we had surveillance
devices within the compound but we
weren't confident that they would be
available during the
during the insertion of gas the day
before and then certainly we were aware
of some of the problems that occurred
while we
while the scene unfolded on the 19th
thank you very much i yield the rest of
my time to mr bryant
thank you thank you
let me ask i've got time just about one
question here uh mr hubble putting
things in the context at the white house
at this point uh you were appointed by
the president again you're you're some
say the best friend to head the
transition team
the administration into the into the
department of justice and they had
people in the other departments also but
you were the one to head to the
transition team into justice
and we've just been through in the
context of that time frame the failures
of uh i guess miss baird ms woods i
don't know if mr had come along at that
point but certainly there were some
failures with the white house and the
department of justice and then you've
got the waco standoff the siege uh
certainly applying some pressure there
and i'm still having some difficulty in
accepting uh
the statement that that you were not
dealing directly with the white house
and maybe i'm not maybe i didn't make my
questions clear about the president but
certainly you had lots of other friends
over there mr lindsay mr foster mr
mclarty all from arkansas
and uh at heading the transition team
you had mr gerson who was the acting
attorney general but he was a bush hold
over so i can imagine your contact
especially with the president indicating
that he wanted to be made aware of any
change any shift in strategy
uh i i i found it difficult and i've
found a couple of phone calls where the
president called you uh during that time
frame on the list here the article that
i quoted you from the
paper said that uh
and again you denied that making this a
statement that he uh you had talked to
business with clinton only when the
president saw updates in the early days
of the cult crisis in waco and that's
certainly consistent with telephone
calls from the president to you during
march which is documented on the log
again
weren't you in fact communicating with
the president because he wanted to know
what was going on and if there was a
change in strategy
ultimately
he could have approved that or
ultimately he could have even
disapproved that i understand that he
relied a lot on his attorney new
attorney general ms reno at that time
but in the end he did have that ultimate
authority as the as the president as ms
reno's boss as your boss to say no let's
don't do that now i understand he he
relied on her
but i again i under the context of the
context of the situation weren't you in
fact dealing with the president some and
other members other friends over there
and keeping them apprised as what was
going on at wake up i i did i think i
did testify congressman if i did and i
want to make clear
the beginning when the fbi advised me of
their plan and the possibility of the
insertion of gas
i did notify the white house council
and that kept in contact through the
white house council i'm sure the white
house council advised the president but
that's the way i i
kept
the white house advised of the plan
and what we were doing the evaluation
that was going on so i don't mean to say
i never talked to the white house i did
not talk to the president united states
about this issue prior to the 19th
my time has expired ms slaughter you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman i'm sure you
gentlemen are familiar enough with the
way the government congress operates and
know that you were damned if you did
damned if you didn't
and if you followed some of the advice
you're getting here now and built a
fence and stayed there for two years
everybody would be yelling every day
look how much it costs these are
supposed to be best in the world what in
the world's going on down here uh one of
the things that i have learned is that
before waco
the department atf and i guess mr potts
can
verify this
really didn't have very much connection
to the top echelon of the treasury
department and then before secretary
benson
made some changes that it was not really
a normal thing for the secretary of the
treasury to know at all times what batf
is doing is that correct mr fox
i'm afraid i'm not your good expert on
that i'm not sure how atf operated
within treasury in terms of you came in
with the clinton administration or
weren't you i i came in uh 21 years ago
over 21 years ago as a civil servant
fbi agent um
i see just an fbi agent well that has
been testified to here before and i
think probably the one thing that i've
learned
is that there have been massive changes
at treasury to make sure
uh that the kinds of breaches that
happen won't happen again for example
i'm absolutely persuaded from what i've
heard that the reason four agents died
and the branch davidians on february
28th is because there was no security
and that postman who heard it from a
television man who learned it from a
woman who had rented ambulances to the
atf talked
and that steps had been taken to make
sure that that doesn't happen again
but one of the things that was saddest
to me here and i don't know if you've
heard the testimony i hope you've been
busy since we all worked for the same
company here
um was from miss sparks
uh it would seem to me that when she
walked into that cat and into the
compound knowing that her visit had been
compromised she was only allowed to see
certain children in certain areas and
yet she said by her testimony that there
was one running sink with running water
there was no sanitation facilities the
children were obviously shell-shocked to
some degree
that
the conditions were so bad there that
i've often won why the state of texas
did not remove the children from that
compound at that time has that occurred
to any of you
that under child protective laws they
would have done that normally
and what a change they might have made
it hasn't i see that all right uh one of
the things that i wanted to point out as
well is that that because
of the deteriorating conditions and as a
former bacteriologist i understand this
very well
and i think that everybody on the scene
has explained the deteriorating sanitary
conditions taking place in that compound
there was no electricity correct there
was no way to heat food
no way to heat anything up to kill
bacteria there was no way to dispose of
sewage isn't that not
that's correct uh and i think that
although you seem to have heard from
every behavioral psychologist in america
and all kinds of negotiators i don't
hear of anybody talking to any medical
personnel my i assume they would have
said to you those children have got to
come out of there they're going to be
seriously ill
from the conditions under which they
live is it not true however that not a
single soul could leave that compound
without courageous permission
there seems to be an implication here
from time to time you waited people
would have come out i think the general
way that uh that
he told us from the beginning anybody
who wants to come out can come out
however the problem with that is we
found the process was that in order to
come out
you have to first have uh i think as one
of the negotiators described it the
other day an exit interview with david
and
it's that point which we believe they
talked about their salvation and their
soul and
and so a lot who maybe wanted to come
out
were had their mind changed as a result
of those talks
the people who did come out there were
some 34 i believe that were that were
saved they did leave the compound 30 35
total before the fire he started out
first with children correct
that's that's true in the first few days
a lot of children came not his own
biological children off which i think
there was some 15 is that correct i
don't know the number of his biological
children except that on march 5th
or rather i think march 5th was the last
day that any child came out march 7th
or in that area he told our negotiators
when we were talking to him about more
children sending more children out
he said you're you're talking about my
biological children now and and pretty
much indicated that there wouldn't be
any more children coming out did you
have any
reason to believe that there was a
special category of persons coming out
perhaps somebody he was uncertain of
somebody who caused him trouble
uh did he get rid of any people that he
thought might want to cause an uprising
among his other followers or something
as things got more and more tense and
conditions got worse
i think our negotiators believed and
they believed on site that those that
you have just described very
thoroughly those who came out
as far as i'm concerned i think these
hearings have shown what i've said
before that i think changes have been
made other than that it's taken an awful
lot of men and women hours of federal
employees for us to go over this one
more time
i i can appreciate um
what it's been like for you i'm sitting
here watching people grown men burst
into tears
and the pain that people have had of
reliving this
hindsight is so easy for us to talk
about but
i i once again i think that the law
enforcement the people who were there
facing death on a daily basis and who
walked up to those doors really deserve
not our abbreviation but the fact that
we are grateful that they'll do that
when the government asks them to
thank you miss slaughter mr shadow
you're recognized for five minutes thank
you mr chairman mr potts i'd like to
begin with you um first of all i have no
sympathy for the davidians who
participated in the murder of the agents
clearly you were dealing with some
cold-blooded people the problem is we
have women in there and we had children
in there as well your goal uh and the
fbi's goal was to avoid further loss of
life was it not yes sir
and this wasn't well not a classic
hostage situation you had to presume the
children were innocent and perhaps some
of the women inside were innocent did
you not
we we certainly believe that there were
people in there who um
considered a barricaded situation but
they were kind of a hostage of the
circumstance i think and the children
were certainly not guilty of any
criminal conduct that's right okay the
goal of the glass gas insertion plan was
as i understand it to force the
davidians out hopefully without harm to
them and without harm particularly to
the children correct yes sir okay
um
indeed not injuring the children was an
extremely important goal for the
attorney general it appears from her
discussions
and for the president is that what you
understood
i certainly understood that no one
wanted any harm to come to anyone you
would agree with that would you not mr
hubble yes i would as a matter of fact
we've had extensive testimony about the
selection of cs gas
as non-lethal or non-toxic and we have
great debates about whether it was or
wasn't
but the whole idea here was not to hurt
people right
that is correct okay i want to go into a
series of pictures uh that i wish i had
a video because if i had a video which
i've watched but i can't show here it
shows this sequence rather dramatically
you see these pictures over here you'll
see at the back of the building right
there where the gentleman is pointing is
a room that's differently called
sometimes the fbi calls it a shooting
range sometimes it's called a gymnasium
sometimes it's called an auditorium i
believe it is some 65 sean how long is
it
65 feet long and how deep
okay i want to focus on that building
right there and on that corner you see
it's now structurally sound this is
while the compounds going on did you go
to the next photo
in the next photo and unfortunately we
don't have these very well but we're now
looking kind of from the front corner
these are taken from the airplanes you
will see that where he is pointing that
section of the building is gone
indeed a great portion of the building
is gone the diagram which shows the
insurance and so shows when you watch
the videotape shows that this tank can
you show the tank is it tank is visible
in that picture that tank right there
goes into that portion of the building
and unfortunately we don't have these
photos in a very good sequence i've got
to deal with what i'm given but it goes
into the building so far that the back
of the tank disappears you can't see it
indeed it goes so far into the building
it appears it goes all the way to the
opposite wall
and it goes in and out and in and out
and in and out and in and out i couldn't
count the number of times but you will
see in this particular picture uh sean
would
you can show that the left slope the
right slope of the roof is still there
is the left slope of the still there in
that photograph
both slopes of the roof are there now
you go to the next picture if you would
sean
the next slope the next picture shows
that the tank goes in
and back out
and that portion of the building then is
gone here's the tank going in and that
go to the next picture if you would sean
here it shows can you see the roof line
show the roof line of that part of the
gym sean right there is the peak line
you'll see now both the left and the
right sides of the back of that gym are
gone indeed the entire roof of that in
for one half of the gym is crushed so
we're talking space 50 feet by 50 feet
is crushed and the entire part has
fallen and the video shows the tank
going in and out and in and out if you
go to the next photo
now we have that from the back and we
see the tank
from a different angle this is the tank
that's gone in and out repeatedly over
and over and over again and now we can
see from that side that that part of the
building is completely crushed
i guess i find that somewhat
inconsistent and i'm trying to find out
i understand the theory of puncturing
escape holes somewhere in the building
indeed on the front there are two or
three escape holes that were punched if
you'll show sean on the left side of the
back of that building there's an escape
hole further to the left right there
this is an escape hole
i'm having some difficulty with that
entire section of roof some 50 feet by
50 feet or 45 feet by 45 feet being
crushed by a tank going in and out and
while you can't see it in a still photo
there is a picture of the tank literally
going up on top of the roof once the
roof collapsed and hit the ground and in
the video you can see that very clearly
and it hits the ground in a later
sequence the tank one point it falls on
the tank the tank comes out it falls the
rest of the way the tank goes up on the
roof and crushes the right side of it
and then comes back out goes back in and
crushes the left side of it to where as
you can see in this final photograph
that entire section of the building is
gone
i'm having great difficulty with
understanding if the insertion of the
gas is to be non-lethal
why we are crushing an entire section of
the building
and if the attorney general was told and
i'm running out of time so let me just
posit these questions if the attorney
general was told that a part of the
strategy this early was going to be to
crush significant sections of the
structure was the attorney general
warned that while we'd been very
cautious about selecting what your
experts say or experts say was
non-lethal gas
we might still crush sections in the
building did she understand that people
might be killed
if sections of the building were crushed
was she or the president advised that if
sections of the building were crushed
that might itself cause a fire because
there was a coleman it was known that
they'd been using coleman lanterns for
days to light the building i find an
inconsistency between the efforts of the
gas insertion plan to save life and and
the actions of this tank repeatedly
going in and out crushing that section
of the building and my specific question
is
was the attorney general warned of this
part of the plan and what was its
purpose a couple of you may respond i
don't know who's best mr poss mr clark
whoever has the best response to that we
well i believe that that there was a
discussion that uh there would be there
may come a point in this where we would
try to
uh poke holes in the building uh my
understanding i understood that yes sir
this i don't see as a whole
no i understand that yes
but i i believe that that the cev
according to what the hrt uh drivers and
said about that day was trying to get
around to to get
gas into the back of that compound which
they could not get to any other way
and i do not believe that there were any
any bodies found in that area the
closest bodies were found a little
further in
each one of those five bodies it's
reported had extensive according to the
autopsy report extensive body mutilation
now i don't know
i was expired they can respond i think
mr clark or you have a right to have two
responses here under our kind of ground
rules mr clark would you be the
appropriate one to respond in addition
to that was the attorney i believe the
question in part was was the attorney
general informed of the prospect of this
type of damage did you anticipate i mean
that type of question have you all been
made available of the briefing book that
we prepared for the attorney general
dated april the 12th
yes we have did you read it
it's not this report no no it's a
briefing book there's a briefing book
for the attorney general no sir well i'd
suggest you read it
thank you sir let me let me let me
explain that what it said in there
is that
the the part of the plan
as this thing extended on
was after 48 hours if there were
no
people coming out that there would be a
systematic
dismantling of the building that would
take place
the authority
delegated to the on-scene commander was
that if at any time
the davidians responded
and that the lives of the agents were
placed in danger
the on-scene commander had full
authority to escalate that plan
the decisions for that kind of thing
were left to the decision of the person
on the scene
that would have been mr jamar and the
destruction of the building was part of
that ultimate plan which was included in
that book
so the attorney general was aware you
could begin to crush the building six
hours in rather than 48 hours
i don't think i said that i'm i there
was a question this time has expired i i
cannot let you pursue that mr barr i
believe we're reserving on the right
side over here we only have mr taylor
left mr barr you're recognized for five
minutes
thank you
mr chairman
mr taylor does want to go mr chairman if
with the chair's approval
i would give 30 seconds of my time to mr
conyers and reserve the rest you may do
that okay mr conyers you're recognized
for 30 seconds of mr taylor's time and
i'll clock it here
oh i know you will mr chairman
thank you very much i wanted to return
to mr richard because we had a
discussion about the administration's
position on the exclusionary rule
and i wanted to agree with you that the
administration joined us in opposing
early on
a contract item h.r 666 that provides
that any evidence discovered as a result
of a good faith search is admissible
in evidence which
in essence does away with the warrant
requirement because
i doubt if anybody's going to come
forward and say they weren't in good
faith when they found the illegal
evidence but in the anti-terrorism bill
they had a sec there's a section there
that deals with search through a wiretap
the bill allows law enforcement agents
to obtain a wiretap
without a warrant
under emergency circumstances if an act
of terrorism is involved and it's going
on to be defined now terrorism is good
let me warn everybody here that i cannot
say you only have you have 30 seconds to
ask a question like at the end the time
the clock is is running for the whole
fight i'm not
uh
30 seconds
we're over a minute now are you aware of
of the point that i'm making here on
anti-terrorism mr richards
i am to this extent uh our congressman
that uh our position with respect to the
terrorism bill uh is as i've tried to
indicate before we believe consistent
with the mandate of the fourth amendment
uh we do believe it allows
wiretaps where terrorism is involved
without a warrant
congressman the current title three
which is the the uh
the um
wire type the general wiretap statute
does have a
an exigent circumstance requirement in
it already at this point which permits
uh when there are exigent circumstances
the utilization of wiretaps uh followed
by within i think 24 or 48 hours notice
to the court and and the submission uh
and i think it is that it is that
approach which we believe is consistent
with with the fourth amendment that is
embodied in terrorism bill so so you're
you've just said that you are supporting
uh a weakening of the uh
the exclusionary rule by allowing uh
terrorism now to be
involved in wiretapping no no on the
contrary
the the administration's position has
been well look stop please uh we'll
we'll do this on somebody else's time uh
you're available when we're not here
having hearings on waco and i'd like to
pursue this discussion with you
gentlemen
three minutes of mr taylor's time he has
two minutes remaining i presume he
wishes to reserve it
or do you want it now uh mr chairman
i'm gonna hold on to that two minutes
you're gonna hold on to it very well mr
[ __ ]
all right
i i will i will yield now down here to
mr barr five five minutes you're
recognized for five minutes mr barton
okay thank you mr chairman um
mr clark uh uh very briefly you
mentioned some briefing uh book uh it is
true is it not that the attorney general
is uh
admitted publicly that she didn't read
that that briefing book
i'm not aware of that i can't hear you
need to use microphone i'm not aware of
that okay well it is true
uh it's it's contained in uh in the the
deputy attorney general's report uh at
page 272. so you know my only point is
don't don't kind of uh uh you know
lecture us about it i mean she she
didn't read it either question but
that's all that's not a question i don't
want to make a big deal out of it your
implication i
don't think was appropriate
i'd like if i could please to mr bush if
you could
take this photograph
probably mr potts
i'd like to follow on some testimony of
yesterday
this is a picture taken immediately
after the fire with the the
rubble still smoldering in the
background showing the entry to the bus
the the underground bus
and uh
mr uh bush if you could uh show me the
the photograph that was up there
and point out the area
right here uh mr potts is the area that
mr bush is pointing to the area where
that goes into the bus
i believe so sir okay i mean if
i mean you're welcome to also i'd i
think that i think that's the area there
that's fine i don't know the area that
mr bush is pointing to is is the entry
into the bus right uh and the picture
that you have is after the after the
immediately after the fire
showing i believe does it not that all
but a very small corner of the bus
is covered up with dirt
i think we
we may have dug that out
i'm sorry we may have dug that out
so it may have been completely covered
up i think it may have been i i just
don't know okay
um
there is that is testimony that i'm
going to refer to from the uh the
court case uh the criminal action number
w93cro46
etc which is the case out of the u.s
district court for the western district
of texas
and what i'm going to refer to
is testimony by one of the government's
witnesses mr r.j craig who was driving
one of the vehicles that day
and his testimony
for example after this was during
extensive cross-examination
was that quote we received instructions
to knock the hole in the wall after
about 10 30
and then he goes on
the question to him is but the tunnel
the tunnel this is the tunnel into the
bus from the inside
the tunnel that you were trying to get
the cs gas into was lower than the area
that where you were dispersing it
and that any further question well you
went in to try to stop people from
getting into the tunnel area or the bus
area
to get into that area outside you've
already described that have you not
and then his answer is yes sir
and then there's further discussion that
that one was at page
5599 and then at page 5600
and the question is
so at the end of that building this is
where you expected there would be an
entryway into the bus
and then he says yes sir and then a
further question and that's why you were
directed to shoot the cs gas there
right and he says that's correct
uh and then a final question uh and a
final answer to put gas in the hallway
of the building to prevent people from
coming down the hall and getting into
the bus
the question is that to me seems
absolutely directly at odds with with
testimony yesterday and i don't think it
was yours correct me if i'm wrong but
testimony directly from
witnesses yesterday
that one of the purposes to allow
especially the kids to get out was
knowing the bus was at least somewhat
separated from the building there was a
trap door from the building into the bus
and that every effort was made to
hopefully sort of herd the kids towards
that that that location so they could go
through the trap door into the bus and
then the agent said one of the first
places they went to afterwards was going
into the bus
which it appears from that is completely
covered up with with dirt so that you
couldn't get into the bus
so the question is really twofold
can you explain the inconsistency i mean
it just seems to me that this uh that
this government witness in the court
case who was driving one of the vehicles
inserting the gas
says very clearly several times that his
instructions were to gas that part of
the building first by the trapdoor to
prevent people from going through the
trap door to get into the bus
was that is his testimony correct and
why is there this this seeming direct
inconsistency
i'm not sure that there is a consistency
and i and i'll do my best to answer your
question mr barr i'm not sure i'm the
best one to do it because the people on
site would be a lot a lot more effective
at knowing
where the tunnel was and how they could
get into it
i think that it's true that that was one
of the first places that was gassed
and it was excuse me while you're
answering that mr bush if you could put
up the schematic which shows the
trapdoor itself right by the underground
bus and point that out i'm sorry mr
punts
i think it was it's true that it was one
of the first places that was gassed uh
and and
part of that thinking was to prevent
people to
to move people toward the center of the
compound we were going to do this on an
incremental basis
and and just move them toward the center
we still held out a lot of hope even
because of the length of time you're
talking about six hours from the time
that this operation began
until the fire started we still held out
a lot of hope that even though that area
had been gas that they would go through
that area put the children through that
area and down into the bus which did
happen in clean air that he was
instructed to insert gas there by the
trap door to prevent people from getting
to the bus it would move them toward the
middle yes sir but it's not going to
prevent them on a long term basis that's
six hours later with that kind of
ventilation from going how would you get
people to escape by hurting them to the
center of the compound
as i said we hope that that the
immediate reaction might be that some
people would come out but this was not
an operation where we expected to put
some cs gas into a room right away and
and have a lot of people come out we
were trying to shrink the size of the
compound the other thing we were hoping
to do was to force some serious
negotiation to force david to get back
on the phone and start talking to us
seriously and working toward
a final conclusion that would have all
them come out without any more gassing
at all if possible
that was the hope mr barr your time has
expired
mr buoyer your record mr ehrlich mr
bowyer mr bowie are you recognized for
five minutes
thank you mr chairman mr hubbell
on the uh the end of april uh 15th i
mean you were painting quite a picture
here from a phone conversation that you
had had
with the men on the ground at waco with
regard to people getting tired tempers
are fraying
i mean all this leads to uh
the funneling effect towards geez some
decision must be made here we've got the
military advisors
telling janet reno that you should pull
pull the team off
i also
noted by some of the interviews
fbi really appears to be applying a lot
of implicit pressures and explicit
pressures
uh into the equations by saying
uh around april 12th advising the
attorney general that he that he karash
is beating the babies i mean there's a
lot of a lot of things here are being
put into a decision-making equation
that uh is placing a lot of stress on
attorney general who's not necessarily
uh too happy about the plan matter of
fact on april 16th in your conversations
uh here
uh according to richard and hubble
uh hubbell advised him that the attorney
general had disapproved the plan to end
the fbi standoff there got to be some
people that are really ticked off here
that the attorney you're smiling that
must be true no i wouldn't say that
congressman what i would say is that
that the fbi and every it was unanimous
believed that this was the only way to
get the children out safely
and they believed in their plan and they
were certainly
certainly going to give us every reason
they believed it would work i believe
that it was my job and other people's
jobs to understand that but richard and
evaluating the decision richard's
response to you is the fbi would not be
pleased
so i i think we can read a lot into that
let me let me uh
make one other comment i'm going to
yield them to mr bryant of tennessee and
and that is we all understand whether
we're here in the political world it
doesn't make a difference in what world
we're in here in the united states we
understand about the aspects of
responsibility and authority
and i i i will submit there's one thing
that has become very bothersome to me
and that is uh i have great respect for
those who are in the field uh someone
referred to it as a thin blue line the
other day uh we have tremendous respect
what bothers me tremendously is are the
politicos in this one the political
appointees either they're saying well
geez either i didn't have the authority
i was only enacting at the time or it
was outside my jurisdiction or jesus
someone had given me better better data
information i i could have made a great
intelligent decision so that briefing
may not have been there on so it's
almost like jeez i wasn't wasn't in
control at the time but i sure am now
it'll never happen again congressman i'm
not aware of any political employee
involved in this other than myself and
the attorney general and i believe we
both take responsibility for what
happened
right i think that's important that the
other thing that's important is when
janet reno says i assume all full
responsibility the buck stops with me i
think that's absolutely wrong because
she works for somebody and we know who
that is and this is the chief executive
officer of the land i yield the the
balance of my time the gentleman from
tennessee uh very quickly i want to
follow up if i could uh i think mr clark
raises a very good point
with regard to the question of shadow
raising i want to follow up on that what
i understand it happened general reno
had given approval for the gas plan on
the 17th after changing her mind
uh she said that as a part of this plan
that
if the gas didn't work for 48 hours
then the vehicles uh the the tanks could
begin a systematic opening up or
disassembly of the building
and that she did in fact give the own
site commander mr jamar authority to
make decisions on that if if something
happened and i accept that i think
that's legitimate
and there's no question about it that
six hours into this 48 hours in fact
around 10 30 their time 11 30 this time
the fbi did begin to move to disassemble
the building as mr shattuck so clearly
pointed out
my question though is that this is a
major shift you've jumped ahead 42 hours
in your strategic plan
this is a major change you're tearing
down the building at that point at least
parts of it
and uh ms reno i think had left this the
strategy session at that point she had a
commitment to go to maryland to give a
speech
and she's enroute up there or giving a
speech my question is what effort and
she retained by the way throughout this
the authority to stop at any point stop
this this plan at any point did she not
she did she did
was she advised of this major change 42
hours in advance that y'all were now
going in to tear this building down or
at least parts of it was she notified
did she have a car phone i'm sure she
had there were ways to contact her did
anyone contact her to let her know this
i believe she i may be wrong timing wise
and somebody may help me i believe that
some of the destruction the building had
occurred before she left
to go
uh to give that speech the decision was
made she didn't want to go
make that speech but the decision was
made that they thought that if she
didn't go give that speech that would be
some indication but i i wanted to tell
you but i believe that yeah and i'm not
being critical i didn't mean to be
critical that she was giving that
tactical i'm just saying you know she
had the authority to call off that rate
at any point yeah i'm wondering was she
aware that you know you were advancing
y'all were advancing the plan very very
quickly i i believe that there had been
destruction of the building before she
left now
miss lloyd or larry you might know
better than me
mr brian go ahead yeah mr brian i i
don't recall the exact sequence of
events and the timing of them but in
terms of this being a major shift uh i
would probably characterize it a little
bit differently because it was part of
the overall
plan with mr jamar having the authority
to
move that up and
mr hubble points out that
almost in the beginning
uh when the tanks came under fire that
they were putting holes in the uh front
of the building our monitoring of this
was via a television that was available
to all of the public and we could see
that there was some destruction
occurring
throughout this process so it to me
was not a a
major shift from the
natural progression of the plan
thank you mr bryant uh mr condit you're
recognized for five minutes yes um i i
want to have a quick question for mr
potts and i uh appreciate the panel i
know most things have been asked to hear
already but um
yesterday or a couple days ago all these
hearings are kind of running into each
other but i asked the fbi about the
possibility of a fire plan and i think
in your bio you said that they would not
sign off on the fire plan at our sign
off on the the raid had there not been a
a
fire plan
was the fire plan followed
if our plan is is written up did not
they they notified the the
the fire departments
they had gotten a list of the fire
departments they had checked on their
availability
they had
checked on the amount of time that it
would take for them to get to the scene
and
so i think in in that respect that it
was of course the
problem was even once the fire
trucks arrived they couldn't be allowed
to go to the scene to fight it
well was there any anticipation and
forgive me if if you've said this in
your bio
any anticipation because of the prophecy
of mr karesh that there would be fire
and blood and explosion that there
you know that maybe we ought to had a
something that would anticipate that so
we could have
stopped the fire
you know sir we talked extensively about
what was available we even had our
liaison officer with the department of
defense checked with them to see if
there was some kind of armored vehicle
that could be used as a firefighting uh
we we talked about planes that could
drop water and we were afraid if we
tried to if there was a fire and there
was water that was dropped it would
crash
the roof and so i mean it was a
the best we could do was the fire
departments that were available was done
so
i've got to yield to my my good friend
from mississippi but maybe i can get a
yes or no on this um
so the fire plan
was not followed or was it followed
sorry it was following it was followed
okay i've come down here to yield to my
good friend from mississippi the rest of
my time and i do appreciate your
response thank you
thank you thank you
and
mr potts i had the opportunity last
night to read your testimony
and
i was at another hearing yesterday
so
please forgive me if i'm being redundant
but i would like to clarify on the day
of the second raid the day of the last
raid
did the fbi fire one shot
even one shot at the division
not throughout the entire standout
standoff
the the vehicles the heavy armored
vehicles that are
shown
were they armed with anything other than
tear gas grenades no sir we as a matter
of fact when they first arrived we had
the barrels taken off and told david
that these were not offensive weapons
that were bringing in
how about who was driving them were they
military people driving no sir we had no
military people driving and we had to
put our hostage rescue team people
through a crash course on learning to
drive those vehicles okay mr chairman i
would like to submit for the record a
dod memo that outlines that the we're
going to the vehicles were going to be
transferred
maintenance would be paid for by the fbi
there would be fbi people driving them
and that they would not be armed without
objection thank you
i'm
further interested
in a statement that you made that's a
pretty strong statement so i want you to
repeat it if you feel comfortable
repeating it
the autopsies revealed that no one was
harmed by the tear gas
or had toxic levels of any component of
tear gas in their systems
who are we referring to sir
heard me i'm sorry this is from your
statement right who are you referring to
in that statement's on page 11 of your
statement that no one inside the
compound had
so you talk about the davidians yes sir
i'm perplexed by something you said a
little bit earlier because we keep
hearing about 20 children and
but you'd said something to the effect
that qureshi implied they were all at
this point these were all his biological
children on march 5th we got our last
child out even though we continued
throughout to get more out on march i
believe it was the seventh or eighth
somewhere in there he indicated when we
were talking to him about sending more
children out he said no you're talking
about my biological children now that's
different
so in addition to everything else he did
he used his own biological children
as human shields
to keep law enforcement from serving a
legal warrant on him and arresting him
for
firearms violations
compiling a hit list of former members
possibility of illegal aliens there
child molestation that could go into
statutory race
uh
holding people there against his will
am i correct and saying yes sir you are
i have i've asked i believe this is the
same panel we've had before us right
everyone's been at the table
okay so then then i'm gonna ask you the
same question i've asked everybody else
is there anything that you've seen or
heard or read
justify the murder of those four atf
agents at the hands of david corrections
followers
or in any way
absolve david koresh from direct
responsibility for the deaths of those
80 people who died at his compound
no
no sir would you state your names for
the record then floyd clark the answer
is no
mark richard the answer is resoundingly
no thank you sir mr chairman i reserve
still my two minutes
so noted mr ehrlich you're recognized
for five minutes thank you mr chairman
um
mr hobb just one quick general question
for you sir uh
you have been uh
you have uh
watched these hearings or you're
certainly familiar what's been going on
you've seen the
the give and take with respect to the
issue of the propriety of these hearings
sir my question to you is uh
is it your opinion that these
proceedings these hearings
constitute a
legitimate exercise of this body's
oversight authority
i do believe it is a legitimate exercise
and
if anything comes out of these hearings
that will help prevent what happened
that's
that's worthwhile
i mean prevent it from happening again
is the way i would like for that the
attorney general has always said
we are the only thing we can do we can't
engage in recrimination but we can
engage in trying to determine what we
could do to prevent
uh this from happening again
sir i i appreciate your forthright
answer and with that i will yield to mr
chav
gentlemen uh mr uh clark uh before when
uh mr shattuck was asking me some
questions you referred to the briefing
book
uh relative to the tank going in and
tearing off the back of that building is
this the briefing book that you're
talking about here i guess not april
19th briefing book this is not it that
is not okay mr hubble let me ask you
some questions sir
um
mr hubble in the scraps of uh paper
that are being referred to as the
vincent foster suicide note
is this sentence fbi lied in their
report to the ag i assume meaning
attorney general
now there's been some speculation in the
press that this sentence may have been
related to the travel gate affair
as originally thought but
not to the travel gate affair but
perhaps to waco
and you knew mr foster well
do you have any sense of what mr foster
was referring to there yes i do and mr
foster believed that the fbi had not
been truthful in reporting to the
attorney general about
a conversation the fbi had with mr
kennedy relating to the travel office it
had nothing to do with waco congress
thank you sir
um mr potts um
as mr conde referred to a little bit ago
um you were aware that there was uh
not gonna be any firefighting equipment
actually at the compound prior to the
final assault is that right
that that would have been obviously the
preference a decision by the on-scene
commander well there wasn't any
firefighting there was there was not
okay now our time's kind of short so i
got to keep them relatively short now
this was basically because uh of concern
the fbi being concerned that the people
driving firefighting equipment might be
fired upon is that right
you mean as to why they were not there
be before yeah
fbi didn't have firefighting equipment
prior to the attack because they were
concerned that the davidians might shoot
at the people in the firefighting trucks
correct
that's that's
correct yes all right yet yesterday um
it's my recollection that that you said
that you were not expecting any gunfire
in that assault isn't that right
i i indicated that i thought that the
plan we had come out come up with
significantly reduced the likelihood of
us being fired on immediately when we
started the operation so i think the
answer is yes yes okay now um
in in planning
uh
very large uh actions of this sort like
the going in at the building
you do a lot of planning like if this
happens than this we'll do this and if
this happens it will do this correct yes
sir now
didn't you consider or did you consider
that
fire might well occur in this instance
and if it does we do this
yes sir
we did
but it obviously didn't work
sir i i think that the information we
have from the fire commanders is that
they
even if they've gotten in there
much much earlier there's nothing they
could have done first of all we couldn't
put them in there earlier because shots
were still coming out of the compound
and the safety of the firemen
they would not have been safe and
secondly
even if okay my time is relatively short
let me get to mr hubbell thank you mr
hubble um relative i think you said
before you expected
uh the davidians particularly mothers
who had kids in there uh
to come out when the when the cs gas was
pumped in there correct that's correct
now had you were you familiar with mrs
sparks who she was uh the lady the child
protective service lady who'd been in
and talked to crush a number of times i
believe i had read a report from her did
you know before that happened
before the assault
read the report did you know of her
existence and what she had to say i i
knew of her existence in a report
prior to the the assault yes okay and
and you're you're aware that her view
were you aware uh
sir mr potts were you aware
which which view i'm sorry were you
aware of mrs uh sparks uh the child and
what her view was of crashing the folks
in there
and were you both aware of the fact that
that
she in her opinion the davidians had
this
it was a very unusual religion i think
we all agree with that but they were
they were basically uh
they thought they had this uh
apocalyptic view of things and and uh
that
uh that we we mean the united states
government i wasn't in congress at the
time so i wasn't part of the government
at that time but the babylonian united
states government was going to come
after him sometime and they were all
going to die and either go to heaven or
whatever and you all were aware they
basically had a different mindset than
that yet we thought that when we pump
the cs gas in there they just come
walking out with their kids i didn't
think they'd come walking out
i think if you you had listened to
like i did and others to the defense
department talking about the effects
that the gas would have on adult males
and what would happen
they were
quite convincing to me
that the women and the children and some
of the males would come running out of
that compound right because the gas was
so bad so on the one hand it was so bad
that it did these things to men but then
on the other hand we always are
downplaying what it would have done to
the kids you can't have it both ways
i believe that
the assumption was
that it would have the same effect that
the children and the and the women and
the men would come out of the compound
as a result of the insertion of gas we
wouldn't have inserted the gas if we
didn't think it would work mr chabot
your time has expired mr klinger you're
recognized for five minutes uh thank you
very much mr chairman and i would like
to uh yield back my time to you thank
you very much
uh mr mr clark uh
i have examined what appears to be your
post-event interview by
the normal investigative internal
processes that were done over at the
agency the fbi
in july
of 93 and it appears to me that you had
some early misgivings about the gas
insertion plan
that you later became convinced of it
but in that process
trying not to read the whole statement
here
you
seem to be
willing to accept it based primarily on
your
concern or desire to see this as a go
slow process that is uh the extended 48
hour plan rather than that let's go do
it all at one time like the military may
have suggested they would have done in
the military operation
uh and ultimately that was obviously
accepted you also expressed some concern
about the firing of projectiles uh at
one point into the compound could you
tell us why you were concerned
about the do it fast plan why you
preferred this extended plan
why you eventually accepted the extended
plan but were hesitant on the other i
think our
mr chairman i think that
the the fbi's position on this from
day one
was to be very deliberate
very careful
and not to do anything that would be
provocative that would
cause some reaction anything that we
might do
might be misinterpreted by those inside
and i think you've probably heard a
testimony that
before there would be movement of these
uh cevs that they would the negotiators
would call in and tell the people inside
ahead of time before they were moved so
that
we didn't do anything that would send a
signal that could be interpreted
or misinterpreted as any kind of
aggressive action on our part that may
cause them
to
react in a in a
way that caused the situation to
escalate
so the the plan
all along was
consistent with that thinking and as we
developed the plan for using the cs
we wanted it to follow that same kind of
thinking
so an incremental
deliberate
giving advance notice
giving ample opportunity
without any unnecessary provocation
that
we would bring about a peaceful solution
you were afraid that with the
provocation if it occurred if it were
interpreted that way as aggressive they
might either try to break out and have
some confrontation that would result in
death or suicide or whatever you didn't
know a fire might be started but
obviously but it was that i mean i'm
just trying to get the reason why you
didn't want to provoke them i think well
i mean we had already the february 28th
as a as an example
and it was
very difficult to
predict with any degree
of accuracy what
they might do suicide was considered
remote at the final point in time
according to all the reports but that
was a consideration was it i think we
tried to consider every possible
option or alternative that they that
again that's part of why you didn't want
to act aggressively why you wanted the
delayed the implemented plan now
but at the end you accepted a plan which
had an acceleration feature in it and
obviously we all know that it was
accelerated and these projectiles were
fired
and it was condensed and that
is something i gather was done
reluctantly but what i guess i'm getting
at is at the time that this whole thing
occurred and the projectiles were fired
and all of this happened
were you aware
that mr jamar had expressed
at least he's felt that he expressed to
us here the other day
an opinion
that it was a 99 likelihood that the
vehicles that were going to insert this
gas would in fact
succumb to fire and that if they
succumbed to fire as part of the plan
there would have been an acceleration
and therefore
were you aware that jamar thought that
mr pot said yesterday he wasn't aware of
that
uh i haven't had a chance to
talk to mr jamar
about that and i'm not sure
that that
feeling or a position is a
retrospective or prospective
assessment i can tell you that in our
conversations
with mr jamar on the 7th and 8th that he
did not voice that and i think that the
caution and concern that i was outlining
for you was shared by all of the people
well i think i think that we exp
especially after the activity that had
taken place on the 18th
that we
believed that there was a great
likelihood that they would not respond
with the government could you describe
for us before my time expires your
opinion about how long the hostage
rescue team could have remained deployed
before it would need to undergo rest and
retraining
after the 19th of april i mean that was
the day obviously this happened but how
much longer
uh i think that we
probably had a couple of weeks
maybe a little bit longer
in talking with uh both the dick rogers
as well as his uh people at work for him
when we were out there uh i think that
if you would have asked the hrt people
themselves i think they would have told
you that they could have continued i
think that the judgment of the superiors
uh
was that it was getting to a point in
time where they did
would need uh to be pulled out and to uh
refurbish their uh their training uh we
we were making plans to do that
if in fact this was not an accepted plan
we were looking at putting
swap teams in to replace them but i have
to also add that when you do that
you greatly reduce the ability to
protect yourself and place
the replacement
agents and personnel
in in a higher level of danger for a lot
of reasons
and i won't go into those but there are
some tactical reasons in terms of the
familiarity with how they were
monitoring what was happening
their ability to use certain weapons
that were in the the inventory of the
hrt that were not available nor were the
swat team people trained to use them to
combat the similar kinds of weapons
inside so you you were you were
increasing the risk to the agents but
we were we were formulating plans to do
that if we had to do that but how much
how much time did you think they had
before you'd have to do that two or
three weeks probably
thank you very much
i would now normally recognize mr taylor
he's the only one remaining on your side
and we only have me over here do we know
if mr taylor is back there coming back
for his two minutes
uh i think he stepped out uh just
briefly is it possible to reserve his
time is there anyone on the other
there's nobody else over here but me and
i've uh i'm gonna
you have time i think
all right then i yield to mr zella for
five minutes thank you very much uh mr
clark
uh thank you i think you helped solve
one of our problems uh we've been trying
to get these briefing books you
indicated this is not the briefing book
in question am i right correct
and uh and and then the 302's indicated
there were two books we have not been
able to just now thanks to you uh been
able to get this from your department uh
we've asked for it we haven't been able
to get it we now have it and thank you
this is part of the problem here of
trying to be able to get to the bottom
of this thing there's so much stuff out
there
um
you know like on on february 28th the
atf took films of every day except that
day the stuff's missing and so this is
very very helpful
i i guess the paragraph that i'd like to
read on page 26
if all subjects fail to surrender after
48 hours of tear gas then a cev with a
modified blade will commence a
systematic opening up disassembly of the
building structure
until all subjects are located
and i guess my question is is did the ag
read this book
and that paragraph and this seems to be
the rules of engagement
um and since they were modified and we
went in six hours
what i think there's more to that
mr chairman and i can't answer your
question about whether the ag read it or
not
okay so we don't know whether she read
the rules of engagement uh we don't know
whether she was told about the change in
the rules of engagement 48 hours or six
i don't think there was any change
but in fact
that tank in the blade and the removal
that section of the building i think
there's another section in there uh if
you uh look and i don't recall we will
we will read it but
could you i just i think you and i have
a different uh uh interpretation of what
that says do you have a page number or
reference we could have staff take a
quick look at it
while you're doing that i was just
informed also mr chairman that the book
was provided to the committee some time
ago so it just got disappeared maybe in
the forty eight thousand pieces of paper
that we got that was unorganized and you
probably understand the limit that we
have to go through i'm sure that's
that's government at its worst i guess
uh mr hubble
you're a close friend of the president
is that correct that's correct and a
golfing buddy
we play golf together yes congressman
and uh i'm not asking scores or anything
like that do you socialize with the
president
i used to
uh
i'm not sure i understand uh
do you spend any time at did you spend
any time at all between the 15th 16th
and 17th and 18th with him
that's the month of april well let me
try to go back you had a two-hour
conversation with mr sage as far as waco
is concerned
and i guess what i'm wondering is if if
this close relationship of yours
i mean
if you're these kind of buddies is there
any way at all that
that and i look the same thing with mr
altman's letter to mr benson on april
15th here's two pieces two major players
here
that are both saying that are both
involved in something that could blow up
literally and and the subject never came
up in any discussions you never pick up
the phone you never talked to them you
never told them
on on official business i communicated
with the president through the white
house council
that's interesting
then did you feel compelled to pick up
the phone
well right now i was confident that the
white house counsel was telling the
president what i was reporting to the
white house council but how did you know
i'm i i have great confidence in mr
nussbaum mr foster and mr lindsey
well
i just uh
i i just think that that here's a case
where we're going ahead with a plan
that's going to affect almost 100
americans that we're going to gas the
situation that ended up with disastrous
results
and i just find a a person who is as
close as you are you wouldn't pick up
the phone and
if you remember right it wasn't until
i i believe
friday or saturday that the decision was
made to go ahead
and at that point the
attorney general did call the president
of the united states and i was in the
room when she made that call
okay but you you spent two hours with
mrs sage getting an up-to-date briefing
including the
apparent
uh surrender plan
or whatever you would refer that to um
and two hours on the phone on the 15th
and you didn't tell anything to the
president until the 19th when
you didn't i guess you let him know that
i did i did not talk to the president
about waco prior to the 19th
and
on on any basis i communicated through
the white house council but i did brief
the white house council
about my conversations with mr say
did president call you back no no he i
didn't call him i mean okay but you
briefed him through the council i assume
you assumed that the council briefed him
yeah he then did nothing
he did he talked to the attorney general
herself
on the 18th
i yield back to the chairman for the
last 30 seconds well i have i just have
one question that i want to follow with
mr clark in that 30 seconds mr clark a
minute ago you'd indicated in the time
that you had had an opportunity to
to think about this that you did not
have any awareness of mr jamar's
conclusion of
that that was 99 likelihood that the
vehicles would be fired on when they put
the gas in
uh prior to uh to it happening and of
course we both concur that what mr jamar
said and he said it yesterday
that the plan called for an acceleration
of that gas being inserted if that
eventuality occurred
had you been aware jamar felt that way
had he informed you prior to the 19th
would you have informed the attorney
general of that was that significant
enough an opinion that you would have
passed that on to her i think all
through this operation mr chairman was
that we
tried to ensure to the fullest of our
capabilities that the department of
justice and the attorney general was
aware of every detail but that would
have my point is that would have been
significant enough you would have passed
it on to every detail
would it would have caused you
to have changed your opinion i i would
have
explored that with him to try to
understand his rationale
the fact is is that we had those
discussions and it did not come up in
those discussions
very well two minutes yielded to mr
taylor you have two minutes left mr
taylor
okay i will time the two minutes we
can't remember mr chairman it's my
understanding that miss thurman was
going to give me two times you want the
time first actually um
mr chairman
she's gonna give me two plus my two that
gives me four cut me off i was getting
ready to just yield you four minutes
oh i'll settle for two okay i'll give
you four
okay
first two minutes right now thank you mr
chairman
i'd like to go back and again mr potts i
apologize that armed services was
meeting yesterday
i might be redundant but i don't think i
am
you say in your statement and this is a
sworn testimony that you've given to
this committee that at 1207 pm the
davidians said simultaneous fires at
three or more locations within the
compound
it was established by teams of
independent arson experts and fire
department
analysis experts from electronic
surveillance over years by videotape
taken from aircraft by observations from
fbi agents
and by admissions of davidian survivors
do you stand by that statement
there is no doubt in your mind that
those fires were set by anyone other
than the davidians no sir absolutely no
doubt and that three fires were said
simultaneously by the davidians yes sir
by a pre obviously a pre-arranged plan
that's correct
i would
uh
mr hubble since we were cut off last
time
you could not answer the question i've
asked every other panel
but i want to ask you as well
because you've obviously studied this
issue a lot is there anything that
you've seen or read or heard justify the
murder of those four atf agents the
wounding of 20 more and i've been taking
it a step further
in any way
negate the guilt
of david koresh in the death of those 80
people 80 people he could have said get
up and leave and they would have left no
congressman not at all nothing okay
miss thurman thank you very much i yield
back the balance of my time to miss
thurman
that i will yield to mr scott two
minutes
dr salem i'm going to be a little bit
redundant just so we can nail this down
on the safety of cs gas obviously
anybody subjected to that will be very
much traumatized while they're subjected
to it but you indicated that there are
no
documented
cases of death as a result of exposure
to cs gas
is that right
are there any citations of medical
problems lasting more than 30 days for
adults or children
of from exposure to
cs gas
that you're aware of no sir
does cs gas cause skin to burn
it causes skin irritation which is
exacerbated if it's wet
and how long does that
last
that depends on the severity of the
burden cause blistering
and not not usually in some rare cases
it may
i think i believe there is one instance
of that that's been recorded thank you
mr chairman i yield back the balance of
time to mrs thurman
at this time i would yield to miss
jackson lee
mr thurman i thank you very much and i
had asked a question
of
director sessions mr hubbell and i had
not got a chance to pursue with you
let me welcome you and and uh
acknowledge that this is not a question
of an indictment this is a question for
information
i do recall however tragically under the
leadership or under the time that uh
president ronald reagan served this
nation well
uh that
265
young men lost their lives in their
sleep in lebanon
i would imagine that there were
officials
that made decisions
that might have
augmented that tragedy even though they
were military personnel they were at
sleep
my question is that we have been
confronted with a very serious question
of cover-up
cover up to the extent that you play
golf with the president
you're a friend of the president and
i'll maintain that today
but that why didn't he know or why
is the blame not being placed at the
door of the white house
i do think we can fix some things in the
system in terms of how many times we
review
a decision like that
but help me understand
if you can recount again that process
where you would not place the blame
at the president and whether or not
there was a cover-up
well let me first say there is no
cover-up
i've never seen
an issue examined like this waco
situation there are reports after
reports
and that's fine
but first of all i did not talk to the
president about this the attorney
general did
i don't place the blame of what happened
in waco on these good people over here
at this table
what
who killed those people was david koresh
or vernon howe
we we live with those decisions that we
made we wish we had some of them back
but we were
i hope
that david koresh was a master of
manipulation
and i hope if people try to place the
blame
on the deaths of those children and
women in the compound on somebody other
than david koresh i believe they are
continually
being manipulated again by david koresh
he is the one who murdered those people
it's sad
we live with it
we dream about it
but the blame lies at the feet of david
koresh not the president of the united
states not the attorney general
not the people who are at this table but
i will tell you i take responsibility
for some of those decisions that were
made to go into that compound i was
responsible other people at this table
were responsible the attorney general
was responsible
and and we wish we had tried something
else knowing what we know now
but the blame lies at the feet
of david koresh not the president united
states and not the attorney general of
the united states
thank you very much mr clark very
quickly
did you get an answer or did you get a
chance to answer mr zella for what the
difference in the interpretation was as
he saw it compared to what you saw yes i
uh
the clarification is is that once the
people in waco
came under fire or that the lives of the
people in this operation were placed in
jeopardy because of actions by the
people inside
the on-scene commander had full
authority and full discretion to do
whatever in his judgment was necessary
to provide for their protection in
response to that
mr chairman at this time um you all have
talked to a great extent about the
problems with the documents and
and the 23 000 or 30 000 pieces i just i
just need to make a very quick
announcement of some interns that we'd
like to thank on our side that helped us
go through those documents as well and
this is their last day today so if i
could thank dean atkins uh michael
beaver stephanie fryde
saviero grazie grazioglio veneer um
dan mackel honey mackelhene yasumi
sanchez and john stevens we just want to
acknowledge the work that they did in
trying to put this information together
for us
thank you very much i believe everybody
else has asked all their questions and i
have five minutes left to yield to
myself
i want to make a couple of questions
that relate to the sage conversation uh
with you mr hubbell on the 15th of april
i think that was a fairly decisive two
hour discussion is my understanding
correct that mr potts mr richard mr
clark were all participants in that
conversation you all were listening in
or was this a speaker phone can somebody
tell me if you were i believe it was
speakerphone so you heard everything mr
hubble heard right that's correct there
were additional people in uh uh on that
conversation mr keaney i got down was
according to the justice department
report is that correct uh that's correct
so there was there was a group of you
around there but four of you were who
were there are sitting out there today
do any of the other three of you pots
richards or clark have any recollections
of that conversation that would differ
from
the conclusions mr hubble gave us on the
points we asked about particularly
pertaining to
mr sage's conclusions that
the attorney's efforts at negotiating in
the end were really no more than an
additional manipulation by uh david
korish and that he didn't think there
was any hope the negotiations at this
point i mean that's the flavor we have
i'm trying to summarize it fairly
that that is certainly uh uh
the gist of my recollection of the
conversation in essence that that we
haven't been able to negotiate anything
during this cause uh uh the the the
course of uh uh efforts on the standoff
to resolve the standoff that we were
in essence uh stymied by this he's a
manipulator uh and it's going nowhere mr
clark said just just of your
recollection as well uh yes and one one
additional uh piece that i i think it
also uh was brought up that this was not
the first time that mr de guerin and mr
zimmerman had assurances from
uh mr quresh that he was going to give
up i believe there were some
conversations in early april that
uh koresh indicated that sometime
between the second and the tenth or
something like that that he was also
going to give up so this was just more
of the same and mr ponce you've already
testified to some extent yesterday about
this was anything else you'd add to that
no sir it's the same uh question for you
did any of the
four of you hubble potts richard or
clark recall at any time mr sage saying
to you specifically that de garan had
indicated to him that
he believed that as de guerin believed
that he could bring that courage would
come out that he was within 10 to 15
days
of the 14th which was the day before
when the whole discussion had taken
place with sage over the latest
developments
did any of you do any of you remember
sage saying that to you or not saying it
to you
was that or is that materially
it would have been material as
everything that was said was material
i have some recollection of him talking
about that the garen thought that he
would ultimately come out
uh i do that but i don't specifically
remember anything a timetable right mr
potts do you remember time i i can't
think of any that much particularity
right mr richard do you remember no i i
can't answer mr clark i can't edit all
right now my point to you is had
uh
that been conveyed to you that
daguerreon felt passionately that that
things had really changed this time is
really different and that courage would
come out in 10 to 15 days because the
attitude had totally changed that he was
no longer thinking he was the martyr but
now the messenger which is what we've
been told by the guerin would that have
made any difference to you and your
state of mind at that point of time
would you would your advice to the
attorney general but any different any
of you i don't want chairman you you you
put a little different flavor on it when
you said the attitude had changed if
that had been conveyed to you i'm not
assuming that it had i'm asking you in
your state of mind at that time based on
what you knew if that had been conveyed
to you would your your advice to the
attorney general if any different would
you have conveyed that fact i would have
explored it with mr sage all right what
about you mr potts i would i simply
would look to mr sage who's talking to
him every day for his evaluation of
whether there'd been an attitudinal
change as opposed to just but the fact
that it alone would not have been
sufficient mr richard i i would have
looked like mr pods to to the assessment
of the negotiators was this a a serious
change by by correction was it uh just
so it really wouldn't have mattered if
mr sages said it wasn't it wouldn't make
any difference mr clark
i would have
reacted the same way i would have
explored that possibility with others
that i would have balanced their
judgment with his uh maybe not just
limited to mr sage but others that would
be in a position uh to give that in well
let me make a comment or two here in the
final conclusions of your panel i think
that you all did a very thorough
evaluation you did it honestly you did
it your best judgment and you gave
obviously the attorney general your best
judgment on the assault with the uh cs
gas
i must say that there are some things
that still trouble me one of them is the
fact that mr jamar's feelings about this
particularly his feelings that the 99
certainty that this would
result in firing on the vehicles and in
turn we all knew and you all knew that
would accelerate he knew that would
accelerate the cs gas plan the fact he
never said it apparently to any of you
and it never got back to the ag and it
wasn't part of the deliberation
proceedings in light of the fact that
most seem to know and mr clark you've
expressed particular concern
that the more aggressive assault which
did in fact take place as a result
of the firing on these vehicles and the
failure of the people to come out
would and did result in in potentially
what exactly happened the reaction that
was very negative so i'm disturbed by
that i think we all should be i think
you should be
secondly i believe that in summary here
today my only other thought is that uh i
do not know the value of what mr de
garan had to say in terms of his final
thing i can understand why you wouldn't
give it weight why mr sage didn't you
would you want to give him what weight
he did but it seemed very impassioned
and obviously he genuinely believed it
and it is disturbing that it was not
given more weight by mr sage but under
maybe it's understandable what doesn't
seem to me in all of this i've heard
today we're going to have more
testimonies seemed that all that
reasonable though was the assumption
that these parents who devoted
themselves to courage who were taught
that the outside world was babylon and
that an fbi attack was the beginning of
the apocalyptic end would pick up their
infants and run out of the compound when
the cs gas was fired it seems to me that
it would be more reasonable for you to
have assumed that they would pick up
their suffering children put as mr hyde
said yesterday put wet rags over their
mouths hide in the most remote places
they could find and simply wait which
apparently or something like that's what
they did
i think of course that all goes and begs
the question with respect to whether or
not you got the best advice or whether
you didn't and
that that seems to me to summarize where
we are today
we've completed this panel
and at this point i would thank you very
much for your coming today for
participating and we'll be ready now at
this point to proceed with the with the
next panel mr bryant mr bryant adam's
consent to attach to the record uh those
two pages which reflect the phone calls
that i referred to without objection in
the ap article without without objection
mr chairman
uh might i i'd like to ask also
unanimous consent there was a photograph
that uh i don't know whether mr uh pot
still has that
we'd like to
insert that in the record as well by
unanimous consent this is the photograph
of the entry area into the bus
immediately after the fire
and also mr chairman rather than
introduce a lengthy transcript from the
trial and i'd like the following pages
entered in by unanimous consent these
are the pages that i referred to earlier
uh of the trial transcript pages 1425
5562 five five six three five five six
five to five five six eight
five five seven seven five five eight
one and five five eight two
fifty six hundred fifty six oh one and
fifty six sixteen without objection mr
chairman yes deserving the right to
object reserving the right to object
mr barr
uh could you uh remind us what those
pages refer to okay this is uh the the
trial transcript from the uh the case in
the western district of texas the u.s
district court waco division of the the
the criminal case and these were the
pages that i uh specifically referred to
in in my questioning of mr potts and
what was the subject matter the subject
matter was the spraying of tear gas into
the area by the bus and the trap door
leading to the bus
without objection is so admitted i again
want to thank this panel you're excused
we're going to introduce the next panel
but we need obviously to clear you out
and have them come in i believe that our
fire experts are here and we will
commence the next panel immediately
we're not taking any lunch break other
than when we get a vote because we need
to be able to proceed today
i think everybody understood that
possibly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
if mr potts and others could clear the
area and we could bring in our other
panel i i would really like to introduce
them before we have a boat
[Music]
actually well no they're going to are
they just getting questions
[Music]
well no they're going to they're just
getting questions
[Music]
and if we could have the panel come
forward if we're here the first uh that
i want to introduce is rick sherrow he
is an army trained arson investigator
after 20 years in army ordinance he
served as a senior explosives officer
with the batf he left that post in 1992
and has been a private arson and
explosives investigator since that time
i'm not sure i think all the names are
now up here if mr sharer could make his
way i see his name tag over here on the
far left
next we have with us on this final panel
of today paul gray
who is an arson investigator at the
houston fire department and was the
leader of the justice department special
fire team review team whose findings are
included in the justice department
report i believe miss
sheila jackson lee would like to welcome
mr gray as a houstonite would you like
to do so
i certainly would mr chairman let me um
offer to mr gray assistant chief gray
and leadership that he brings to the
houston fire department and i might take
a moment of personal privilege just to
say the best department in the world but
in any event to welcome here to
washington and to acknowledge the
houston fire department for its hard
work
both in terms of the effort made in the
tragedy of waco but as well
in the efforts made on behalf of the
citizens of oklahoma city so i welcome
you
to washington d.c and certainly give my
respects to the houston fire department
thank you mr chairman you're quite
welcome the next witness we have is
james james quinn terry did i pronounce
that right yes that's correct thank you
who also served on the fire review team
for justice he is a professor of fire
protection engineering at the university
of maryland he has served as chief for
fire research at the national institute
of standards and technology he is the
current chairman of the international
association for fire safety science
and then our final witness is mr clive
doyle he is a branch of davidian who
survived the fire inside the compound
and will be our other and last witness
on this panel today if you would i
noticed you're all standing if you raise
your right hand
and
i ask you would do you swear or affirm
that the testimony that you're about to
give today will be the truth the whole
truth nothing but the truth
thank you please be seated but the
record reflected all four for the first
round of questioning to mr klinger five
minutes
thank you mr chairman and i would like
to ask mr doyle who is the
uh only the second i think french
davidian who has uh appeared before the
before the committees uh and is a
survivor and was there on the event
if he would uh
be able to
give us a narrative from your
perspective
of of the events that took place mr
doyle
if i may i'd like to read a statement
that i prepared
which gives somewhat of a narrative
well you may do that but we are under
this five-minute rule so we'll the best
you can to uh to you don't have to limit
it precisely to it but we'll have a vote
here in a minute
so please proceed
i'd just like to thank the members of
the subcommittee for this opportunity to
speak at these hearings
if truth and justice are really the
important concerns here then it puzzles
me that only two
of the survivors
have been given an opportunity
uh to speak at these hearings that is
david thibodeau and myself
several survivors i know were in the
washington area last week
and were not called and also i know that
those
nine survivors that are in prison
would definitely have like to have added
their
experience to these hearings
so it is my privilege and i feel my duty
to address
the subcommittee members
on behalf of those survivors that can't
speak for themselves
and on behalf
of the 82 that died
throughout the 51 days
first thing i'd like to say is that
there was no ambush of the atf officers
there were not 40 50 60 people as is
alleged waiting for them at every window
with guns
very few of the people
on february 28
inside the building
knew anything about
the arrival of the atf until
maybe a minute or so before
the trailers drove in the gate
i personally was in my room at the north
end of the building which
if you've seen diagrams of the building
would be the third window
from the left-hand end
and i recall
hearing some people in the chapel excuse
me in the
cafeteria area
and it puzzled me that people would be
in there since breakfast was over
i went out to see what was going on and
it was at that time that there was talk
that wood had come in that something was
coming
somebody was coming
about the time i arrived david koresh
walked in
from the opposite door from the kitchen
serving area and confirmed that he had
heard somebody was coming and he
cautioned us and says i want everybody
to stay cool
go back to your rooms and just
you know wait he says i will go to the
door and talk to these individuals
whoever they are
i went back to my room and within a
minute i'd say or less
heard david at the front door
saying hey wait a minute there are women
and children in here
let's talk about this
immediately shots rang out
coming from the outside in and i'm
although not an expert in firearms or or
ballistics or anything you could
definitely tell the difference between
shots fired outside
as opposed to shots fired indoors had
its distinctly different sound
i went running down the hall thinking
there must have been a massacre or
people hurt at least
in the area of the front door
and found perry jones laying in the hall
screaming that he'd been shot
harry jones was in his 60s
he was unarmed
as was david koresh
when they went to the front door both
were shot in the area of the front door
david was shot in the wrist
perry jones
was shot in the stomach
i know that this is different
than what the autopsies allegedly reveal
i have some contentions with
the autopsy findings
and the tarrant county medical
examiner's
office
i don't
you might say trust their findings in as
much as during the trial that we had in
san antonio
dr piowani made repeated mistakes in the
identification of various people
and various information about these
people
we could get into the details later
upon finding perry
screaming that he'd been shot and
holding his stomach where there
appeared to be blood coming through his
claws
i told him to hang on there for a minute
and i rushed to the front door thinking
there may be others
also wounded to my surprise there was no
one else in the foyer area and i re
retraced my steps back
and helped perry
with the help of another individual by
the name of livingston malcolm we helped
him to a bed
uh on the inside of the of the
building it was in all fairness to you
and i think that mr thurman would agree
to this
that we didn't anticipate when we
started your testimony when mr klinger
asked that that we would be interrupted
by this vote and it occurred almost
simultaneously
although the five minutes that he has
has expired we always give the witnesses
the opportunity to complete the answer
and you are going to have an opportunity
to put your whole statement in
let us hear your description of what
happened that day but i think we should
come back from the vote and let all of
us have the opportunity to hear it
uninterrupted by all these noises and
all the hassle that's going on and you
may take whatever time you need to do
that when we come back so with that in
mind the hearings will be in recess
until after this vote will try to return
within five minutes of the vote's
conclusion the hearings are in recess
you're watching day eight of last
month's house waco hearings we'll be
back with more testimony in five minutes
first we talk with david jackson of the
dallas morning news about his papers
coverage of the hearings
david jackson of the dallas morning news
looking back on the the waco hearings
what's your assessment of what came out
of all those hearings
well a lot of documentation about what
really happened there was some feeling
that the
entire incident from a to z hadn't
really been thoroughly examined
certainly not in a congressional forum
so
anything you ever wanted to know about
what happened or didn't happen
in waco we could probably find an answer
to it now although some would argue that
those questions have been answered in
at least one form or another before the
hearings but now there's there's not
much doubt that we've
totally exhausted the the debate so to
speak
was there a moment in the hearings that
was particularly riveting for you as a
journalist
well for several for us in texas one was
the
testimony of former treasury secretary
lloyd benson former senator from our
state who was
heavily criticized by members of the
panel for
what they felt was a lack of activity on
his part for not getting as involved as
he should have
in the raid secretary benson of course
said that uh
you know he was delegating
responsibility to the atf and
and to others so that was a particularly
interesting part of the hearings for us
and also janet reno's testimony on the
final day which kind of wrapped up
everything that had happened the nine
days previous and it was a final
opportunity for people to to really say
what was on their mind about the waco
incident and uh
the the exchanges between
uh
miss arena when members of the committee
particularly the republican members was
uh parts that were quite interesting
expand on that a little bit about what
you thought was particularly interesting
well just the um
just at several points that several
republicans criticized miss reno for the
gas attack and
miss arena responded that was it once
again that she took responsibility for
it at one point she talked about she was
particularly hurt by
the suggestions that she was responsible
for the deaths of the children inside
the compound i mean this is pretty
dramatic stuff
you know it was a horrible incident i
think anybody who saw it live on
television will never forget it i know i
never will
and just to bring back uh
to have such a prolonged discussion of
that final day of that fire and those
children dying inside the compound it
was was quite emotional
you mentioned members of the committee
which members in particular uh stood out
do you think during the hearings well of
course the two chairmen um
bill mccollum and uh
bill zelloff
were
particularly memorable but they each had
their individual style i would say uh
congressman zelda was a little more
aggressive than congressman mccollum
in
in questioning
some aspects of the entire incident but
both were pretty critical and uh on the
other side would be uh
congressman schumer from new york who
pretty much carried the ball in
defending the administration
i think those were really the three key
figures
what was the atmosphere in the room like
that perhaps you can tell in person that
doesn't really come across on television
um
it would usually start off tense right
when witnesses would start testifying
um
but of course all the sessions were
quite long i mean some of them went to
nine or ten o'clock so you get to
you can get pretty exhausted sitting
there and watching some of these
hearings uh in fact lee hancock my
colleague and i we kind of switched off
to try to
try to beat back some of the exhaustion
but it's uh
it's it's intense i guess is the right
word because you just never know what uh
who's going to attack when and
how the person may respond
other than the the big political names
to testify there are a number of folks
testifying are experts in a variety of
areas what was how would you
characterize that part of the testimony
it would provide a good background
particularly about the history of the
branch dividing religious cult
the use of tear gas and the types of
tear gas that can be used and things
like that frankly i didn't find
that testimony as riveting as the people
who were actually there on this on the
scene the people who were in waco i
think that was the really most
interesting testimony
but some of the expert testimony did
help to fill in some gaps educate some
people about some of the things that
were involved and
some of the background and
some of the decisions that were made you
mentioned trading off with your
colleague how easy or difficult was this
a story to cover
it was pretty difficult because it was
uh so so thorough so many questions and
the witness panels
some of them were up to like eight or
eight people as i recall the largest one
was eight people and so it's a lot of
different angles to cover and you have
to try to put in a coherent fashion on
deadline
also our early edition is we like to try
to get stories in by seven o'clock
eastern time so that we can get in the
early edition which goes all over texas
so that put a little time crunch on us
as well
but
it's just very difficult because there's
just so much information you have to try
to boil it down to an understandable
form and also make it relevant to the
reader so it uh
it was difficult but fortunately lee
hancock i think spent all 51 days in
waco when this happens so
we probably had a better shot at than a
lot of people you mentioned the
documentation uh that came out what new
did you learn from the hearings that you
didn't know before
frankly i'd have to say nothing but i
was pretty familiar with the
issue having
been in dallas at the time that happened
and having read both the treasury and
the justice department reports having
read several books about the incident
and this is something that was a big
debate
during the hearings and it's still a big
debate is how much new came out of it
well if you were intensely familiar with
what happened and had read all of these
things
you know nothing new happened but how
many people have had the time or the
interest to want to go through all this
documentation so for someone
for the average joe sing at home they
probably learned quite a bit about
about what happened and what some of the
mistakes that were made and probably
found out some things they didn't know
before
hearings are done in the house what's
the next step
well there's talk the senate is talking
about having waco hearings of its own
but i think there's quite a bit of
debate because
i think it's fair to say that a lot of
republicans were not pleased with what
happened during the house waco hearings
they they felt like they either didn't
make their case well enough or they came
off a little too zealous
and this debate is carrying over into
the senate so i think there's some
questions as to whether to have
continued hearings on the waco incident
or have more general hearings about
federal law enforcement
as you probably know senator specter is
planning to have hearings on the ruby
ridge incident
and they may try to tie in with that and
look at
federal law enforcement in general as
opposed to the specific
incident at waco
david jackson of the dallas morning news
thanks very much thank you
tomorrow day nine of the waco hearings
the witnesses include a panel of fbi
special agents and on friday will air
the final day of the house hearings with
testimony from attorney general janet
reno
tonight on c-span war in the pacific
this week as we approach the 50th
anniversary of vj day we're airing a
series of programs focusing on prisoners
of war and the a-bomb tonight see part
three of the series at midnight eastern
time 9 pm pacific
we now return to our coverage of the
house waco hearings testifying our
former branch davidian clive doyle and
arson expert james quintery
[Music]
when we were in recess a few minutes ago
for a vote we had
mr klinger's time having expired in the
process of mr doyle giving his testimony
and responding to the question to
describe what happened inside the
compound and and whatever else you wish
to with regard to
the whole situation for the davidians
that day
mr doyle as i told you before you may
proceed and
you're not being clocked because you are
responding to a question to mr klinger
so please tell your story mr chairman
yes mr schumer
[Music]
thank you
uh i understand that mr doyle will get
as much time as he needs to do his
opening stem which i have no problem
with on mr klinger's time post that mr
klinger took the time to ask him that
question he had five minutes but
there'll be more that's right and um
we have two people who would like to do
the same mr quintieri has a presentation
to make that may go beyond five minutes
in terms of the film
and mr gray had wanted to uh i have no
problem with that provided that they
begin their presentation someone yields
so that's so that we consume somebody's
five minutes right then we can go on i
think that's an orderly appropriate
thank you appreciate it mr doyle you may
continue until you have finished
you're recognized thanks sheila
as i was
stating
prior to the break
i helped perry jones with the help of
another individual we helped him back
into the men's dormitory area
at the north end of the building and
placed him
in a bunk bed
we put him on an inside room rather than
in his own room because there were
bullets still coming through the walls
and we were i was afraid that if we put
him in his own bed he would receive
other wounds
you know as a result of these shots
coming into the building
it turned out that the bed we put him in
belonged to kevin whitecliff
i went
from placing perry jones in the bed i i
commandeered three people that were
basically in shock and
kind of milling around
i told them to stay with perry take care
of him
okay conversation if you could take them
in the back room if they need be thank
you please proceed i asked these three
individuals to take care of perry
comfort him do whatever they could for
him and i rushed across the hall to my
room
in order to get him some
tylenol
i had a couple of tylenol tablets that
had been given to me and i brought them
back and gave them to him to alleviate
the pain he was screaming it was very
unnerving
to hear his screams of pain
after giving him the tylenol
somebody
came up to me and said winston blake was
dead
i said where is he they said he's in his
room
so i made my way further up the hall
to the north he was the last room
uh on the inside
and as i approached his bedroom doorway
i could hear water running and it kind
of puzzled me
couldn't make out you know what was
creating that sound
until i rounded the
the doorway and found winston laying in
a pool of blood and water on the floor
the reason for the water
pouring into the room
was the fact that the
outside of winston's room
his was the only room on the inside
or i should say on the
the back side of the hallway that ran
the length of the building that had a
window in it the other three rooms
on that side of the hall
uh butted up to the cafeteria area and
therefore they only had sheetrock walls
but his room had a window but you
couldn't see out of the window there
were three
uh huge plastic water tanks
on a foundation outside the window which
totally blocked the window from either
seeing in or out
and uh the water was coming from
dozens of bullet holes that had been
coming out of this uh
water tank or
on a downward angle
in other words on the outside of the
tank
the bullet holes were high up and and
coming down into the room
which led me to believe
uh
the helicopters had been firing
contrary to what
atf and
and other officials
have stated
other witnesses
have confirmed
such as marjorie thomas who gave a video
deposition for our trial in san antonio
catherine madison also
testified
that
bullets were fired
and then and for those that were
upstairs and toward the back of the
building
most of the survivors that i have talked
to will testify that's the first shots
that they heard was from the helicopters
as opposed to those of us that were in
the front and on the first floor we were
hearing them at the front door so they
were probably fairly simultaneous
so i
i believe that winston blake was was
shot from these helicopters therefore i
disagree with the taran county medical
examiner's office which is
a point in my opening remarks that
tarrant county
testified that winston blake was shot by
somebody inside
that he was supposed to have
gunpowder burns in the wound
but from what i've read
a
new autopsies were done when his body
was returned to england
and it was decided there that uh
there were no powder burns in the wound
and his wounds were con
went along with the concept of being
shot from above
i understand jim cavanaugh
indicated in some answers that he
gave or in some statements he gave the
other day that
he was the one that initiated calls into
the
mount camel
building
during the initial raid
i think just about everybody who's read
anything knows that it was wayne martin
harvard graduate lawyer
that
initiated the 9-1-1 calls
to the sheriff's department
in waco
and
any delay
any suffering caused by agents that were
shot
is
has to fall to some extent
on the fact that
larry lynch the sheriff's deputy who was
answering the calls monitoring the calls
was not able to reach the atf and
arrange for any help or ambulances or
whatever
we were calling for ceasefire right from
the start
this is not conducive or
does not go along with the concept that
we're all just waiting to massacre them
there was no murder of federal agents
i am in sympathy
with the families of those that lost
the families of the four agents that
died
but i don't call it murder when people
are
trying to defend themselves
uh
believing that you're being attacked by
a military force using helicopters and
and so on
uh who come racing into your house or
trying to race into your house using
grenades and and various uh
different kinds of weapons shooting into
your building
if those agents were shot from inside i
would at least give us the benefit of
the doubt that it was self-defense
the
the prosecutors during our trial tried
to prove
conspiracy and murder and all 11
defendants were found by a jury to be
not guilty of those two charges and i
think that
to me is
for the president and for any
media or
anybody in this committee
to continue to refer
to us as murderers
i feel that's unjust
if the killing of federal agents which
was never proven as to who shot them
if the killing of them constitutes
murder then those who shot
and killed our people inside
must also bear that label of murderers
[Applause]
as i say i sympathize with the families
i know what they're going through we
lost
a lot of friends and a lot of our
families i lost a daughter
inside mel carmel
there was a lot of fear
after the atf retreated after we finally
got the ceasefire set up
allowed them to come get the wounded and
those that were killed
there was a lot of fear that there would
be retaliation
there were people who began grabbing
guns after the fact um
the government tried to say that
everybody they could put a gun in
everybody's hand at the beginning and
during the raid and that's not true
most people were unarmed
there were a few that had guns and i
admit that and they were probably those
that reacted to seeing
david and perry
and others gunned down
who responded by firing back
but it was not a general ambushes
they would like you to believe
as i said after they had retreated and i
might
just add that
in the course of their retreat where you
where the agents were helping each other
leave the property that was the first
time that i actually got to see agent
and was totally shocked by the number of
of individuals involved
because i had in the course of the
morning uh
tried to
you know i would ask people who's out
there and where are they and they said
well they're hiding behind the vehicles
and so on but i couldn't see anybody so
it wasn't until they got up and began to
leave that and my mouth dropped open
totally surprised at how many there were
as i said after they'd left we figured
retaliation we figured you know with
agents wounded and dead
that they'd want to get even there's a
lot of fear inside on the
part of the residents that they would
come back perhaps at night and uh try to
get revenge on us
so some
began to grab weapons and or to pass out
weapons to others that didn't have
weapons and so on some that already had
weapons were
getting extra
magazines or whatever with
ammunition in and so forth
david koresh
had been wounded twice
that morning once at the front door and
having been wounded there he
slammed the door and ran upstairs where
he was ended up being shot again
during that first day he was laying in a
little hallway that went back to the
central tower
feeling that he was about to die he was
bleeding profusely
uh he thought his hip was shattered
and uh
but word got to him that people were
grabbing weapons weapons were being
brought out of where they'd been stored
and uh
even though i didn't hear it personally
the word came down to to us who were in
the chapel area um that we were to put
our faith in god we were not to
feel that the guns were going to be our
protection and anybody that didn't have
a weapon uh prior
to the raid itself
or people who had weapons and were
getting extra weapons or extra
ammunition would have put them all back
where they came from
and uh
not everybody apparently knew where they
went so a lot of them were just
dropping them where they you know
happened to be when the message came
around
and so i
picked up several
weapons
and took them back i asked where they
were supposed to be kept and was told
that they were kept in the concrete
vault area which was
basically behind the
the cooking area of the kitchen
which the base of the central tower
and that was the first time i even knew
there were weapons stored in there
like the atf i thought that whatever
weapons
were out there
were stored in the upstairs room that
the atf were breaking into but i found
out that that
was stale information they hadn't been
there for
several months
so
in taking the guns back and putting them
back in the room was the first time i
was aware of where they'd been moved to
what a lot of people don't understand is
that there were areas of mount carmel
that were off limits to most of the
people
people didn't just go up to the rooms
that
were david koresh's that were over the
chapel or near the gymnasium
probably one or two people had access to
the machine shop no one else was
permitted in there
other areas were off limits for various
reasons
so uh
the fact that you know
everybody knew things is is an
assumption
for the next 50
days and and i might add before that
that during the course of the in the
morning
um
word had come to us by you know the word
was getting around at how many were
wounded and who would who was wounded
and so on
we learned that peter jen had been
shot up on top of the water tower peter
had been working in there
built um well he built some scaffolding
in there and some platforms so that he
could scrub the rust off of our big
metal water tower
he was shot
when he put his head out the top of the
of the water tower that's all i know
about that
peter hibsman was also
shot in there scott sanoby
jaden wendell was shot laying in her bed
on the second floor she was a mother of
four
unbeknownst to us for several weeks
david jones had been shot
i guess he was embarrassed about his
shot because it was in his
butocks
or buttocks
okay and it was until the nurses came
into the chapel one day and said well
they just removed a bullet from david
jones that we even knew he'd been shot
his his children didn't even know it
that were in there with him
steve schneider's wife had been shot the
bullet had split her finger open that
had skipped up her arm and lodged in his
shoulder
there was a lot of people that
were very upset
to see
this carnage to see people killed your
friends killed and wounded
and
i'm not
going to
justify everything that's perhaps being
done
but i do think that they had a right to
self-defense and try to defend the women
and children under the circumstances
i think anybody would have done the same
if they'd have been in our position not
knowing what all was going on and what
it was all about but just being caught
in the crossfire and so forth
for the next
50
days
we basically went through
varying degrees of hell
i remember the night that uh
i was sitting in the chapel where the
dory i think began to get dark and i
don't remember the date but it was when
they first brought the tanks
uh the fbi brought the tanks into play
in in the siege
and we were sitting in the chapel and
you couldn't see out of the windows of
the chapel they were like opaque
um kind of that rippled glass that they
put in bathroom windows and so on
but all of a sudden the whole building
began to shake like an earthquake
and so we went over to the south wall of
the chapel and cracked the window in
order to look out
and uh
half a mile away on the
farm road that leads from elk down to
bell mead area
was this big convoy of trailers with the
tanks mounted on the on the top of these
trailers and the ground for a half a
mile was shaking and the building was
shaking and yet we were hearing
on the radio that we had a fortified
compound and we kind of
said to ourselves if only they could be
in here and realize how flimsy this
place is
one of the girls
lisa farris by name
went into the foyer about the time we
saw the tanks being brought and
picked out a world book encyclopedia and
began to read up uh what they had
written in there about the various the
bradleys and the various tank
tanks that were
we were being told were being brought
down
uh i can remember
in the chapel area where i was it was a
lot of
fear
people were making remarks like well if
if they've got this kind of firepower if
they open up on us
this place is going to look like swiss
cheese people were very concerned that
they'd either be shot by the tanks
or if the tanks made incursions into the
building
that we would be crushed by falling
timbers and so on
we were trying to cooperate i believe
david was sincere in his cooperation
with the 18 excuse me with the fbi
negotiators
uh he had originally been talking with
the atf and i
i believe he felt he had a very good
rapport with
jim cavanaugh or whoever
he'd talked to on the 28th
so much so that i believe after the fbi
took over the operation
david demanded that jim still be allowed
to talk to him on the phone because he
felt this uh
closeness to them at no time was there
any hatred toward the atf
or toward
the fbi agents that were there
uh for the things that were going on
david had a very
deep concern for people's souls
as far as the negotiations were
concerned i believe they were trying to
wear him out
trying to of course in
in their doing their job trying to get
as many out alive as possible and that's
commendable
but
this whole situation should never happen
in the first place it could have been
handled so many different ways
at different times to where
no agents would have died and no
residents of mount carmel would have
died
but having gone through
the initial raid and people being killed
we were trying to make the best of it
and children were being sent out we were
cooperating
it was my understanding that
we were being told that we couldn't all
just come out at any place at any time
in mass
that it was to be orderly it had to be
arranged over the negotiating phones
and so
people like myself who
was occupied with various jobs of taking
care of
garbage taking care of
human waste and so on throughout the 50
days felt that
in all likelihood the women the children
the elderly would be the first ones out
and those of us who were able-bodied and
able to perhaps take care of necessary
chores would probably be the last but we
were sincerely
expecting to come out everybody i know
in there had their bags packed
but as the 50 days wore on as
the tactical team in the tanks began to
do things on a more and more you know
more more pressure was inc
expanded by them
which seemed to work at cross purposes
with what the negotiators were promising
and so on uh people began to balk
we observed
you know
immoral what we considered immoral acts
fbi agents were mooning
people from the tanks
a number of individuals
have testified to that and told me that
we had all we had the electricity turned
off of course
and
most of our fresh or frozen foods
were destroyed or spoiled
so as i say we went through varying
degrees of hell with
noise
music
bright lights
the children
were suffering along with the adults
we were without water having had our
water tanks shut up we were living on
rain water whenever it would rain people
would put buckets out the window and
collect rain water and it was rationed
i doubt whether anybody got more than
eight ounces a day if that
i lost 25 pounds
by april 19th
i know others that lost about the same
amount
you say why didn't the people come out
there's two reasons one is fear one is
distrust all right i take it back
there's more than one reason
one is fear
of what's going to happen to you if you
come out
one is distrust because you're being
told certain things that aren't
taking place
the negotiators have promised that
if certain people come out they could
keep their bibles when they were taken
to jail
i'd been told that i could if i came out
i could go and live with my daughter in
california but everybody that came out
we saw
was being handcuffed and carted off to
jail we were hearing their bibles were
being taken away from them
their bags and whatever they brought out
with them were being confiscated and
held as evidence and things like this
and so even though we all had our bags
packed
as time went on
people began to
maybe not even take them with them when
they exited one of those was kevin
whitecliff who was in the chapel with me
he had a bag packed and uh when it when
he came out
he just gave all these clothes aways
i'm not going to get to keep these so if
you want them you know go ahead and use
them and as a result of the lack of
water
uh
we were starting to wear anything we
could find
you know we even got into the
supplies that
david and the guys that went to gun
shows
they had bought up large supplies of of
camouflage clothing
we got into that because our clothes
were dirty and we couldn't wash them we
didn't have any water
we didn't wear them as a statement we
didn't wear them to to hide in amongst
the bushes or anything like that it was
simply a matter of necessity in order to
have some
element of cleanliness
there were people that
came out of the building especially in
the last week or two before april 19th
that had grenades thrown at them all
fired at them
steve schneider was one of them and he
was the one that was one of the ones
that was doing the negotiations with the
fbi he was
going out at various times and picking
up batteries or milk or whatever that
the tanks would bring in
uh a lot of which was bugged as you've
probably learned in these
hearings we found a lot of them we
probably there was others we didn't find
but
even steve schneider in coming out
to pick up something one day had two of
these flash bang grenades
lobbed at him scared the daylights out
of him
so
on the 19th of april
i was in the chapel
it was still dark and i was using the
lights from the floodlights that they
had on us all night
these sleep deprivation methods that
they were using
somewhat
backfired in a sense because i was using
the light to try to transcribe one of
david's studies that was on tape i was
listening to it and trying to write it
out in longhand using this outside light
i remember about six o'clock or
give or take a few minutes
we were told over the loudspeakers that
tanks would be
inserting holes into the building
or poking holes into the building to
insert gas
since i happened to be awake and others
that were awake immediately we began to
wake up everybody else and
and let them know that you know to
expect
this attack this
uh gas
being sent in
some of us had gas masks
the children didn't
most of the women didn't
i believe it's been testified to this
committee that uh
tends to aggravate that gas and i can
testify to that i can't tell you exactly
how the children dealt with it
but if water aggravates it
then
trying to wrap wet towels and wet
blankets around you to survive
probably only made their suffering worse
since they were in a cul-de-sac
type room with no ventilation no windows
and only one door
which at least once was the gas was
fired in at point-blank range uh into
that area
questions have come up like why didn't
you put
the children in the bus
where there was relatively clean air
but during our trial it was testified
that
the storm shelter the underground storm
shelter as they call it
or the bunker
was one of the first things they gassed
the northwest corner of the building had
been pushed in by the cv
and when the driver was asked why he did
that he says because they'd heard there
was a trapdoor in there
and it was
his job to
push building material and and so forth
uh over the trap door so nobody could
escape
so it to me it's
it's
a dishonest statement to say well why
didn't you put the children in the bus
as i say there was a lot of
concern as to what would happen to
people that came out whether they would
be shot
those of us in the chapel
were dodging
the ferret rounds they were like rockets
coming through the windows and through
the walls
uh when i'd first heard they were going
to inject gas
other than from the nozzle of the cv
in my
uneducated
understanding i'm thinking of hollywood
where a grenade is thrown into a room
and somebody runs over picks it up and
throws it back out the window if you
don't want it
i mentioned that to somebody and they
said well you can't pick them up they're
hot
and i said well maybe we could use a
glove
you never got to see them they whiz past
your head so fast that uh as i say it
was like a rocket the only time
you could see them at all was when they
hit a wall stuck into the sheetrock and
were hissing and so on
anybody that was hit by them could have
been severely hurt i heard jimmy riddle
had been hit in the face but happened to
have his gas mask on and was only
knocked down he wasn't seriously hurt by
one of them anyway
but other than that
i don't know what was going on at the
other end of the building because
after six hours of gassing in six hours
of tanks
penetrating the walls pushing on the
walls
destroying the gymnasium at the back
those of us in the chapel were
virtually cut off from the rest of the
building the roof of the gymnasium had
collapsed and blocked the back stairs
that went up to david karesh's rooms
um
the tank had come through the front door
area on numerous occasions the last one
right into the chapel area
was spraying gas there
they'd continue to push on the front of
the building to where the whole first
floor hall that ran the length of the
building
was blocked with the dividing walls in
the various bedrooms being pushed back
into the hallway and the sheetrock and
the tuba force
cutting off any opportunity for us to
to have contact with the people at the
other end in the cafeteria or whatever
we were not able to get upstairs and
now whether the stairs out of the
cafeteria was still usable i don't know
i was not a as i said we were cut off
uh to the point where we couldn't didn't
have contact with any of those people up
there
at one
point probably
around noon i'm not real good with
time but
i'd say around noon somebody came into
the chapel and
told us the building was on fire
we instinctively re
i had the feeling i don't remember them
actually saying where it was but
my recollection was the feeling of
everybody in the chapel was it's
upstairs in the front somewhere
and so we moved away from the front of
the building and got up on the stage and
went round behind a petition that was
built on the
the stage of the chapel
and on the south wall a tank had knocked
a hole in the
from the outside in there was a big heap
of sheetrock and
and
lumber and so forth that the tank had
pushed in
and uh
the first ones to get to that hole
were david thibodeau and myself
and we hesitated for a moment
in coming out
the conversation as i remember it was
well if we come out we will be shot
we knew there were sniper nests uh
sniper positions uh
on the south side there was one that was
sandbagged over near the fence we knew
that there were agents inside our boat
shed we knew there was a tank parked
next to the boat shed under the tree
there were individuals outside of the
tanks and i might add that all through
the 51 days siege
if all we were were a bunch of crazies
that wanted to kill agents
we had
endless opportunities to fire on them if
we so chose and we didn't
pardon me mr doyle
uh point of uh inquiry mr chairman do we
have a time frame now i don't mean to be
cutting mr doyle oh he's uh he's being
permitted to finish his statement he
really okay so mr klinger's time but
because i came in late and didn't know
about but i apologize to you mr dolph
interrupter
so there was this moment of hesitation
on the part of david
thibodeau and myself as to what would
happen if we came out
uh out of the hole would we be fired at
there was some concern about it
we were surrounded by tanks there were
bradleys there were the cvs
and they had been
as i say lobbying these
ferret rounds or firing these ferret
rounds most of the morning and they
sounded kind of like mortars or whatever
you couldn't tell whether they were
firing at us other than those or not
if they'd use silences we wouldn't know
so
in that just
moment or so of hesitation other people
were crowding in behind us to the point
where
uh eventually
ten people were crowded in a little
narrow space behind this petition
what i recall in looking out the hole
and deciding whether we would
jump out
was that all of a sudden smoke came
along the outside of the building along
the south wall of the chapel
uh heading from west to east toward the
back of the building and and when it got
to the hall it was like it just got
sucked in
where we were and the whole area that we
were in just turned pitch black
and
almost immediately it was like you could
feel heat over your head and on both
sides
and i found myself down on the floor
rolling around trying to protect myself
from from the heat my hands were the
only
areas that were basically uncovered i
did have a gas mask on at the time in
spite of the fact that the filter had
blocked up
about 30 minutes after the gassing
started
uh i'd been told that earlier in the
morning
the filters wouldn't last long
and when it did block up i'd taken my
mask off only to find my face burning
and stinging it was like he had acid all
over you
and so i put the mask back on
i felt i'd rather suck air through the
block filters and
continue with this burning sensation i
saw other adults
that had less clothing on than myself
stinging and crying in pain because of
the
cs gas getting on their skin
and
because they were
uneducated in the use of gas or what it
was like some of them were trying to
wipe it off with minimal amounts of
their drinking water on and perhaps a a
rag or whatever only to find that it
made it worse
so as i say what the children would
going through
only god knows
there came a point
in my rolling on the floor and trying to
protect myself from the heat and being
in the pitch black not able to see
that the voices of those behind me
screaming
kinda got through to me
i recognized
who they were
could identify the voices
that kind of galvanized me to
just leap to my feet and jump or dive
head first in the general direction of
where i figured the hole was
and i landed on the sheetrock face down
and
kind of
slithered out
onto the ground
when i stood up
the skin was rolling off my hands
my coat was all melted on my back and
smoking
now
i looked back over my shoulder
and the hole had just come out with a
massive flames
and the first thought that came to me
was
i'm the only one
i'm the only one just get out
i was in shock and pain and i staggered
away from the building
and i ran into the reason why fans had
kind of forgotten that they'd surrounded
us with this razor wire and i ran slap
bang into it and
i tried to look you know what do i do
now where do i go and
i look to my left and i looked to my
right and as i as i did i saw
david thibodeau and some others
walking up to the front gate with their
hands in the air and it was the first
time i realized
that others had gone out besides myself
and not only that but some of them had
come from the same area and i hadn't
even seen them leave everything was so
pitch black they'd walk right past me
and
managed to get out
so i decided to follow them
and as i
rounded the corner of the drive some
perhaps
60 70 yards behind
three or four individuals ahead of me
i presume it was an fbi
agent over near the tree
who was dressed in camouflage yelled at
me to come over to him and i kind of
staggered over there and limped over
there
i didn't realize my left ankle was
burned
the right side of my face was
burned
in both hands and i was in a kind of a
great deal of pain and the ground was
all chewed up like it had been plowed
because of the tanks
so i hubbled over to him and he was
screaming at me that he would blow my
so-and-so head off
if i didn't you know if i made a false
move and keep my hands up and come over
here because he wanted to know where the
children were
unfortunately i wasn't able to tell him
i didn't know i'd been sick all day the
day before and it stayed in my bed and i
was pretty sick most of the 19th
so that i'd laid on the floor of the
chapel between the pews most of the
morning trying to keep my head out of
the
direct contact with these ferret rounds
and so i wasn't much help i made
suggestions
that maybe they were in the bus because
i didn't know that they blocked the
entrance
i said normally they're upstairs
with the mothers
uh and i might just make this comment
that on the 28th all the rooms that you
see the atf agents firing into on the
second floor were all all had women and
children in them
they were all
where the children stayed that whole
front row and around both corners were
rooms with women and children and
but anyway
since i wasn't much help to him and he
ordered me to go on up to the gate
and be arrested with along with the rest
of him so i staggered
away from him and with his threats in my
ears that he was you know if i made one
false move
he'd blow my head off
i got up to the gate and uh when i got
there
there were four of those that had come
out of the fire four men
uh
already laying on the ground handcuffed
i was told to start a new row behind
them
to get out and face down on the ground
and i was handcuffed in spite of the
burns
and
it was about that time i saw
the huge fireball that so many have seen
on the videos
go off and i pretty well wrote everybody
off at that point i figured there's no
one going to get out of there after that
and uh
but
all of a sudden
ruth riddle was brought up and laid down
beside me
ruth had jumped out of a window i found
out later and in the process had broken
her ankle
her knees
her legs were burned not
very badly but enough to be painful
and she was put down beside me and
some agent fbi agent i presume
uh grabbed her by the hair and was
jerking her head back and forth
screaming at her what's your name tell
us where the children are
and ruth who was in shock and in pain
wasn't answering
i didn't understand why
and i heard a voice off to my right
saying you better quit that they're
taking pictures
and so he let go of her hair you know
from
jerking her head around and let her go
and he turned to me and he says what's
her name she won't answer me
and i said
i'd already given my name they'd already
taken pictures of us laying on the
ground and so forth and i didn't
understand exactly why she wasn't
answering
i asked her later during the trial when
i had an opportunity to talk to her and
she said she was just in so much pain
and shock that you know
it's not that she was being hard-headed
or anything but
at that point when he asked me what her
name was i said look i don't know why
she doesn't
respond why she's not answering i says
but that's her right
we're told you know
that you don't have to say anything
unless
you have your lawyer present so i didn't
know whether that was her reason or not
but i says if she doesn't want to answer
then i'm not going to tell you her name
either that's her privilege
and that says i don't know her reasons
shortly after that
i was put in a bradley somebody
in command
made a decision that i was bad enough
and they put me in a bradley and
felt like you were being dragged down
the road on your stomach but
they did take me to a medical tent
where i was given morphine and it was
decided by the doctors there to send me
to
parkland hospital in dallas
i passed out on the helicopter i don't
remember when i arrived
when i woke up
but as i said i'd pretty well written
off everybody in the building
[Applause]
including my own daughter my 18.
you've told us your story i think you'll
have an opportunity to answer questions
and can do more uh at later date we've
been very
lenient in the time because of the
circumstances and we're going to have a
couple of presentations it will also be
a little deviation from what we normally
would do mr scott you're recognized for
five minutes
thank you mr chairman i had uh many
several questions for mr quintery but i
think i understand he has a presentation
and the presentation will answer
a question so why don't i just ask him
ask us what it takes for the
presentation thank you mr quintaria if
you would do that i think that might be
helpful to all of us
some point i'd like to show a video if
that you may you may proceed mr content
okay
right
shortly after the fire of the branch
dabidian compound at
waco texas on august 19 1993 i was asked
to contribute to the fire investigation
in doing so i enlisted the support
of dr fred maurer also of the department
of fire protection engineering at the
university would you just pull the
microphone up a little more closely
thank you
we visited the waco fire site during
april 22nd to the 24th
at that time we joined the team under
paul gray who's at my left from houston
and that team also consisted of thomas
hitchings of pittsburgh william cass of
los angeles and john ricketts of san
francisco
the group under paul gray would focus on
the cause and origin of the fire
we would analyze the development of the
fire and draw interpretations and
conclusions from that analysis
principally we had visual data to work
from the fire had completely leveled the
compound so that no significant
structural remains were available to
establish the development of this fire
however this fire was probably one of
the most extensively recorded fires in
history
not only were commercial television
stations continuously recording this
event
but surveillance government planes were
taking still photographs and using a
forward looking infrared
known as a flare flir
video that's an infrared video
these visual records became the
principal source of our data
for this analysis
the video and photographic data were
made available to us by the fbi
video copies of the data we requested
were given to us at the fbi headquarters
in washington dc
on april 25th
subsequently the fbi video and photo
laboratories supplied additional
materials and support as requested
during our investigation
the data included television coverage of
the fire
by the canadian broadcast corporation
and by channel 10 waco these were
representative of the commercial
statement the stations that were
recording
also we had the flear the ir video
recording and aerial photographs these
covered the period of the fire
approximately 12 noon central daylight
time to approximately 12 30.
the principal source of the data to
establish the inception of the fires and
their locations is the flare video
based on the calibrated clock of the
flear this was calibrated to do
to the national standard time i believe
that the
day before they used it
that was used as our official time there
is a time also on the canadian broadcast
tape it's eastern time not central time
and it's off by 19 seconds so we were
able to use the flare video as the
official
time
uh
if you will in this study
from this visual data
i was able to determine the point of
origin of the fires
their growth rates
and estimates of the fire energy output
rates at critical transition points
in their development
i also drew conclusions on the nature of
the ignition sources the role of the
tear gas
the effect of the wind and the
survivability time of the occupants
i will summarize these conclusions and
how they were determined in addition to
this statement i would like our official
report
and a video i made for the criminal
trial to be submitted for the record of
this hearing both will be accepted
without objection
reserving the right to object yes uh mr
bob
i need a little clarification because
i'm not sure how this fits in with what
i understand our established procedures
were this was a tape prepared
by whom
this was prepared by the fbi laboratory
under my direction so that i could use
that as an aid in explaining the fire
development
uh for the criminal trial of the branch
davidians okay and that was used it was
used in that trial uh okay and you
referred to something called a flare
video the flare video which is uh
yes uh aaron their video on the video
there will be segments of the flare
segments of the commercial stations and
some still photographs and they will be
labeled so that i could explain
uh more completely
uh how we you know examine this fire and
what we saw
okay and what we need to do
as i understand there is another video
the flir video
uh which is more comprehensive in terms
of showing the entry and egress of the
tank and and uh the the different points
of the fire uh will we be able to
introduce portions more complete video
that goes along with this then we'd be
glad to have it in here
the objective of these hearings this set
of hearings is to demonstrate as best as
possible what happened to the fire and
try to debunk the theories that are
wrong and come to some conclusions we
cannot do this type of a hearing without
videos so if there's something that you
feel is not being properly presented
here we'll consult with the ranking
members and we'll be glad to augment it
but the objective is to bring everything
forward here today that's the objective
okay then if just for clarification then
then we we will be able to uh utilize
the other the other video then if we
allow this we have it available and we
can produce it in a timely manner we
certainly would okay thank you
preserving the right objectives chairman
yes you may reserve the right to object
mr taylor uh mr chairman also for
clarification now since we are
by your last statement obviously trying
to get the whole truth
as the chairman changed his mind on
allowing the two reporters from the waco
paper to come testify before this
committee
and the woman who claimed she was held
against her will and the woman who
claims quresh had compiled a hit list
are you going to allow i have not you of
course your request is going
predominantly to mr zelloff who's your
subcommittee chairman in this dual
hearing
but nonetheless i will answer but
nonetheless i will answer you on your
reservation i have not changed my mind
as i indicated and i join and concur in
mr zelda's view
the witnesses who you wish to call the
newspaper reporters and those who were
involved in the other uh aspects of what
happened in waco in terms of being
participants in some fashion are
redundant and duplicative we are
attempting here today to get at the fire
we're not attempting to get it telling
the broad story picture other than that
we presented one davidian which was by
mutual agreement earlier to tell this
story
and we could have presented a whole
panel of dividends there has to be a
finite limit to how we proceed in order
to go through these here
exactly and there also has to be
a reason
for the government to have got involved
in the first place
and that is that is what i would like
the people of this country to know
right now all right the regular order is
that we're at the point now where the
request has been made by the witnesses
to present this material and evidence if
there's objection it will not be
admitted into evidence and this hearing
at least for the moment will come to an
end and we will not proceed it's as
simple as that because we cannot have
this hearing without the evidence that's
here for them visual evidence this this
will not work we've heard mr doyle but
that'll be it
so
the at any rate uh is there objection
preserving the right to object
mr boyer i do have a question about when
he's mentioned a fleer video is this a
flir video that was shot on the day of
the fire yes
and was it was it by military aircraft
or by fbi i couldn't tell you that so we
don't know who shot from what type of
aircraft was shot it's a government
aircraft uh paul gray is telling me it's
fbi aircraft
and uh it was shot for more than just
the time of this fire and the segments
that i have used are from the i think
the the period of the fire and that's
the most relevant i think to myself
thank you i i do
i withdraw my reservation without
objection the data will be admitted we
will be in recess until five minutes
after the vote is in progress
we'll be back with more testimony in a
few moments
during the waco hearing some news
stories reported on tensions between
members of the committee we asked
several reporters about that one was
washington times reporter laurie kellman
it was to be expected um
classic
a classic tactic when your party is
under attack is to say that the hearings
are politically motivated and not a
whole lot new is going to come out it's
waste of time and taxpayers money so
that was to be expected what i don't
think anybody expected including the
republicans was the extent to which the
democrats
planned on
obstructing things they they really
dominated things for hours at a time
especially the first couple of days and
congressman zelif in particular was not
prepared for that he he told me he was
flustered and caught by surprise by it
um and and it's something that the
republicans as they do oversight
hearings from now on will need to be
better prepared for
if they intend to keep their hearings
focused and one of the reasons these
hearings were delayed two days one on
two days longer is because they just
couldn't grab hold of of the um of the
delaying tactics used by the democrats
one thing that your viewers may not have
noticed in terms of nuance is that the
co-chairman representative bill zelle
from new hampshire
uh was constantly making the point that
president clinton was you know deeply
involved there was a washington times
story beforehand that said that you know
this might lead to impeachment
proceeding somehow without any real
specificity is what he was talking about
he was constantly critical of the
president he went on the national talk
shows on sunday i made a statement that
we're going to have you know the
equivalent of a smoking gun and we're
going to have new information about the
president's involvement
he also happens to be a bob dole
campaign official in new hampshire
so there is some
you know incentive for him to do that
and
in the end there was no smoking gun
there was no new evidence and zelloff
continued to be critical and at one
point i asked on a press conference i
said well i'm confused are you saying
the president was too involved or not
involved enough
and he kind of was stunned by the
question and really didn't have an
answer for it so it's just a matter of
just throw it out there and criticize
without really having anything in
specific to go after
tomorrow day nine of the waco hearings
the witnesses include a panel of fbi
special agents and on friday will air
the final day of the house hearings with
testimony from attorney general janet
reno
labor day weekend on c-span we mark the
50th anniversary of vj day the end of
the war with japan
among the programs live coverage of a
joint services review at wheeler air
force base in honolulu hawaii
president clinton will speak at the
event friday at 3 p.m eastern time
we now return to final coverage of day
eight of the waco hearings witnesses are
paul gray of the houston fire department
and fire expert rick sherrow we'll also
hear more testimony from arson expert
james quinteri and former branch
davidian clive doyle
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
these joint subcommittees will come to
order i do not believe we'll have any
more interruptions this afternoon
because we've now completed business on
the floor of the house
we do have a very serious business to do
here though and we will be here for the
duration of completing that when we
recessed for the last vote on the floor
mr scott's time had expired in the
process of asking mr quintera to explain
the fire
evidence that he had he was in the
process of giving us a statement and we
just accepted into the record some
documentary evidence which you wished us
to and now you may proceed mr terry
and i'll depart somewhat from that
statement
uh so that i can narrate uh the video
that would be fine
and uh as i pointed out this video was
composed
uh through the fbi laboratory under my
direction so that i could use it in the
branch davidian uh criminal trial
it has on it the flare
excerpts from the canadian broadcast uh
tape
excerpts from channel 10 of waco and
some still photographs that were taken
uh overhead by an
aircraft uh
okay let's start the video
i might add that mr doyle and mr gray
are not in their seats if somebody would
notify them not that they're testifying
now it would be helpful
please proceed
okay what we're going to see is this is
approximately at 12 noon if we can just
hold it there for a second
this is an aerial uh view of the
compound as it existed
uh just several moments before the start
of the fire
and you could see that there is a
demolished area here in the front of the
building i will call this part the front
of the building there's some other
demolition area here and here so these
are openings made by the tanks
uh
significant openings and in the back the
gymnasium is partially demolished in
this debris pile that we see
here as well
i should point out that there was a very
strong wind a prevailing wind that was
approximately 17 to 24 miles an hour
from this direction going diagonally
across this is from the south to the
north
as i said i'll refer to this as the
front of the building
there were gusts in this wind but
principally we could say it was about 25
miles an hour the building is
principally of wood construction the
interior was gypsum board walls perhaps
gypsum board ceilings
the floor and roof were made of plywood
what we're going to see let's start the
tape we're going to see how we
synchronized
uh the three tapes the tapes were run
continuously and as i said we used the
clock on the flare which was calibrated
to the national standard so that we we
have a very good precise record
of the time and we've synchronized this
with the departure of a tank
from this corner of the building this is
the right front corner of the building
now you're looking at the black and
white
flare
uh the flare image is going to respond
to temperature as well as reflected
sunlight
okay let why don't we just uh pause
there uh for a moment and let me explain
what what a flare is a flare is
uh the symbol the letter stand for
forward-looking infrared let's just call
that you know the infrared
video
uh the way this operated it would uh
focus on the temperature that it would
see in the field of view
and then it would set a temperature
above and below that average temperature
that it would see so for example if the
ground temperature was approximately 80
degrees fahrenheit it would set some
limits above and below that and that
range was approximately 40 degrees above
and below
that would set the grayscales on the low
end we would have see it as black
on the high end we would see it as white
so if something in this screen changed
from gray or black to white
we could be sure that in the early
stages of this fire it was attaining at
least a temperature of 120 degrees
fahrenheit that's how sensitive this
flare is
my sense is that this is used for
surveillance and it's used for night
vision vision and it's able to see
people even though there may be no
sunlight or artificial light available
so it is very sensitive at about 200
degrees fahrenheit it would become
saturated
and at that point you would just see
white so at some point in this fire the
flare doesn't become very valuable
because the entire screen is mostly
white from the heat of the fire
another advantage that the flare has is
that
because of its longer wavelength it's
operating between 8 and 12 micrometers
where our eye is more like 0.6
micrometers much much lower because of
that higher wavelength it can penetrate
through smoke sort of like an x-ray
and in that sense the flare enables us
to see through smoke about 20 times more
than our naked eye now once that smoke
gets very hot and very thick then it
can't see through it anymore becomes
saturated because of its scale but the
advantage is in the early part of this
fire the flare not only is very
sensitive to the small temperature rise
but it allows you to see through smoke
that might have obscured parts of the
building and the fire development so
this is very critical in uh
discerning what is taking place
okay and we can start the tape and you
can simply see how we're
correlating the times you notice the
time here this is the canadian broadcast
time that is not the correct time that
is eastern time and it's 19 seconds off
so this time should be regard
disregarded on what we see in the future
there was actually a time recorded on
the flare and that could be was obvious
uh in reviewing carefully uh the tapes
and what i had to do is go back and
forth in looking at these independent
tapes this is waco channel 10 and you
see the tank departing from that point
now what we're going to see is the first
fire is going to occur
in this
room
and it will occur one and a half minutes
approximately after the tank leaves
all right
it is difficult sometimes to see this
you have to look at it carefully so i'll
try to call your attention to it if you
look at this point here you will see
this window
begin to turn slightly grayish
it does right now
if we
nine seconds later the window on the
opposite side
right here
is going to also show an illumination
which is due to this temperature rise
and in my opinion that's due to smoke
being transported from the fire started
at one end of the room to the other end
of the room that occurs about nine
seconds later so at 1207 42
approximately a minute and a half after
the tank has left that location we have
the onset of a fire
uh in this view right here you see it uh
in in this uh point it's a second floor
this is probably a bedroom the room is
about 16 by 11 in dimensions about eight
foot high we might imagine that there
would be uh beds or mattresses in that
room in this general location uh i think
i counted about seven box springs
from mattresses
okay
so that is the start of the first fire
now we'll see the start of the second
fire this is much more difficult to
discern you have to watch the tape a few
times
what we will see
is
some smoke rising from this point
and that will occur approximately after
a minute from the first fire now if some
of you just saw this flash here that is
a momentary event in my opinion that's a
reflection due to sunlight reflecting
off some object in that debris
there is no thermal effect that persists
there
so whatever it was it's momentary
yeah at this point in this vicinity
right here there was a column of faint
smoke rising i admit that it's difficult
for you to see at first looking at this
one has to study this
at some time for some periods
you'll notice that the back of the tank
here
is illuminated due to the fact that
that's where the hot engine is
so one minute later we have a fire now
on the first floor in the rear of the
dining room
in that area i did note in the uh debris
of the fire that there were about 20
burn uh stacked chairs so that could
have been a possible site for the
beginning of this fire here you see a a
split screen
in which we have the flare on the left
and
the canadian broadcast tape on the right
and from this you can see the difference
between what you would see with your
naked eye and what the flare
sees
and i call your attention to the fact
that sometimes you will see a large
amount of smoke on the right and not
that much on the left and that's because
we're able to see through that smoke uh
with the infrared
we are looking at the development of the
fire
uh in that
bedroom area the second floor uh right
tower
right what we're going to see here
at 1209 42 we will see an event
known to people
who investigate and study fire that
event is called flashover and that's a
point
when we have a transition in this fire
in which the fire goes from a discrete
uh
object that you could discern very
readily burning in a room such as this
to a point where flames now fill the
room
and that transition can occur in seconds
it is known as flashover before that
time the room might be survivable after
that time is definitely not and now the
fire is a threat to spreading to other
rooms
we can discern flashover on this when
flames come out of this window
and that's an indication of fire filling
that space
the other thing you should notice is
that the flames come out into that
nearly 25 mile an hour wind
and you might ask how could that be the
only way that could be is if there are
some barriers back here closed doors or
windows
that don't allow the wind to blow
through that area and for that reason
the wind is not having a significant
effect on the fire development in that
room and in that area
right it is acting as if there is no
wind there is basically what
people call in fluid mechanics a
stagnation point at that
in that region
now we are continuing on in time and
we'll backtrack in a moment to pick up
some of the other fires but you
definitely see the second fire here
and actually here in this debris area
you will see what might be a fourth
flyer or connected to the third and
we'll go over those
in a moment
this is the inception of the third fire
this will be on the first floor in the
chapel the chapel was the largest space
in which this uh which the three fires
started this is a space that is
approximately i think 60 by 40 feet
uh it is a single story space with a
higher ceiling and right at that point
there you see the onset
of
the thermal image that indicates a
fire or hot gases
at that point
now some 45 feet away approximately from
that point that window point
uh
in the debris area here we will see an
emergence right now
of some
hot gases
and that could be a separately set fire
if we look at the time duration between
these two events it's approximately 38
seconds
that's consistent also with if someone
were to put a trail of
gasoline or some other liquid fuel
between those two points and allow the
fire to spread
over that uh trail it would take
approximately the same time so it may
have been connected with the starting of
the third fire
here we're just going to see an aerial
photo this is about the same time that
we were just looking at you see the way
the smoke to the naked eye would have
obscured most of that building with the
flare giving us the ability to look
through it and see the onset
of these fires as i said as the smoke
becomes hotter and denser then the flare
would saturate and the image on the
flare is not as valuable to us anymore
okay let's let's go on
we will now see flashover in the dining
room and if you were observing flashover
carefully for the first flyer you would
have seen that the walls of that room in
that area actually began to become
illuminated as heat was penetrating
through those walls
and shortly thereafter that event took
place flames came out of the window
therefore we could almost calibrate this
flare and say when we see a heat pattern
coming through the walls of a room
it is likely that there is tremendous
heat hot gases inside and that room is
ripe to go to flashover and we will we
you will see that
in this area here you'll also see the
roof
getting hot and even uh flecks of hot uh
uh
airborne debris
uh moving up
like firebrands uh from this fire here
you can see
we just sort of went by it but you can
you can see here
in this area
uh the thermal image coming through the
walls in addition to that
uh flashover could be determined in this
area by noting the smoke coming out the
front left corner of the building
previously to that the smoke did not
significantly come out when flashover
occurred in the dining room there was a
flashover gives us a very large rapid
release of energy
that gives rise to a slight pressure
increase and that will push smoke out of
areas where it wasn't coming out before
and in this case it can push it out
directly into the wind
and that was one of the characteristics
of the dining room fire so therefore
flashover could be noted there as well
the significance of flashover is the
time from ignition to flashover and the
speed of which that occurring is an
indication of
uh you might say
uh perhaps how this fire was growing and
how it could be related to other things
we know about the way fires grow these
fires were
rapidly developing developing fires they
could be listed in a
relative way as fast to ultra-fast
developing fires in those two locations
uh this is the cbt
cbc tape and it just shows smoke
evolving from this point indicative
of
flashover
here you can still see flames
emerging from this window into the wind
you notice the wind and the way the wind
is affecting the smoke
we'll now look at the onset of flashover
for the chapel the chapel is the largest
space and it took a flash over about
four minutes to occur
in that much larger space indicating
that that fire in my opinion was
encouraged
to grow rapidly
we can note
flashover in the chapel
by the fact that we will see a puff of
black smoke come out the front door here
that large opening
made by one of the tank vehicles and you
could see it there
as we pass through flashover and we have
a fully developed fire the fire will
equilibrate this pressure pulse will die
away and now after that we will see we
will not see smoke coming out in the
same way
if we can just pause at this point you
can see uh the fire here the first fire
a minute later a fire began in the
dining room area
and a minute after that a fire began in
this chapel it has not burned through
the roof yet but the ignition in the
debris area because of the wind has now
propagated
significantly over that debris area
these are three
distinct fires
from this information i can conclude
that these three fires that occurred
nearly one minute apart were
intentionally set from within the
compound
even if a tank
battering had caused spillage of some
fuel perhaps from a lamp
a match would be needed to initiate the
fire
if the lamp were lit when the tank
knocked it over if you presume that
happened because of the sensitivity of
the flare we would have seen that
and you saw that the only chance that a
tank might have done something like that
is a minute and a half before fire
occurred in that first location so that
is that is not possible
um
if there was a spillage it needs at
least an electric spark to ignite it
that could have happened if there was
electricity available the electricity
the power was shut off to the compound
therefore even if there was a spillage
of something due to this battering
someone would have to put a match in it
to ignite it
so it is obvious to me that these three
fires needed an ignition source
deliberately placed in each of these
three locations
also you have the time periods involved
and the very discrete different
locations
none of these three fires could have
caused any of the others because their
growth rates would not provide
sufficient heating to cause such remote
ignitions in other words this fire is
not putting out enough heat to cause a
fire on the first floor in the dining
room
any external heat source that might have
been used to start the fire would have
clearly been visible as you could see
from the infrared this was not seen
although normal furnishings and interior
construction characteristics would
provide a means for fire propagation the
more than usual rapid spread of these
fires especially in the dining room and
the chapel areas
indicates to me that some form of
accelerant was used to encourage the
rapid spread of these fires
now if we can go on with the
tape
all right this is approximately uh 11
minutes
or i should say at approximately 11
minutes after the start of the fire the
flames will merge
over the compound
the fire was probably detected on the
flear
as low as something like 50 kilowatts
that's a fire about this big
all right you can get your arms around
that now when these flames
merge
approximately
11 minutes later
we have three and a half million
kilowatts estimated in this fire
the black smoke i might add is probably
due to the fact that we have a fuel-rich
fire inside we're not getting enough air
to the
materials that are now decomposing
uh producing the fuel in this fire
uh you might have seen in that segment
that a person actually jumped off the
roof
and walked away
uh that person had had climbed out of
one of the windows previously and had
lied on the roof for
some period of time
[Music]
you'll notice that in areas here there's
no more smoke coming out
if people were in this area at this time
it might have been uh
possible to survive uh this fire in some
of those locations
okay
we just hold it there for a second uh
there was a significant event that i i
did not point out and some of you may
have seen it
uh at
12 19 and 15 seconds a person did jump
from uh one of the windows on the second
floor
and uh if that wasn't obvious to any of
you or you wanted me to go back and show
that later we can we can do that at this
point let's just move on here you see
this rather dramatic event of this
fireball there's some debris that
appears to be in it
what it is i cannot say for sure but
based on its duration and its height
and the size of the diameter of the
fireball
one can estimate uh
what how much fuel was suddenly released
to cause that this is being caused from
a rupture of some kind of tank or some
kind of sudden release of energy
and that is equivalent to
in as an estimation 93 pounds of propane
so it would be consistent with a hundred
pound tank of propane that might have
been used for heating or cooking
purposes
in the compound i'm not saying it is a
tank of propane it is consistent with a
tank of propane rupturing
let's move on
and if you could trace it back down it
looks like it's in the vicinity of the
uh tall
uh tower in the center or next to the
kitchen area
uh there is a person that walks across
the front of the building at this time
where they exit it from uh it's not
clear but the person that jumped from
this window apparently
went into the debris area here and will
be seen being rescued by an agent uh
shortly this is a person who is ex
executed the building from some place
i can't determine from this vantage
point
but uh
subsequently we will see a person being
rescued from this area
at this time
this is now uh
21 minutes after the start of this fire
and you could see that the building is
collapsing in
places
and it's pretty much fully involved
this is the surrender of one of the
occupants
you will now see an agent
run
and rescue the person from this area
certainly i would suggest that if that
agent wasn't cited for that act he
should be
commended for that
so
okay if we could just
hold it at that point i would like to
conclude with a couple of remarks based
on my estimates of survivability
of the occupants in the compound
and on the uh the tear gas
and
what it might have done in this this
fire
i've estimated these these are rough
estimates but i i think they're pretty
reasonable that the occupants would have
had
uh sufficient warning uh in no doubt
that the the the uh
fire occurred
and this would have enabled them to
escape
for up to five minutes from the start of
that first fire or perhaps as many as 20
minutes
in some protected areas of the building
so between an interval of five minutes
after the fire started and maybe as much
as 20 minutes a person could have
escaped from some parts of that building
this was dramatically seen and i'm sorry
i didn't point it out from a person
jumping from one of the second floor
windows where conditions of this fire
would have been much worse than the
first floor because we all know heat
rises and that's where the smoke is
going to collect and the hot gases that
person jumped from that window at
12 minutes after the start of the first
fire
the exits were within about 30 feet
of almost any point you know from the
perimeter of of this building
uh people knew the building and there
were some large openings in there that
were put in by the tanks that could have
facilitated people walking out
carbon monoxide into smoke would have
been the primary threat
in my opinion to the occupants this is
the threat to most people that are not
intimate with the fire and the way most
people die in fire
however preliminary autopsy reports that
i had available to me indicated that
only five
of 31 victims where carbon monoxide was
recorded so where 31 victims had
recorded
data on carbon monoxide
only five of those would have been
considered lethal that would be over 50
percent carboxy hemoglobin
hence if these data are correct at least
26 of these victims did not die due to
the fire
the autopsy report goes on to indicate
that in at least 27 of the victims
gunshot wounds could be attributed to
the cause of death
let me address the tear gas
the tear gas is composed of methylene
chloride which is a liquid that forms an
aerosol
droplet around the cs itself which is
the ingredient
uh that makes your eyes tear and and
cough so the methylene chloride my
understanding is its role is just as a
dispersal agent
it is the more flammable of the two
components that is between cs
and methylene chloride
uh as a vapor in air
under normal conditions it's flammable
at 12 percent in other words anything
above 12 percent to approximately 20 it
would be in the flammable range and if
we had a spark or a small match and if
we had conditions like that we would
have fire propagating through the
atmosphere much like a fireball there
was no observations like that made for
this fire
in addition if you look at methylene
chloride as a liquid which it would
normally be
under under these conditions it it boils
at something like 109 degrees fahrenheit
so as it's dispersed into this compound
with the cs
it would start to evaporate and may
puddle in some pools if they put a lot
in and in those liquid pools if one
tried to ignite it it would actually put
out a match and this is due to the
chlorine in that compound so in some
sense it acts like an inhibitor
uh recently i conducted some additional
experiments to assess the role of the
methylene chloride as a wetting agent
all right
so if it deposited on
wood or paper or things like that that
would burn in this compound and uh
it would be then absorbed since it's
normally a liquid from my experiments i
can conclude that the methylene chloride
had no enhancement effect on the fire
spread over the room furnishings and
other things that burned in the compound
also i can conclude from the
literature information about cs the
point where it will ignite
it that temperature is comparable to
what we would find for most fuels around
us
so in my opinion based upon that the cs
itself as a powder would not enhance any
fire spread and i could elaborate on on
those experiments and that issue so i
can say that the tear gas had no bearing
on the propagation of this fire
on the effect of wind
wind effects did have a profound effect
on the external fire spread over the
compound and approximately 25 mile an
hour wind from the south caused the fire
plume to be bent
at approximately 65 degrees with the
vertical when the fire fully involved
the compound and i said at this point
that
firepower was probably about three and a
half million kilowatts
compared to the inception that we saw on
the flare which is estimated to be about
50 kilowatts
the flame length was 240 feet long
wind effects did not appear to have a
significant effect on the fire growth
within the compound
uh these were seen by the flames
emerging from that window directly into
the wind so from that point there
that fire was behaving as if there was
no wind and it was probably due to some
closure doors closed or other obstacles
behind
that room
the tank made openings on the front of
the compound could have had some effect
on fire growth over the first floor but
more significantly could have provided
air to areas of refuge for some of the
occupants
during the weeks preceding the fire at
the branch davidian compound we were all
bystanders to the drama of the standoff
and we wondered how it would end
the eventual outcome was a horrible
event
in the two years since many theories
about the fire have been proposed
some quite bizarre
i hope this presentation
uh our report that we drafted and i'd
like to submit that for the record and
and the video uh
i hope that will help to explain the
events of this fire we're going back to
regular order now mr quintero we thank
you for that before i recognize mr
schiff i just want to point out to you
that you're going to be given this tape
which is nothing more than a copy of
what you already have you know about so
that you can prepare it for when mr
shattag or others may wish to question
you about it mr schiff you're recognized
for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
um
mr kintery you how do you could you say
your name again siri winter excuse me
quintery
country
um
mr winter uh you've stated that you
believe i still have it wrong would you
say it again quintiary
okay excuse me
it's a quintery
i want to say you have rejected the idea
of the grenades and the methylene
chloride having anything to do with with
the fire is that right that's correct
let me ask the other two fire experts
here uh mr cheryl and mr gray do you
agree with that or do either of you
believe that the use of the
pyrotechnics or the chemicals in the in
the ferret rounds the gas grenades could
have contributed to the fire uh mr gray
first of all they were not pyrotechnic
uh
canisters
and i totally agree with mr quintero
right
mr cheryl may i ask you the same
question uh the information i have to
this date there were no pyrotechnics
involved
of the
idea of the methylene chloride i agree
with the doctor on once it's in a liquid
form however it is a safety hazard when
it is in a vapor form as it's originally
injected there is a possibility but it's
something that has to be explored a lot
more
so mr mr shiro your opinion is a
possibility but
uh you would leave it as possibility
right now at this point yes sir
um
uh mr winter i want to ask that you said
that the proof of
arson was that these uh
these fires to begin required a match i
believe something like that yes well i
think that's pretty much usually our
match if they if we had a flammable
liquid it would require something like
that but it wouldn't necessarily require
a match would it
uh as i said if it were flammable liquid
we could ignite the vapors with a spark
or with a flame that's spilled on it
okay any what you mean is not a match
which is the word you use a flame a
flame sure but you didn't say the word
flame you said the word match and the
point i'm getting at is
it is my understanding that there were
lanterns being used for uh for light uh
because the electricity was turned off
in the compound did you have the same
understanding yes
is it is it possible that lanterns could
have overturned and and caused or
contributed to this fire
uh it is possible but the lantern would
have to have been lit and somebody would
have to turn over those lanterns in the
in the area of the first fire there had
been a tank there minute and a half
before and one might that might suggest
that it knocked over a lantern however
as i said due to the sensitivity of the
flare
had that lantern been lit and knocked
over we would have seen it at that time
on the flare because the flare is going
to respond to a very low temperature
rise
and a very small fire and that fire
would been been more than consistent
with a spill plant
so the fire was consistent with a
spilled lantern it was was not
i'm going to ask you to restate that
what i'm what i'm saying is that
somebody would have had to have turned
over three lanterns in those locations
if if a lantern was the starting point
of this fire all right
and how do you know elaine i cannot tell
you precisely how these fires were lit
well if there were lanterns in use
and if you had either through vibrations
of tanks hitting walls
or
through a number of people panicking
uh inside at
what they might have perceived was an
assault notwithstanding the fbi
broadcast going to them
uh couldn't either or both of those
factors have easily overturned lanterns
inside the compton well the only
evidence we have of a tank being in the
vicinity of one of the fires is the
first fire and that tank has has now
left the minute and a half after the
fire has begun
if that tank knocked over a lantern and
the lantern were lit
we would have seen it
in in that flare video because it would
have been sensitive enough to see that
if the tank had spilled their lantern
and there was no flame there to ignite
it that's possible but somebody would
have to come and put a flame in that
what if people
running around and i'm trying to picture
what it must have been like inside the
compound what if people running around
knocked over a lantern is that possible
of course it's possible i want to ask
what was the fbi's
fire plan in case that there was a fire
during their their plan to end the siege
i have no knowledge of that
did you ever ask them what their fire
plan was no because that that wasn't
what i was asked to look mr gray did you
ever ask the fbi what their fire plan
was or did you know what it was
i did not
uh mr cheryl are you aware of of uh what
the fbi's fire plan was as a contingency
in case a fire started from any cause
during this attempt to end the siege no
sir not at all
does anyone know if the fbi had a fire
plan
i don't know
mr sheriff it's my understanding you are
uh you are now retired from the bureau
of alcohol tobacco and firearms uh nose
arm retired from the united states army
i worked for six years for the bureau of
alcohol tobacco firearms okay thank you
but you did work for
the bureau of alcohol tobacco and fire
yes sir all right um i i see my time has
expired but if i have additional time
i'd like to come back to you on that and
also to you mr doyle thank you mr
chairman
mr schumer you're recognized for five
minutes thank you mr chairman and i
would like to ask mr quintieri uh some
questions
quintiary thank you
um some questions
uh we've heard a number of different
theories and i just want to bring this
out your testimony was excellent but
somewhat arcane uh
and um since i've had a chance to study
it i just want to bring these out we've
had a number of theories about how the
fire started and i want to ask you
for each theory was what you observed
consistent with that theory or not
the first is from the transcript that i
read earlier today of what happened
inside the compound that people in the
compound poured gas or some kind of
flammable substance they call it gas
here
on the floors and then later
three people in different parts well
this transcript doesn't prove that and
then they lit lit
that gas would that be consistent
with what i concluded it would be
consistent that the fire was started
deliberately it's not necessarily true
but it would be consistent that the fire
was started deliberately by people who
poured gas and then lit a match to it
yes okay a second theory and you went
over this a little bit with mr schiff
is that the fire started when lanterns
were knocked over by tanks
would that be consistent with what we
observed on the uh tape
in only one case where the tank was at
the first location and it could have
knocked over a lantern but then someone
had to light that fuel spill a minute
and a half later right so it would not
be consistent it would not be consistent
with the tank starting the fire correct
now a second theory was that people were
running around and maybe knocked them
over i will not ask you a question on
this because that's just speculation but
what i find puzzling about that
speculation is the tear gas was injected
for six hours
and within one minute
or one and a half minutes three
different people accidentally knocked
over three different lanterns in three
different parts of the building you'd
have to have that to have the running
around theory make sense yes fire is
very rare and for fire to develop in
three locations a minute apart is almost
impossible without someone intentionally
doing it another theory that we've heard
mentioned is that a flamethrower from
the tanks started the fire
now as i understand it we would have to
have seen on the clear
a hot streak going from the tank to the
building for that to happen and we did
not is that correct absolutely so you're
saying that a flame thrower from the
tank starting the fire is that
consistent is that theory consistent
with what we saw on the tape no indeed
there's no such thing as flying okay
final theory
is that methylene chloride started the
fire and you talked about that a little
bit but i just want to ask you so we get
it on the record clearly that
methylene chloride or tear gas was
somehow ignited
and started the fire
methylene chloride is well i just want
to ask you a yes or no question is it
consistent no with what you saw no that
methylene methyl
did not start or contribute to that
because if somehow a gas cloud was
ignited as i understand it there would
be a huge blowout not just three
separate fires in different parts of the
compound but one big sort of whoosh
absolutely and everything would go up
okay so in other words to summarize the
only theory of those four
we may find others but of those four
which are the four that i have heard
most commonly mentioned
the only one that would be consistent
with what you observed was that the fire
was started internally
by somebody
yes okay now
okay
um have are there any other theories
that you haven't touched on
that we have heard bandied about either
by critics of uh by people who are upset
with what happened in waco or not
am i leaving any out not that i could
think of it at this time
okay
and obviously this was a terrible uh
terrible tragedy but i get from your
testimony sir it seems to me
that there is no question
that the 80 people
who who perished and others who suffered
like mr doyle were clearly without doubt
victims but in all likelihood someone
inside the compound was the victimizer
mr gray would you agree with the
statements that have just been made
i i 100 agree with dr quintery we were
part of the same team
and
if you don't mind in the in the interest
of fairness here i did prepare at the
chairman's request a a statement that i
would like to deliver i promise it'll be
shorter than the other ones you've heard
today
um and i would like to i have it
prepared again mr gray and we don't want
to
duplicate now but i know that you
have a good reputation for that uh so
that's certainly on your time
if you yield for that person i would
deal for that purpose
my name is paul gray i'm assistant chief
of the houston fire department's arson
division i'm in my 24th year as a
professional firefighter
and i am proud to have spent my adult
life as a member of this highly regarded
and most respected profession
for the past 16 years i've also held
commissions by the state of texas as a
peace officer
and certified fire investigator
i have worked closely with many state
local and federal law enforcement
agencies and i've been recognized for my
professionalism and job performance
i have received awards for meritorious
service
i am certainly not without flaw but my
service record is
i am here today to assist in applying a
medicinal dose of the truth
to the still festering wound known as
the branch davidian incident near waco
texas
on april 19 1993 from my houston office
i watched live news coverage of the
fbi's assault on the branch davidian
compound in waco
i remember having feelings similar to
the ones i had as the space shuttle
challenger disaster unfolded on live
television
as flames engulfed the compound i kept
watching for the sight of dozens of
people safely escaping the building
just as all of america prayed for the
sight of parachutes silhouetted in the
smoke-filled sky on that other sad day
in 1986
as precious seconds passed in the
inferno grew i realized there would be
no happy ending to this story as there
was no happy landing for our astronauts
seven years before
terror sorrow sadness anger frustration
these and other inexpressible emotions
of sympathy were revoked by those
pictures
then on another morning in april two
years to the day after the fire in waco
in a split second all those emotions
were reignited by an even greater
catastrophe
in oklahoma city
homeless city
i believe that if we are to fully
comprehend where a person stands on an
issue
it would help to know how he came to
stand there
i would like to try and explain how i
came to stand where i am today
i remember many years ago as a young
firefighter and paramedic
the exhilaration of helping save a life
or the miraculous moment of birth
i remember crying over the lifeless body
of a child because i was too late to
help
i recall the sheer exhaustion of
performing cpr until every muscle in my
body ached
i'll never forget the helplessness of an
accident victim staring into my eyes
grasping my collar in his fist
and pleading with me in his last breath
not to let him die
i came to have a heightened respect for
the precious fragility of life
and as my career led me into law
enforcement i swore an oath to pursue
those who do not share that respect
i take that oath very seriously
and when other officials in public trust
violate that oath it angers me
and i take enormous satisfaction in
exposing them
in fact my current duty assignment
includes administration of the internal
affairs division in which we attempt to
maintain the integrity of our profession
which can never be attained by covering
up our mistakes
i am proud of the men and women in this
profession but my philosophy is mess up
and you're gone
as the ruins of mount carmel still
smoldered into the evening hours of
april 19th i received a call from
assistant special agent in charge of the
houston field division mr don carter who
asked if i would be willing to
participate in the investigation of the
cause of the fire
it was my understanding that atf's
national response team would not be used
in the investigation because of that
agency's involvement in the february
28th raid at the compound
i assume that the request for my
assistance was based on the following
factors
first
i was at the time the acting director of
the houston arson bureau
one of the largest fire investigation
agencies in the country located
relatively near waco texas
and secondly i was known to atf because
of my past association with their arson
task force in houston and my experience
in similar investigations as a former
member of the national response team
as the chief officer of the houston
arson bureau i had the authority to
delegate this assignment to any of more
than 50 qualified investigators under my
command
i chose to accept the assignment myself
for one reason only i wanted to do it
i met the other members of the fire
investigation team as they arrived in
waco including mr john ricketts mr bill
cass mr thomas hitchings
prior to this introduction none of the
team members had ever met
i agreed to coordinate the team's
activities and was accepted as team
leader and spokesman
this decision was made by the team
members themselves based primarily on
geographics
texas ranger sergeant lane aiken was
also assigned to to assist the team mr
john hudec mr john kaus and their
accelerant detection canine dog
responded to the scene from pennsylvania
by the way that dog was trained by atf
we selected armstrong forensic labs in
arlington texas to provide laboratory
assistance and evidence analysis
i suggested this lab because its
proximity to the scene and dr
armstrong's specialization in fire
debris analysis
dr james quintieri
and fred maurer from the university of
maryland's fire protection engineering
department were also brought in for
consultation and to focus on fire growth
rate and development
for the next nine days we examined
measured sifted photograph the fire
scene the canine was used to locate
possible areas containing flammable
accelerants we collected debris samples
documented their location and submitted
them to the laboratory
we viewed photographs of the incident
taken as it occurred and obtained
videotape from the media and the fbi
texas rangers were assigned to conduct
interviews with the surviving davidians
and members of the fbi
i hate to interrupt you but i did not
let mr quintero really go to make a
statement i had him making the
observations of the technical things of
the fire as much as i understand what
you're wanting to tell us
that you did this background work i know
you did and it will be submitted for the
record uh i feel in all fairness i'm
gonna have to let mr shara say about
three minutes or four minutes too but
our objective here we've just gone five
that's why the yellow lights come on
in all fairness we are here to ask
questions we this is the only panel i
let mr doyle tell a story because we
substituted for uh five or six davidians
who might have been here for a whole
panel and i let mr quintieri do this as
an effort to try to get on the record i
don't i don't want to be rude but unless
you've got something substantively to
add to what mr quintery said about the
fire i would like to restrict it and you
can submit that testimony for the record
we just don't have the time i have
something substantive to to add to these
hearings on the record uh especially in
response to my character being
assassinated the other day in these
hearings
that is part of this that is part of my
statement i i guess i wasn't aware
if you
if you would yeah if you could just
summarize it and go to the end it would
be very helpful i was not aware your
character is being uh attacked here in
these hearings i i certainly didn't hear
it but mr chairman it was during the uh
de garin and mr zimmerman when they were
questioning the two attorneys questioned
it yes the affiliation and i think that
that's what he was trying to clarify i
think what we can do here is certainly
make sure
that his full testimony is submitted to
for this but i i agree that we should
give him the opportunity to summarize mr
chairman please go ahead mr gray under
the circuit chairman yes mr barr
parliamentary wouldn't that be
appropriate if there's a member of this
panel that wishes to rehabilitate a
witness or go into something they're
certainly more than welcome to use their
time well i really think i think go back
to what you say if there's something
substantive we are going we are going to
have to make it very short i think mr
gray understands it if you can do a
couple more minutes and summarize where
you are i will permit it but mr gray i
just
i can't let everybody who might have
been uh feeling they've been attacked in
here
present a whole rehabilitation
credibility statement it just that is
not the nature of this hearing but
please proceed sir i'm responding to a
letter from misters assigned by mr zelif
requiring me or asking me to to prepare
a statement for delivery in here and
that's what i'm doing we appreciate it
your statement is without objection the
whole statement is admitted to the
record we've had a lot of statements
submitted for the record in writing
we've given allowed only one or two
witnesses for very peculiar purposes to
give oral testimony we've gone directly
to questioning as you if you've been
observing these hearings no
and uh and i'm not trying to cut you off
like i said be rude but it just we just
have a limited amount of time this
afternoon but please proceed for a
couple more minutes a newspaper
editorial critical of my selection to
the investigative team pointed out that
and i quote the editorial doubts are
being fed by criminal defense attorneys
renowned expert at creating doubt
reasonable or otherwise end quote i'm
sure not the only person who has heard
defense attorneys assert that is not
what they believe that is important
rather it is what they can convince a
jury after all that is their agenda a
few days ago in these hearings you heard
dramatic testimony from the same
attorney who was quoted in another news
report as saying quote arson team chief
paul gray may have tainted the
investigation due to his apparent ties
to the u.s bureau of alcohol tobacco and
firearms
in an effort to foster that belief and
further discredit me
mr boyer who's not here right now
of this committee participated in an
obviously orchestrated exercise to
expose my past affiliation with atf i
make no apologies for my past law
enforcement experiences and have never
tried to conceal them i am proud of the
work i did while assigned to the task
force as is evident by having ats
address phone number and insignia on my
business card
i am insulted to have to acknowledge
these slanderous assaults however i can
state without reservation under oath
before god and this body
that i and the members of this
investigative team reached our
conclusions with complete objectivity
independent of influence from any person
or allegiancy to any agents agency or
cause the singular focus of our
investigation was to determine the truth
i have endured personal attacks by those
who would have the world believe that i
was somehow part of a government
cover-up in favor of the fbi the atf or
this administration
frankly i could care less about the
reputation of those agencies and in fact
i didn't even vote for president clinton
no one needs to try and convince me of
the horror of this tragedy i was there i
was overwhelmed by it
the sights and smells of smoldering
human corpses haunt me still
the unrecognizable burnt figures of
mothers and mutilated children into
grotesque figures of death are still in
my nightmares
i felt a sense of indescribable
emotional sympathy for these people and
i will never ever forget it most
importantly i could never ever sleep
with a clear conscience or even live
with myself if i knowingly
misrepresented the truth about what i
believe happened in waco
certainly not to protect the reputation
of any government agency or this
administration finally
i would like to state for the record
that this hearing is two years too late
it is most certainly too late for the
innocent victims of oklahoma city
who weren't allowed the luxury of a
negotiated surrender or any other option
and for whom i also grieve
thank you thank you mr ray mr sharer i
think in fairness to you uh you should
be allowed to make a brief statement i
understand you have one
uh we would appreciate it if you would
make it brief and summarize thank you
yes sir thank you i have one prepared
request to be entered in uh will be very
brief objection i'll make a very brief
excerpt from that
there were four good agents killed at
mount carmel many wounded many of whom i
knew personally i resented it when i saw
it happen since that time i've met some
of the survivors from the fire
i want to make it very clear i don't
take sides the truth is the only side
that we need to worry about
i didn't come to these hearings with
questions or with answers i got a lot of
questions
ever since this thing has happened the
limited resources i've had to examine
i have
many many questions some of which i'll
very briefly summarize
was mr gray fully aware or not
necessarily mr grave the writers of the
report fully aware and informed as to
the full extent of the so-called
breaching operations
the reason i say this
in there the word is mentioned
to allegedly
escape from the inside
i wonder about this use of the word
allegedly
hopefully it's uh an innocent uh mistake
did mr gray or other fire investigators
really know exactly what chemical agents
and in what amount were actually
introduced into the building we still
have quite a bit of controversy on that
did the authors of the government fire
investigation report fully research the
properties of those chemicals used at
mount carmel and if so why is the data
reflected in their report technically
flawed i will cite merely two examples
one on the methylene chloride
i quote probably could not have been
ignited during deployment and delivery
by any common ignition source present in
this application
end quote however the dow chemical
corporation material safety data sheet
specifically states that this chemical
forms flammable vapor air mixtures
in addition the report states
quote the effectiveness of this product
is diminished proportionally to the
amount of air available for dissipation
which is why is it it is intended for
enclosed space application end quote
this statement is in direct
contradiction with dow chemical
corporation safety data sheet which
specifically states in confined or
poorly ventilated areas vapors can
readily accumulate and cause
unconsciousness and death end quote
do we have actual knowledge
of the training of knowledge and
training of chemical agent operations
procedures
involved in this gassing plan
the another item the flammable liquid
contamination found on items of clothing
of certain survivors of the fire were
declared to be proof that they had
started the fire
i would like to know why key information
as to how some of this contamination
occurred was emitted from the reports
specifically those survivors who exited
the south side of the building
they had to walk through an area that
was contaminated by fuel from large
tanks spilled by the government tank
operations
we also have
these uh probably the most important so
i'll just cut to that
there were statements and concerns about
could the tanks have crushed containers
of fuel
cans of gas
cylinders of propane
in the report and i quote if this had
happened an immediate vapor air
explosion or flash fire would have
occurred
involving the vehicle itself it did not
happen end quote
i must take serious exception to that
as fire investigators know or
firefighters know
unless there is a separate flame a spark
a means of initiation
fuel can be spread it can be crushed
propane tanks can be run over and they
will leak but they will not explode or
burn
this is not speculation
i took an armored military track vehicle
and ran over samples of every every
flammable liquid and gas known to be at
mount carmel and reported in the fire
report
there's no fire there's no explosion i
would like to submit this copy of the
videotape without objection
there are also uh still photographs i
wasn't aware at the time i was called to
these hearings
of the material that could be presented
so what i have is not as much as i would
hope for it to be
but uh i'll be glad to answer any
possible questions thank you
thank you mr sheriff mr hyde you're
recognized
thank you mr chairman i'm pleased to
yield my time to uh mr schiff
thank you very much chairman
mr gray i just want to begin by saying
that i agree with you
um that possible association you may
have had with atf
does not taint your testimony in my mind
as a professional but i also want to say
that anyone's association with other
organizations including the national
rifle association does not necessarily
taint their testimony either but that's
been a favorite character assassination
that's been used all during these
hearings i accept witnesses at face
value as professionals as witnesses
and i further want to say i see my role
as asking questions to bring out
testimony and evidence for conclusions
to be reached later
and for that reason mr quintieri i'd
like to come back to you a little bit
please sir
when asked by mr schumer about the
possibility that this fire could have
started in three separate locations by
lanterns overturning at the same time mr
schumer asserted and i believe you
agreed well that would take quite a
coincidence to happen
you stated uh fire is very rare uh and
they're adding to the idea that that
would be a rare event
right
and adding to the idea that that would
be a tremendous coincidence for lanterns
to be turned over simultaneously in
three different places right
you have to answer out loud recorders
can't take nods
very easily
well i have to ask you this question how
common is it
for the united states government to send
armored vehicles
to buildings inhabited by our men women
and children
and to be uh pouring tear gas into them
uh how often does that occur
i can only answer that question based on
what we see in the news media how many
times did you answer that question as an
expert how many times have you seen it
affairs how many times have you seen it
in the news media
barely seen in the news media rarely
you've seen it more than once i can't
recall
my point is i'm trying i'm trying to
picture what it was like
inside this compound
when armored vehicles are advancing
first from one place but very quickly
thereafter
uh in several places
uh and and maybe they came about because
there was
a fire from the building i don't mean
flame fire i mean shooting fire
but
there are a number of people inside that
building who who would have panicked
wouldn't they wouldn't you think that
would happen that's not a i guess
arson-related question it's a human
question when you think that might have
been going on inside that structure
again i think panic is a psychological
term and i'm not sure i can really uh re
describe panic to you in in in that
sense okay uh mr cheryl if i may turn to
you
um you testified you retired from the
united states army but did serve with
the bureau of alcohol tobacco and
firearms i would like to ask were you
serving with the bureau
uh in february of 1993 or right about
then no sorrow was not so you you
during during what period of time did
you serve with the bureau i was on uh
leave
administrative leave at that time period
in 1993 all right so you had no part in
the in in the preparation or anything
having to do with this raid no sir not
at all did you did you have the
opportunity to review it either or have
you reviewed it just uh from news
reports uh uh and and or from official
reports or from both yes sir i've had a
chance to review both and uh also talk
to people that were there uh branch
davidians and atf agents as well
well let me ask you as a former uh
professional with the bureau uh what's
your opinion of the plan and execution
of the raid back on february 28 1993
if you have if you formed an opinion
unfortunately i uh predicted something
like this was going to happen two and a
half years before waco
what i saw going on
within the bureau
what did you see within the bureau that
caused you to predict that this would
happen two and a half years before wake
up the
mindset first let me say
the people in the in the bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms they're
some of the best agents in the world
there are unfortunately some bad apples
as we see in every organization
these have tarnished the badges of the
good guys i'd like to see a tarnish
taken off i saw
recruiting of personnel
going to younger kids
who had a mindset there was a very
anti-gun
mode inside unfortunately there's a lot
of atf agents that are nra members
so they're not all anti-gun but there
are some and the attitude was moving up
toward the top and not just atf we see
it in law enforcement agencies down to
street level
city police departments now
and we heard testimony the other day
about there will be no knock search
warrants in the future they're gearing
up we're seeing
more battle gear if you will we're
seeing a mindset on the side of law
enforcement it's a dangerous mindset a
mindset to do what the the bad guys are
are winning
which is we've got to attack the bad
guys we've got to use bigger guns bigger
armored vehicles now
more and more
and unfortunately we're seeing citizens
uh most of them are the bad guys but a
lot of them that aren't are fighting
back they figure no matter what they do
they're going to get hurt whether
they're bad guys or not and i'll finish
with this question do you did you see a
mindset developing towards the idea of
military style operations as a
preferential way to go yes sir i have uh
with the armament uh with the equipment
and with the tactics and the training
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
chef ms jackson lee i believe are you
ready are you next i'm told you are
mr taylor or
who's taking time down here
you want to pass your entire site over
here
uh let's see uh mr kobel are you ready
to take some time
thank you mr chairman
uh i will extend mr the gentleman from
new mexico's remarks in that i i was not
there and i'm not an expert in
firefighting gentlemen but i don't know
that it would be all that coincidental
for liners to be knocked down given the
environment at that time
mr doyle let me ask you a question you
referred the gentleman i only have five
minutes so if you all can be brief i
will be appreciative mr doyle you
referred to wet towels did you have a
supply of wet towels there
i'm just uh commenting on what i heard
was the way that the children and the
women were found after the fire so you
wrapped in blankets and wet towels you
never saw any wet towels no
so you well do you know with certainty
i guess what i'm getting around to is
how were they how were they moist with
water
right because you had mentioned earlier
about there being an obvious scarcity of
water what was the source of the water
rain water was the only source we had so
it would have been soaked with the rain
water that you had saved up i guess
apparently yes
no one i don't think has mentioned
the possibility of the of the cause of
the fire
as being from gunfire either guns fired
from inside mount carmel or guns fired
from outside
the compound could that
mr sharon or the others could that have
ignited
the fire
uh yes sir uh go back to what i had said
in the test that had been done on the
armored vehicle crushing fuel tanks
we used one gallon cans in that test
just for samples and out of one gallon
the fuel would spurt up to 20 feet
which would could cover quite a bit of
area especially with multiple cans or
larger cans were hit gunfire could very
well set off fuels such as gasoline
lanterns the building from what has been
described to me personally
people thought they were in an
earthquake
the building was shaking uh it was
falling apart and we've seen in
earthquakes
people aren't running around setting
intentional fires i'm not saying
it was not intentionally set i'm saying
i still have a lot of study to do well
it would seem to me that it would not be
unlikely that gunfire could ignite the
flames gentlemen you all want to be
heard on that yes sir we don't have any
more studying to do we've done our
studying and this fire did not happen as
a result of gunfire certainly what mr
cheryl here says can happen it doesn't
take a fire expert uh to be able to to
know that you can run over a gasoline
can and spill the gasoline on the ground
and it not ignite mr clark do you want
to be heard
i mean i'm not familiar with any
experiments along those lines but if the
projectile from the jun gun was hot you
would have seen it on the infrared you
don't see any kind of traces like that
now certainly if a projectile punctures
a can of gasoline when it's puncturing
it then there's going to be some heat
due to that puncture and that could
ignite the gasoline
let me revert to mr doyle and extend the
gentleman from new mexico's questioning
concerning the possibility of of
lanterns
mr dole did you observe or do you have
any knowledge about lanterns
being accidentally or intentionally
knocked over that could have started the
fire during your time within the
compound
there were
lanterns in use
i observed no lanterns knocked over on
the 19th
and nor did i hear any gunfire coming
from within
mount carmel
throughout that morning thank you mr
doyle mr quintero
it has been said that some of the people
inside mount carmel
died by their own hand self-inflicted
gunshots did that did those shots were
they revealed on the flare that you were
observing
no that would be within the you know the
building and you would have to have been
able to see through the roof of the
building the flare is not capable of
that
if anything came from outside the
building in that was hot it should have
been visible on the floor
mr chairman if anyone wants uh my time's
about out but i think i'll yield the
gentleman for me i'd be glad to take it
well the gentleman mr brian can have it
that's fine tennessee got me first mr
thank you gentlemen for being with us
just very quickly to our two experts on
this left then uh the more traditional
ways of investigating arsons uh were
they employed in terms of were their
tests run to see if there were in fact
accelerants
gasoline found within the charred ruins
of this uh area and uh were burned
patterns was there enough left there to
determine burn patterns and things like
that yes there were tests what were the
results
the results
we collected
over a hundred samples
of debris
basically just fire debris
and had them submitted to dr armstrong's
lab
and uh he did analyze him
and he reported back to us his findings
and he did confirm
that there was gasoline kerosene
um coleman fuel and some other
accelerants present in the compound
you mentioned burn patterns and i said
in my statement that the this building
was essentially leveled so you really
could not look for signatures like that
but let me add something
uh
burn patterns are
uh cited by fire investigators and
recently there has been a study done and
i have some informal results from that
study to actually look at whether burn
patterns are meaningful in any way or
can be interpreted the way people think
and the conclusion is that they cannot
so one cannot just look for burn
patterns this was one of the reasons we
were asked to look into this fire as
well as
the group under paul gray and that is to
bring the science of fire in what has
been learned through fire research
into this element of fire investigation
so we can make observations and
interpret them based on the physics of
how fire would behave
and then draw conclusions from that
and i think that that is that is
that is a more important aspect
and if you a lot i think paul gray said
maybe something like this should have
been done following such a fire when
there is a national incident of such
prominence and it is a fire
i feel that in order to learn something
from that the resources of the country
should be put into understanding what
took place because fire is rare we had
an event in the world trade center where
a bomb went off
if that bomb had caused a bigger fire
people in that building would have been
threatened and we would have had a
catastrophe more than what took place
so we should learn from these events and
we should use the element of science to
bring it in bring in not only into fire
safety in general but into the area of
fire investigation this is what we tried
to do and the role that we played
brian mr kobold's time and yours have
expired miss slaughter you're recognized
for five minutes
chiro did you discuss your uh appearance
here today with anyone from the nra were
you contacted by them or have you
discussed it with them no they have no
one whatsoever
when you commented that the guys were
starting to fight back to whom are you
referring
no i was uh the average citizen the the
militia movement uh not necessarily
militia i've talked i've talked to
university professors uh doctors
grandmothers
they're they're starting to wonder
what's happening to the country uh the
government's not being honest with them
on a lot of things they're searching for
the truth
unfortunately they're getting a lot of
garbage and that's the only word i can
use
uh
about flamethrowing tanks and
conspiracies and i don't believe
is that your that is your feeling that
the government is involved in a
conspiracy here i don't believe in
conspiracy theories i don't like them i
think they're ridiculous uh there are
some things that the government needs to
be more honest and open with the public
on
but i'm sure that's going to happen
mr doyle i first want to acknowledge
your great pain and realize that you
lost your daughter but i'd really like
to understand a little bit more about
living inside that compound how long
have you been there
i first went to mel conwell in 1966.
were you are you married
were you
you were married uh was your wife with
you at the compound
uh no i've been divorced since 1976. but
your daughter did go with you
and your daughter was one of koresh's
wives
she has never
admitted that we were very close and she
has never
mentioned a word of that to me
you uh that accusation has been made
that i you know i'm not in a position to
confirm or tonight
well and i'd i'm happy to give an
opportunity for you to deny that if
that's what you believe you know i don't
believe that but
mr doyle you said that that you were
told you couldn't come out on mass who
told you that
that was the information we were given
early in
probably steve schneider since david was
pretty well incapacitated for the first
three weeks or so so it was someone
within the branch division they told you
that there were people coming down from
upstairs uh
conveying messages and so it may have
been steve i'm not real sure
and you were also told that if you came
out you could expect to be shot and
killed
the
way it was explained to me was that
the the sniper mess or the perimeter
agents who were around the perimeter and
needed to be informed that individuals
were coming out and they needed to be
described to them you know their sex
their age or how many and so on that was
the understanding i was given
when you lived at the compound mr doyle
were you free to come and go as you
pleased yes you could go anywhere you
like yes did you have to check in or out
with anyone at all
not really no
and throughout the whole time that you
were there were you aware of people
being held there against their will
people were not held against the will
uh i when uh i mean there's a whole lot
you mentioned there were a lot of places
that were off limits so
there were rules that you had to go by
but you could you could leave any time
you wanted that's correct
is it your feeling that any time during
the 51 days that you could have walked
out that door yes
but what do you think would have awaited
you
well in my case as i said i was told at
one point uh by the negotiators the only
time i ever talked to them on the phone
they asked they didn't say you were
under arrest come on out you know
they asked me when i was coming out as
far as i could remember the wording and
uh
i said well why do i need to come out i
have not committed a crime this is my
home this is where i live
and they says well you know we have to
get things you know settled we need to
talk with people and so on
and i said well where will i go if i
come out and they say well you have a
daughter in california don't you and i
says yes that's correct i said well you
can go live with her
and
as i said what we saw of those that did
come out
were they were being sent
to
jail the adults
even
elderly women in their 70s were being
actually indicted for murder or charge
this was
nearly told that that's what happened
when people came out we saw it and heard
it on the news
i see
um
mr doyle did uh
david koresh you mentioned that he
thought he was going to die is that
correct that's true what was his
reaction when he thought he was going to
die
how did he feel about it
what did he say to his followers
um
let's see
i think he was kind of
scared in some respects but uh from what
i understand he made a phone call to his
mother and left a message on her
answering machine she wasn't there that
he was and he said he would see her
you know when he returned
we we believe in a resurrection and so
it's
that uh so mr quresh like all human
beings at that point was really afraid
to die is that would that be a correct
statement
to some extent yes
do i understand mr toilet that at this
moment you still believe
mr karesh was the lamb of god and that
he is coming back on the day certainly
bringing all the people who died with
him
we believe in a resurrection which i
want to know about koresh right he will
be included yes and you believe that
throughout your time with him that what
he told you was the truth
sure i do you don't feel in any way
that you were used by him
or
made to to stay or be a part of that
organization you felt absolutely free to
come and go any anytime yes i do was it
do you know of any other religion
that requires men to give up their wives
and daughters
i've heard of some but i couldn't name
them
are you are you still an australian
citizen are you american i'm an american
citizen
uh i it
was were you a part of a religion like
this in australia
i was a member of the davidian and the
branch davidian churches in australia
before coming here yes you were brought
into that by david karesh's visit to
australia no
i i became a davidian in the branch
dividend long before david krish ever
you were with the rodents right
yes i'm sorry i have i have taken
advantage of your good feeling thank you
mr bryant uh you're recognized for five
minutes thank you mr chairman this time
i'll yield my entire time to the
chairman well i thank you for yielding
and and i will yield half my time two
and a half the time you yielded two and
a half minutes to mr zelda
uh mr doyle uh do you know brad branch
yes i do um i talked to him yesterday an
interesting conversation where were you
on 228 when the atf tried to deliver the
search warrant
i was in in my room
which was the third window from the left
on the front of the building he tells me
he was with david at the door
is that correct you know that's his
story i never saw him
he he also told me that that
the atf
there was a female agent that shot the
dog
from behind as they were delivering the
search warrant at the door
uh that's where the first shot the shot
was the dog
and then the response possibly erupted
from them do you think that's correct uh
that's possible
during our trial there was quite a
number of agents claiming that they shot
at the dogs and five dogs ended up being
killed
and and that may have
erupted in in firepower if the first
shot was actually at the dog it could
have been misinterpreted or whatever i
don't
but particularly from people that may
have noticed my personal experience the
first shots i heard were from outside
coming toward the building let me let me
ask you this
do i still have a little bit um you
you heard the testimony on the fire and
but you were there
um what do you think what were your
observations uh relative to the i mean i
i saw it on tv i saw the tanks go in i
saw us go through the buildings come
back i heard the announcement this is
not an attack um you know and the tank
would go back in and go right through
the building
what did you feel what were your
emotions well we definitely weren't
believing what we were hearing over the
loudspeakers that they were not entering
the building or this was not an attack
but
you know we were told they weren't going
to be shooting and yet they're firing
what amounted to
mortars or rockets at us these ferret
rounds which sounded like a mortar were
you you were afraid
sure yes what about the kids i mean
is this a safe place for kids to be in i
think that's why
the women ended up putting them in the
cement building because they felt they
were protected i yield my time back to
the chairman okay thank you very much mr
zelloff mr quintieri
when did that first fire start what time
precisely
yes sir
yeah i think it's 1207.42 i'll just
refer to my that's as early as you got
on the flare that would have been the
earliest time for fire starting there's
any documentation on it i just want the
record to reflect that in examining the
transcript mr schumer was referring to
when the quote at the end was let's keep
that fire going the time listed here was
11 48. that would be inconsistent with
what we saw with what you saw on the
tape that's right i also would like to
ask you a question about the other
comments apparently there was fuel being
poured or spread at 6 7 a.m in the
morning wood fuel i don't know what the
fuel was but it might have been kerosene
for lanterns who knows but would normal
fuel we think of fuel oil or kerosene or
wouldn't it evaporate
or would it evaporated by noon it would
begin to evaporate but if it's
saturating into the wood floor it could
still be ignited later uh if it's
something like gasoline it's going to
evaporate much more rapidly than
kerosene and it's going to be much
easier to ignite than kerosene
well there's some pretty uh
i guess you could say damaging
statements here with regard around 723
about questions about is a way to spread
the fuel in there and some hay and this
sort of stuff
but there is a question mark in my mind
about whether the fuel being poured
earlier might not have been just simply
pouring it into these lanterns we don't
know obviously we don't we don't know
and what i might add is that
when one says that a fire is
appears to be intentionally accelerated
it could have been done based on using
flammable liquids it could also been
done based on the way
the normal fuel load might be arranged
the way you stack chairs if there were
there were bales of hay the way that was
arranged those things could have added
to the
you're not aware of there being any hay
in there though other than that yes i i
did see bills
mr you heard earlier a writ a litany of
of reasons of possible ways that fire
could have been started in there we got
one added by mr schiff about the gunfire
uh but you know from all kinds of
listings mr schumer read off
uh and mr quintiary responded to each
one of those in the negative that none
of those were possible in your statement
it seemed to me you were in an effort in
part contradicting that but i'd like for
you to run through with me if you'd
agree if you don't or if you disagree
with the different possible methods of
starting that fire that were ruled out
by mr quinte erie can you do that uh yes
sir uh the first one is the flame
throwing tank absolutely did not happen
uh the flame on one of those to set the
record straight was 180 to 200 meter rod
would have blown right through the
building
so that didn't happen that did not
happen does it uh the lanterns being
knocked over
there is a possibility however we'd have
to have fuel leaking ahead of time which
could be attributed they could be in
areas crushed
by the vehicles uh during the assault on
the building
especially in the the rear area of the
building a lot of damage was done
there's a lot of things that could
happen
uh the thing that really concerns me is
why the building was so totally
destroyed
afterwards after the fire was was out
there was no firefighting whatsoever
attempted
and then the crime scene and it was a
crime scene was totally absolutely
destroyed i've seen this happen before
well i understand that but my point i
don't want to take a time asking a
question though is that you did not
dispute
the
generally speaking the answers mr
quintieri gave you you would have ruled
out those things that he ruled out in mr
schumer's response yes sir all right
that's just what i wanted to know
because i didn't want to leave something
hanging because your your statement was
somewhat critical comparatively speaking
and i wanted to find out uh at this time
let's see
mr watt you're recognized for five
minutes mr chairman i yield one minute
to miss slaughter and four minutes to mr
scott i thank you very much for yielding
mr doyle i wanted to make one other
comment uh the forensic laboratory
finding show that on your shoes was
substance identified as camp stove oil
which would indicate that you had walked
across it
on your way to the hole from which you
escaped
correct well after how came out of that
being there
the fuel oil was not in the area of the
building inside the building it was when
we came out they had
tipped over our diesel and gasoline
supplies that we had uh we had four
large tanks on pedestals which are
obvious
mr
that the fire that you saw that covered
the hole that you came out of
immediately after your departure have
been uh raging there because there was
camp uh stove oil fuel on that floor
is it possible i don't believe not in
the area where we came out no you were
not aware of any fuel of any sort
there had been
a lot of the women would bring their
lanterns into the chapel
during the scene i'm talking about but
not in the area we exited from no all
right thank you thank you mr white thank
you
mr doyle were you tried for any uh were
you one of the defendants in the trial
yes i was i spent 10 months in jail and
went through the san antonio trial and
was exonerated on all points okay during
the trial did any defendants whether it
was a joint trial everybody tried to
have 11 defendants did any of the
defendants stipulate that the fires
started were started by people inside
the compound
not that i know no
they were trying to from what i
understand
say that i was the one that littered
because my hands were burnt but that
those charges were withdrawn uh during
the trial because of lack of evidence
and so on i think they were they were
building this point up because of the
shoe the dog hitting on the shoes and so
on you have you have no knowledge of any
defense attorney stipulating the
davidians started the fires
i've heard since the trial that there
were
defense lawyers that are making that
claim in in in the press
what about during the trial
you're not aware of it during the trial
i don't remember coming out in the trial
and no divi
did any davidians
mention or admit during the trial that
they had set the fires no
not to your knowledge no
no not to your knowledge not to my
knowledge did any of the defendants
admit
mr gray can you comment uh about the
flammability of cs gas again i mean i
think we went
you're i think you said that it was not
flammable is that right
that it did not contribute to the to the
fire secretary how do you spell how do
you spell your last name because we have
to do two different spellings and it's
you i n t i
e r e okay
uh can you can one of you or both
comment on the flammability of cs uh gas
whether it contributed to the
dr quintery's move right whether it
contributed to the fire or not
in my opinion it did not contribute to
the fire
based on the fact that as an airborne
flammable vapor
it did not evidently reach a
concentration for the methylene chloride
that would have caused the fire
propagation through this compound we did
not see any such behavior that would be
indicative of a flammable vapor
in other words like a natural gas leak
in a building nothing like that was seen
secondly
if this
methylene chloride or cs deposits on
objects that will later burn
is there a question as to whether they
would enhance the fire spread over these
objects make them ignite easier
all right in my conclusions the answer
to that also is no and it's based on the
data in the literature and experiments i
did just recently to make that point
more definitive and what were the
results of your experiment that
methylene chloride did not have any
enhancement effect
on the fire propagation in this fire
and in addition in one of the
experiments the methylene chloride
actually put out a candle flame that was
adjacent to to a dish of methylene
chloride the vapors actually put out the
candle flame so it could actually act as
an inhibitor under some circumstances
and the remainder of the time mr gray i
think you were cut off in your statement
did you
not have time to
finish your uh were the things you
wanted to say didn't have time to say it
well i kind of
i omitted a part of it but
just for your information to clarify
something important about fire
in any fire investigation
there are a limited number of
conclusions that can be drawn
fire either occurs as a natural
phenomenon as a result of an accident or
intentional human conduct
when there's insufficient evidence to
support a definitive conclusion we have
no problem
leaving it undetermined and that's what
we will do if we don't know
when there is no reasonable doubt
however
as to the origin and cause of a fire as
in this case a clear conclusion may be
drawn without reservation and that's
what we did
in this case um
to to further
get back to something that mr cheryl had
said earlier in in response to a
question about the different ways this
fire could have occurred and some of the
questions that he had
um
we are not saying and never did say that
you can't cause a fire by kicking over a
lantern like mrs o'leary's cow theory
uh certainly that can happen
what we had to do is take all of these
theories like a bullet striking a
flammable liquid uh like a lantern being
tumped over and all these other theories
and we had to apply them not in general
terms but we had to apply them to this
specific case under what we know
happened by the the primarily and
admittedly the photographic evidence
helped us more than anything i think in
this investigation
so
when we took our for instance our
samples our debris samples we compared
those samples taken and identified in
the areas where we saw fire in the
photographs
and enhanced and improved or
corroborated i should say by the
infrared
the the thought of a tank running over
the report responds to an allegation
that a uh in fact it was another one of
those unfounded conspiracy seeds laid by
jack zimmerman that said originally that
the tank had run over a propane cylinder
and caused the fire and that's what
started the fire
what we were responding to was the fact
that propane is a liquefied petroleum
gas
and when exposed to atmosphere when open
to atmosphere it evaporates very rapidly
what what we meant in our report
is that had a tank run over a propane
cylinder exposing a gas like that we
most probably would have had a fireball
right then and there because propane if
not ignited early in a 25 mile an hour
wind and dr quintario agree with me it
dissipates very rapidly it doesn't leave
a pool uh to just sit there for a while
the other thing
was um
the the flammable liquid containers the
gasoline cans the coleman fuel cans and
i think i saw some photographs some big
pictures that we could show if somebody
has them somewhere
there are those cans very important they
were found in the debris
if you close a cylinder excuse me a
container if you fill a container with
gasoline or water for that matter
and you seal the top of it and you set
it in a room and you set that room on
fire
there will be an increase in pressure in
the inside of that can due to
due to the liquid trying to expand and
trying to convert into a vapor
as that occurs that container begins to
swell until it just basically gives up
it will break and it'll rupture spilling
its contents
after the fires out
we will find that can
and it will show evidence of internal
heat rupture pressure
and it will be evident that that can was
closed and sealed up at the time of the
fire
however in this case
we found about two dozen
flammable liquid containers
with the tops removed
not
not blown up but removed we also found
some of these containers and there is a
photograph i saw it just this morning
of holes punched in the side of these
containers not not that they were
flattened and we did find by the way we
did find a couple of containers that
were actually smashed and they could
have admittedly been smashed by a tank
and they were back there in the
gymnasium area the last place to catch
on fire i shouldn't i should add
we did find some flattened containers we
did find the containers
that were not flattened and they were
not over pressured and ruptured they
were opened
and they were had holes punched in them
similar to inconsistent with a knife
blade and finally
the
explosion
the big explosion
the question was asked of mr quintero
earlier about had he heard of any other
theories yes i've heard of another
theory in fact as part of the the
lawsuit against the government
i read a part of an affidavit submitted
that said
that the fbi on foot entered the
building shot the davidians and planted
an explosive device on top of the church
vault that he called it we referred to
it as the bunker because it's a concrete
cinder block
that's another theory that did not could
not have possibly happened
in this this particular incident
referring to that explosion the
explosion happened well after the
building was totally destroyed
it was it was very unlikely
that uh that that explosion was anything
other than a propane cylinder as dr
quintery pointed out he did this guy's a
wizard with the man
uh i i asked him many times i probably
bored him to death but i asked him a lot
of real dumb questions and i asked him
very plainly and simply doc is it
possible for this to happen
and he would give me a mathematical
formula and show me that there is no way
that
cylinder of propane we found in the
courtyard there is a small
courtyard
um that is next to
the the center part of the building
in a little alcove
there was in fact a 100 pound
propane cylinder
with a piece of the top
blown out about the size of a football
exactly where
that explosion occurred and i have no
doubt that that is what the big
explosion is and it was certainly not an
incendiary device nor was it a bomb that
the davidians had planted in there thank
you very much your time has expired mr
shattuck you're recognized for five
minutes
i'd like to thank the members of this
panel i think it's been very helpful
testimony mr quintieri
uh i'd like to give you an opportunity
to explain
one issue that's
been that i think you had to rush over
in your testimony it is the flash in the
window there's this long dog run if
you'll recall that's on the top of the
gymnasium that runs the opposite
direction and there's a window one
single window at the law at the end of
that long
what they called the dog run
and as the camera was going by the
infrared camera there's a flash of heat
in that window and i think you said
if you can show
show the dog run
there you go that's the dog run that
window you said there was a moment
carrier or
an incident
that wasn't repeated can you explain why
that's not a fire
again for us okay uh
i didn't discern that it was in the
window i thought it was more in the
debris pile in that location
okay if that that's what we're talking
about it was a momentary flash
uh
it's uh indicative of sunlight
reflecting off something and registering
on the flare it could be a thermal
pattern if it were a thermal pattern
there is nothing that persists from that
right so therefore it is more likely to
have been reflected light off of
something shiny in which the sunlight
now gives an apparent temperature rise
and if you don't know if excuse me
excuse me
if the i would just want to ask you the
flare if it were i saw it and it looked
to me like it came off the window okay
um if the the flare would pick up a
flash off the window is that what you're
saying
some kind of reflection i was told that
some of these windows were boarded over
and some of them had aluminum foil on it
so if it were aluminum foil caught at
the right angle with the sunlight you
would see that we're going to see it
again i think in a minute because we're
going to show some of the flare tape it
is just a quick flash i agree with you i
just wanted to understand what that was
if it's the sun flashing off so be it
um mr chairman the next point i want to
make is that uh during my questioning
really of mr potts and mr hubble um i
went into some issues
they dealt with
the flir tapes the fbi tapes that were
taken i understand we're going to show
those in a moment
so that we can see what they showed but
though i had not asked mr clark a
question he became quite angry
over some of my questioning and demanded
to know if we had we here on the panel
had this report
it turns out and i've checked with staff
on both sides and i just for the record
would like it to reflect
first of all talking with staff both for
the judiciary committee and for the
government operations subcommittee um
neither none of our staff indicate that
we had this report we absolutely did not
have this report in this form
i understand a discussion went back and
forth between the justice department
officials who are here
and our staff and they say well you had
it we did hold up what appeared to be
this document and mr clark said it was
flat not that document it is indeed not
that document
the only thing that the justice part
department now says is that it may have
been in stacks of paper like this that
we received
i never saw it and it wasn't given it to
us and it was not identified to us in
any way as the april 12
briefing paper for the attorney general
mr clark is not with the attorney
general's office now nor with the fbi so
perhaps he did not know that we did not
have it or that we did not have it in
that form i certainly was unaware of it
um it is i understand the report that
the footnote on page 272 of the
department of justice report says that
the attorney general herself did not
read carefully uh nor did she read the
supporting documentation for it with
that uh i'd like i understand when you
show the videotape that is the flare
tape
which shows these incidents leading up
to the fire
anything of that nature that mr shetty
would like i don't know how lengthy this
uh tape might be for points mr chairman
it may be worthy to speed the tape up so
that we don't we're gonna you direct
that whatever you want uh here if you
can see the tape and and uh mr quinte
area maybe you could point things out
could you point out that tank with your
little indicator your green indicator
you see the tape the tank now going into
the back of the building
this is the gym
the perpendicular line at the top is
what they call the dog run with the
window
maybe
there's the first entry of the tank
there are a series of these if you have
the ability as i understand you do to
show double time maybe when the tank is
way away from the building
you could speed the tape up
so that we can see uh principally it's
entries
okay that is double time
there we go this is uh
a second entry
mr quinchieri with the with the bright
light at the back of the tank be the
exhaust of the tank uh that's the engine
i think it's the heated back part of the
tank thank you it might be possible to
see the exhaust as well
mr quinn here if you could pull the
microphone yes i'm sorry
i would allow mr shatter to explore this
with you for a little bit
that's part of his question to get this
tape clarified
as you see now the tank is approaching
again it's still at the right edge of
that roof
going at the corner of the
mr clinton do you know where the bunker
is can you show that with
the bunker is back there
there's yet another entry by the tank
and at some point the tank disappears
into the building
i'm not sure which entry it is
there was a plume of heat it looked like
they came out the back of the building
at that point
again that white light coming out back
out is the engine at the back of the
tank
that's correct that would be my
interpretation maybe you can point out
the white that i'm referring to with it
thank you sir
[Music]
this is the point which the tank again
disappears
for some time into the interior of the
building
um
this continue on for quite a while mr
shattuck it does if this is double time
maybe we can speed it up ultimately
there comes a point where the right
corner of the roof collapses onto the
tank
there we go
now you can see so if you can stop it
right there
you can see where now the roof has
collapsed with these multiple entries
if you can take the green and show the
dog run and then show that shadow
there's the dog run and then below it is
a shadow showing where that whole
section of roof has collapsed away and
now if you can show the tank i think
this is the point which the tank begins
to go up onto the roof
right there okay if you proceed
and maybe this is double time okay
as you can see at that point there's a
the tank is now going up on the left
half of that roof
it's already gone up on the right hand
do we know what time this was yes i
believe we do it shows it's a i believe
it's right around 12 o'clock 12 11 31 11
31 so it's a half an hour or so before
the fire began
is that correct mr quinn here that's
correct
and in a part of the building where the
fire didn't in fact start
except for that force fourth uh
incident that we saw in the video
i think my point of my question earlier
was not that the fire in fact started
here but that it could have started here
once you started destroying a part of a
building that that kind of destruction
could have led to the start of a fire
whether it did or did not
certainly it could but it didn't
we're evaluating what's the risk what
changes do we need to make if we take
excessive risk
that's the issue frankly any time you
run into a a
framed construction building like that
with a tank you run a risk of burning it
down
as you can see now if you would mr
quintieri show that
now the right half of that roof has been
destroyed and i believe just a few more
frames here the left half of the roof is
in fact destroyed itself and that's the
rubble we later see consuming fire
that's correct
mr shedding how much more of this tape
do we need i'm not trying we're just
about finished mr chairman uh we've now
destroyed the right half of the roof
uh
completely we take a couple more runs
and destroy the left half of the roof
uh and and essentially i think the tank
backs out
if you can see the ridge line um mr
quintero maybe you can point out that
ridge line
you'll see that in a few frames and in
the still frames we have up
it was destroyed all the way up to the
ridgeline this is what you're talking
about well i'm talking about the
ridgeline going the other way this and
the next one further down right there
all the way from the left from the green
arrow to the left that roof becomes
destroyed along that ridgeline go ahead
don't actually fall down
what can you tell us can you read for us
the time now it's now 11 43 and we're
running at double speed thank you
keep running it
it's after 12 o'clock i think what
you're looking for is that flare it's
after 12 minutes is the player after 12
o'clock and is a tank present at that
time um
it's in the area there's a tank it was
in york it was in the video which you
showed right mr quintieri yeah
if you
if you allow me if you run it to 1208
that's about the time
that you show up
at that point we'll be able to see at
this point as i said it's difficult to
count the number of entries of the tank
but the points made i believe
we're running ahead to 1208 fast forward
sure enough okay that's fair enough
we're trying to save your time and
everybody well we want to chairman thank
you
we're at the we're on uh mr shattuck's
time of actually mr quinney area is
theoretically answering this question
which we're getting to at 1208 as soon
as this tape gets there and it'll all be
over
mr chairman
with all due respect
if mr conyers time went against my five
minutes and was measured to the what are
we now mega second
we're at 1204 at this time mr chairman
and if we might mr quinney area if you
could show that that where now it's now
destroyed to the roof line
mr truman that's fine i really have
nothing further mr quinoa has explained
the flash if he wants to show it on his
tape for his tape that's fine but he i
wanted to give him an opportunity to
explain that flash in the window i did
see it people have raised it with me i
think people need to understand if it's
a reflection of light it's a reflection
of light so be it
that's all i want to do
i think thank you very much thank you mr
shad again and miss jackson lee you're
recognized for five minutes
[Music]
thank you very much mr chairman
i have started off many of the
questioning that i have done
uh acknowledging the tragedy of the loss
of life
and have made that known to many of the
witnesses that have come forward
mr doyle i'd like to acknowledge that to
you
and as i um
try to get an understanding of how we
can
ensure
the real facts and that this does not
happen again
on all parts
i do want to understand
something that i read
in the new york times article
but as well
david koresha's theology suggests that
he would come back in 42 months i
believe
from april 1993
and i think mr doyle you said uh that
you hope he comes back pretty soon
what do you mean by that
uh and when would pretty much in my
lifetime surely
even a lot sooner than that but we don't
set any times and i don't believe david
ever exactly said it that way that he
would be back in
42 months
did he say it that way are you saying i
said i don't i don't recall ever hearing
him put a time on it
what would he say to you when he sees
you
i hope he uh
indicates that he's pleased to see me
i don't know what he'll say what would
he say about your escape
coming out of the building
you go through a lot of guilts when you
come out of a situation like this and so
many others don't i feel somewhat guilty
that i'm alive i feel somewhat guilty
that i'm out of jail
i don't think he would condemn me for it
uh if that's what you're thinking
but i don't really know what he'll say
until that day happens
and
is he or would he come back
as a human or as god
or however you would interpret it would
be better in your interpretation
pardon what we would call a glorified
body visible uh
but not bound by the flesh
and so you right now are not sure when
that might be no
would he ask you um
about how you escape
would he ask you about how you escaped
spartan i expect him to already know
you mentioned um that you were in the
chapel weren't feeling well all day is
that my understanding or most of the day
i've been sick the day before
the 18th i had been in bed sick all that
day
and because i guess i'd dozed off and so
on i wasn't able to sleep that following
night so i had come down to the chapel i
was in the chapel at 6 00 am when the
gassing first started were you in the
chapel most of the day
throughout the uh the 19th yeah
up until the
word of the fire is
you had indicated several
comments about what happened throughout
the compound was that based upon what
people told you coming back and forth
i made
one trip up to my room in order to get
some water
i had some water in a
glass
container and when we were told that the
gas would affect our clothes our food
our water and so on
i thought to myself well it's not going
to go through glass probably so i went
and retrieved water at that time i
noticed that my room was in the process
of being demolished then that was fairly
early in the day you you told us about
incidences that happened around the
compound was that based a lot on people
coming and telling you since you were in
one area
uh depends on which instances you're
talking about you mentioned the
cafeteria in other locations
i was not aware
as far as the
round hitting jimmy riddle in the face i
was told that by somebody let me ask you
quickly and i apologize to you have some
questions for the gentleman dealing with
the fire itself uh why were you not
allowed to go to certain rooms in the
compound
some rooms were off limits because they
were private david's private rooms were
basically off limits unless you're
invited
the machine
where he would take his wives in some of
the rooms
that's where he
slept up until he moved
he was not in those rooms on the day of
the raid
that he would take some of his wives in
those rooms he would take
people in there he'd take men in there
if he wanted to give him a bible study
or he'd take the women in there if
that's
what was going on
and if he was sleeping and that's where
he would take his wives in those private
areas
into his rooms yes let me ask some and
mr chairman i'd ask the same deference i
need the tape run because i have to ask
mr quintery a question about the escape
i have always
wanted to pursue
the availability and thank you mr doyle
of the or the opportunity for escape and
you mentioned there was the tape where
you would show us of the person jumping
off the building i would like you to get
me to that point please so that i could
see that and i'm going to be talking the
questions to both you and mr gray
of uh this whole issue of escape
one the question is as in terms of the
timing the last questioner
had does go through a series of films
that started at 11 31 with the
cevs
and so my question is it seems that the
first cev came
about that time or maybe they were there
beforehand but the question is the fire
started how much beyond
uh the cev and i i don't want to disturb
you i need you to get to the film so i
don't lose my time on uh that question
but how much more time after that cev
that we saw at 11 31 did the fire start
and is that likely that you could hit
something at 11 31 and
you be the cause or that entity be the
cause of a fire and it didn't show up
until about 12 when it began to show up
not likely as i said there could be a
spill of fuel but it would have to be
ignited later in some fashion that's the
only possibility so that 20 minutes
except for the lighting of
certainly would have been rare for the
cev to be the only reason that 20
minutes later a fire started not from
this
the flame would not have come from the
cev hitting the building that's what i'm
trying to determine that's right are you
going to get to that for me because i'm
like that's what i need you and mr grey
to answer that's the way you showed me
where the person jumps off the roof
that's what you would like to see yes
not the one running on the ground but
the one jumping off let's go to uh 1218
and i'd like mr gray and mr uh terry to
answer the question about the
possibility of escape
as you watch this person in how long a
period of time
that
was so to reflect upon whether
80 people 50 people 30 people could have
secured an opportunity for escape
if you showed some flashes flashovers
and i need to see the context of that so
i can
uh you have to go back that's the person
jumping let's go back
because i missed it i was looking at you
i'm sorry yeah yes
all right
let's stop at that point
here you see the person on the roof that
person had previously come out of one of
these windows
uh that person lay on the roof for some
time and has now made a decision to jump
on
and we have not identified who that
might have been yes
that was uh abram reynolds
brandon
all
riddle had already come out
i understand
ruth riddle is the person who jumps if
i was told that and i'll i'll show you
that
uh
you know just after this if we let this
run let's let this run
so this individual is walking away
and then at 12 19 in 15 seconds
is this the time i'm sorry
approximately 12 minutes after the start
of the first fire
12 19. yeah 12 19 we will see someone
jump out of this window
that's a second floor window
fire conditions would have been much
more severe there than on the first
floor
and certainly people in the vicinity of
this opening could have walked out
if they were in that vicinity at about
the same time or even later would it
been likely here she is
or if that's miss riddle
there's a person jumping hanging from
that window
falling
all right and and therefore
that area there
from your fire experience evidence is
that it was clear enough for someone to
get to a window
or that it was clear enough that if
individuals in that area
they could have come out
i believe people that were in this area
would have had longer time to survive
and certainly people near these openings
on the first floor where wind would be
blowing through and providing fresh air
they would have had more time to get out
people in the dining room if there were
people there
uh or people who stayed in the bunker
which ignited later
uh they would have had
to get out much sooner disagree in your
experience with hands-on fire
suppression
and saving people
what period of time
is a range of time
that people could save themselves with a
fire raging
from the inception of this fire we're
talking about this fire only not in
general we're being specific here
we feel like because obviously we're um
you know 10 12 minutes
14 minutes after the fire begins
i would um
take a an educated guess of about 20 to
22 minutes
from the inception of this fire from the
first ignition
um that there may have been some viable
conditions inside the building
you say people in a 20-22 period time
period or people 20 minutes they're
about so i think they had they had 20
minutes or so to get out of the building
before they were
overcome
the point has been made and your time is
up but i would in your time if you'd let
i'd like mr
jerry maybe to explain where in all of
this sequence mr doyle came out if mr
doyle could tell us that i mean as long
as we got this picture up here i think
people would like to know that i haven't
attorney will yield the time that i have
for you mr chairman just for that
purpose can you uh
do you know mr doyle you where did you
come out of the building you know you
can't see where
uh four of us came out we came out on
around the corner on the
right hand side of the screen
uh out of the chapel the very back part
you can't see it in these not from this
angle
thank you
thank you very much
at this point i might just add that um
the three that came out ahead of me
met
rennis abraham when he walked away from
the front there they met at the corner
and they all were out before i came out
you came out after these that we saw
jumping there were three went out ahead
of me unbeknown to me at the time but
when i came out and ran into the razor
wire fence i looked up and they were
already walking up to the gate
so they'd met at the corner thank you mr
uh mr barr you're recognized for five
minutes thank you mr chairman uh mr
doyle uh previously we've heard
testimony from
the fbi that during the course of this
whole day that is april 19th uh while
the banks were coming back and forth and
to see the cs gas being inserted that
they were broadcasting a message over a
loud speaker did you hear that message
a lot of the time yes
uh was that the message you recall some
of the words being this is not an
assault not assault we're not entering
the building okay was that being played
at the same time as
the pictures of mr shattuck showed us
earlier of tanks going in and smashing
down walls and going up on the roofs
well
it probably started before the actual
penetration but it continued during that
time as far as i know yes
in other words while the tanks were were
smashing into the building they were
saying we're not going to enter the
building right okay
uh mr doyle there's also been a great uh
not a great deal of testimony but some
testimony and i know you're aware of it
from uh from your experiences as well as
the previous trial
about uh
the uh the bugging device picking up
discussions about fuel being placed
around and putting fuel out and saving
fuel and so forth the morning of the
19th very briefly what were those
conversations concerning if you know i
never heard the remarks about pouring
fuel or
spreading fuel
i did hear
one remark in the vicinity of the foyer
area or
you know the front part of the church
because of the cans of fuel that were in
the hallway when the tank began to come
in the front door somebody made it we
might we better get the fuel
and several of us ran over and either
grabbed one or two cans one in each hand
or whatever and moved it to what we
thought was a safe location i took mine
back to the back stairway and just put
them on the bottom there okay i'd like
to draw your attention to the large
blow-up of a photograph on the easel
here
and mr bush will point out a tank
entering the front of the building
uh is that uh is that the front of the
building where they're taking tank is
entering
that is the front of the building but
it's not the front door area that's
right
uh
if that tank kept going would it uh
would it go directly to the bunker area
what they called the bumper
okay do you know if the tank came came
in close proximity with the bunker
during uh our trial
the driver of the cv
said that he went right on into the
kitchen area which was right in front of
the
tower there and his comment was he never
saw so many cans of beans and stuff in
his life or something to that effect
okay whether he hit the
concrete i don't know okay do you know
if there was any cs gas in in the bunker
from what i understand his purpose for
going in was that he sprayed at least
one canister or one bottle of gas from
the boom in there with the almost point
blank range okay we had earlier here but
i think some of the
witnesses earlier took them with them a
blow-up of this
schematic diagram here
which shows the location of
the bodies
and there's a great concentration of
bodies that were found
in the bunker
that's where the women and children were
what was their what was the reason for
them going to the bunker area
well i can only speculate i don't know
but i would say that they probably felt
it was
safer that it would maybe protect them
from the gas
was the bunker area one of one of the
lowest uh rooms in the in the building
was on the first floor okay
mr uh
quintery uh if someone
during during the time when the when the
airplane was flying around taking the
infrared uh uh pictures
if somebody were
in one of the rooms
in the top floor
below the roof
and they struck a match would that show
up on the
on the flare film no
okay if a weapon were discharged inside
of a room
would that be picked up
possibly if the projectile is hot
okay uh but uh the striking of a match
the lighting of a coleman lantern would
not have been
picked up
okay
uh you mentioned earlier going back to i
think mr shattuck's line of questioning
or at least he discussed this the
hot spot that may have been a reflection
uh could that have been something other
than a reflection as well we don't know
what it was dude we don't know what it
was but it was momentary and and did not
persist it and it didn't recur did not
did not
uh let me ask you and uh i know that i'm
not asking for
for you to speculate as to whether or
not
some something was was likely or not but
just possible we went into this with
some of the previous witnesses and if
you've already covered this i apologize
for going over it again but could the uh
the cs gas in them and the methylene
chloride vapor have uh
possibly operated as an accelerant
the answer to that is no okay it could
not have no
it is it is possible that that the
methylene chloride
because it's flammable in the vapor
state between about 12 and 20 percent
it could they could ignite and propagate
nothing like that behavior was seen in
this fire so we can roll that out
definitively
okay thank you
time has
expired uh miss lofgren you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
you know mr gray when you made your
comment about how you felt when you saw
the fire for the first time i felt it
just brought back memories for me
because i felt exactly the way just
sick and
close to tears just thinking about what
was happening and i think i was glad you
said that because i think it reminded a
lot of us how we felt
and the question is you know how did it
happen did it have to happen and i think
to some extent at least i hope that that
this
hearing will at least help in some way
to
to determine that
you know i am
listening to you mr doyle i was uh and
i've been saying throughout
these hearings i think it's important
whether
i share your faith or not that people
should have tried to understand the
world from the point of view of yourself
and others whose beliefs differ
from my own
and i'm not sure that happened perhaps
it was impossible for that to happen
but one of the things i'm wondering
about is
your relationship
uh or i don't know that's probably not
the right word but uh between
mr cora she was your leader and
yourself and the and the other davidians
for 51 days between the february atf
rate and april 19th there were all kinds
of discussions
going on between mr koresh and i think
mr schneider as well as the negotiators
did he talk to you about what the
content of those negotiations and what
was said
steve schneider would at times tell us
what was being discussed on the phones
but not minute by minute rundown and
what about david porish
as i said david was basically
incapacitated for the first several
weeks anyway of the siege and um
i only probably saw him two or three
times in the whole 51.
so he didn't
the fbi at certain points negotiators
were urging uh people to leave and
urging him to have people leave that was
never he never like had a meeting and
told people the davidians that
necessarily no steve schneider went
around
day by day and would ask well who wants
to go out today that was
a daily routine as far as
on steve's part
but it wasn't like they said you should
leave now and he didn't play that role
yes of course i mean no he didn't come
down and
make a point we had asked and actually i
think mr taylor asked and i thought it
was a good idea i guess we're not going
to do it to enter to subpoena some of
the reporters who've written stories and
i think all of us in public life know
that just because it's printed in the
newspaper doesn't mean it's that's what
we've come to learn
so
since you're under oath i'd like to ask
you a question about there was an art a
series of articles printed in the waco
tribune herald and in that one of part
three of that series there is a story uh
i'll summarize it there was a
barbra slauson
and yourself were going for a um a
shopping trip of some sort and that the
car stopped and that you believed that
korish had the power to stop that
vehicle is that an act is that true or
not true that's not even familiar with
that story at all i don't recall it
karen is my oldest daughter your oldest
daughter would you believe
as part of your faith that mr korsh
would have have had the ability to do
such a thing
to stop stuff
david made a point of always saying i do
not have the ability to do miracles my
only gift we might say is
to explain the scriptures as god showed
them to him
he made no profession of doing miracles
or tricks or anything all right let me
let me ask you that you're there's an
article in the new york times as well
that uh indicates
i guess you were interviewed and another
lady
who also
uh a davidian who did not
perish
uh
quoting or paraphrasing that
korash was a prophet and that what
happened was outlined in the book of
revelations do you believe that's true
if you could just say yes no because i'm
about to run out of time okay uh we
accepted originally we accepted david as
a prophet we come to accept him as
somewhat more than that toward the end
um i don't want to interrupt but i've
got about 30 seconds left and i've got
one more we saw connections with what
happened uh to what we were being taught
but they are not the complete
fulfillment so so what happened really
was not complete but pretty close to
what was expected during in the future
i see let me ask mr gray
and
mr doyle referenced it earlier
in his testimony that
he was and i can't remember what the
exact
phrase is
an arson dog had hit on him for his
clothes and shoes i'm not an artist
investigator he'd also indicated today
in his testimony that he didn't see
anybody
tip over
lanterns or and and that he certainly
you know just didn't see anything like
that why would a dog episode did a dog
do that
why would that be what could the
explanation for that be in your
professional judgment sir
the answer your question is we did bring
in
a specially trained hydrocarbon
accelerant detecting
canine in this is similar to a drug dog
or bomb dog they're trained to sniff out
and alert when they smell hydrocarbon
related products
the dog hit on about a hundred different
places in the compound we basically
gritted the ground out and had the dog
trace over most of it and the dog hit
made positive alert signs
in about a hundred places
and they corresponded with the points of
origin that we established
the dining room area the chapel and that
left excuse me right front window
one of the other things we had the dog
do
is
sniff if you will the clothing that had
been removed from the davidians as they
left the building including mr doyle's
clothing
i think he testified earlier that
um he stepped in some kerosene or
something outside on his on his uh shoes
well
the problem with that is
when the dog alerts on something and i
also have to say this i have to qualify
it a dog's sensitivity is about a
thousand times more sensitive than a gas
chromatograph
what i mean by that is a dog may alert
on something and it comes back negative
from the lab laboratory that is
in this case
the dog did alert on mr doyle's shoes
they were submitted to a laboratory and
the laboratory analysis showed that that
was
a light naphtha
consistent with coleman fuel
just like the can in the picture we had
earlier coleman fuel which was also
found in the uh inside the chapel area
where mr doyle was and and where he
escaped from
his jacket very interestingly was also
alerted on by the dog
we removed the jacket
laid the jacket out on the ground with
both sleeves spread out and actually
walked around the jacket with the dog
the dog only alerted on the cuffs of the
sleeves
mr doyle's hands are not burnt the way
you would think of a thermal burn his
hands were on fire
the sleeves of that jacket
were also analyzed
and
the laboratory report
determined that they did contain
a class zero deep paraffinated kerosene
consistent with in fact i remember this
phone call because i had no idea what
these items were they were all numbers
to me dr armstrong called me
and told me i have an identifying on you
know number 19 c or whatever it was
he says
it's charcoal starter fluid
and i congratulated him very good doc
you did a great job and he says you want
to know what kind and i said yes he says
it's gulf light now what i find
painful actually
first of all i find it painful to say
right here in front of mr doyle
and i find it horrifying
to think that this is what really
happened but
mr doyle has testified that
he rolled around on the floor and he had
his back was on fire and all this kind
of stuff and he stepped in some fuel
outside
that may very well be the case except
the fuel that was on his sleeves was
different than the fuel that was on his
shoe
the fuel on his sleeves was the same
kind of fuel you use to start a charcoal
fire
golf light charcoal starter fluid that
was analyzed by the land
his hands are not burnt they were
burning they were on fire big difference
mr taylor you're recognized for five
minutes
thank you mr chairman
mr doyle
like everyone else i regret the loss of
life of your daughter and i really think
that
all of this was preventable
but i personally think it was
preventable of david kresh who had
apparently from everything i can see and
read and hear an incredible amount of
control over people
husbands gave their wives to him parents
gave their very small children to him
your local paper said that
and i'm quoting now howell was turning
the branch davidians into a harem
men were mutual virtual eunuchs warned
to guard his secret
most married men stayed after howard
took their wives
to those who left they called into
outsiders there were saps
but they couldn't bear the thought of
leaving
it threw them into despair for if they
left
what was all suffering for
in these articles
it says that owl says that he was the
lamb of god
it actually quotes him talking to a
reporter saying
and i'm
that he was jesus
do you believe the david crush he never
claimed to be jesus what was her
quote
uh i'm going to quote
but in another interview i'll confirm
making this astonishing claim if the
bible is true i'm christ
but so what what's so great about being
christ a man nailed to the cross
a man acquitted with acquainted with
grief you know being christ ain't
nothing in the name jesus in the name of
christ that's separate with us okay so
i'm going to ask you do you think david
crush said that and do you believe it to
be true
what i'm saying is he never thought he
was jesus christ 2000 years ago we do
believe he was a messiah yes
and you believe that he was a messiah
a messiah okay
in an article and i'm not i think this
came out of the new york times
there's a curious quote attributed to
you and another person
and it says if god gives us a command
then it's not a sin
would that include anything
adultery lying stealing
murder
in the ten commandments it says thou
shalt not kill
for those who believe the bible that's
god's instructions to israel at sinai
the number of months or years later they
come up to
canaan and they're told to go in and
kill all the people that live there
you be the judge
did you make that statement that if god
gives us a command then it's not a sin
we believe that if
a command comes from god
then he takes the responsibility for it
it is not
sin if you're obedient to what god says
did god command the davidians to kill
those four atf agents
god didn't command me to kill anybody
there was no orders to kill anybody
uh
in fact i don't believe it was ever
proven in our trial that we actually
killed them
it's i'm not saying
nobody shot anybody from within
but it was never proven as to who shot
who
and a lot of
there was some evidence that there was
friendly fire in the wounding or
whatever of some of the agents
i'm not denying that they might have
been shot by us but it wasn't proven
in self-defense
i believe that the people were justified
if they fired back when heavy amounts of
gunfire were fired into rooms with women
and children
mr gray i'd like to go to your testimony
because
i've done a lot of research on this and
i'd like you to go back to
your theory
of how the fire started
i heard you talk about the gasoline cans
being open
please in the brief amount of time that
remains tell us how you think the fire
started
well
i thought we had done that but basically
dr quintery and i were part of the same
team
his report
is actually a supplement to mine
there is no disagreement between us that
this fire was intentionally started
inside the compound by the people in
there using flammable liquids as
accelerants when you say the people in
there who is that
the davidians themselves in fact um
uh
if if you don't find me jumping back to
my statement again there's one one
sentence i think as well
and and i i wanted to say this too
because of my
i don't know
because of what they accused me of being
in collaboration with the government
federal law enforcement officers
obviously did make some tactical errors
prior to enduring this tragic incident
and i hope
this body somebody holds them
accountable please i'm pleading with you
somebody out there in the federal
government still
screwed up big time okay
but they didn't start this fire
that's the bottom line
there is no doubt in my mind
that the ultimate responsibility for
intentionally setting fire to the branch
dividing compound lies squarely and
solely with the davidians themselves
and there's just
that's all i got to say about it
thank you
thank you mr taylor mr zeller if you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you uh mr doyle um
did you notice while you're in the
compound
anything relative to a
methamphetamine lab anything relative to
drugs any anything any
any meth labs at all there was no lab
in mount carmel under david's
jurisdiction we found upon returning
there after being gone for a few years
in 1988
we found evidence that somebody
not a member of the church had had a
drug lab and that
paraphernalia recipes chemicals whatever
was handed over to the sheriff's
department right
um
and and you know you've you've gone
through an awful experience and as we
sat and listened to you today
and you've been through a trial and
you've gone through two years we've had
a chance to think about it this week
kind of opens that all up again you've
heard testimony
atf fbi
and and all of us and uh what do you
think i mean what what's come out of
this have we've gotten
are we making any progress
there's still a lot of conflicting
information if you
one thing i do want to stress and that
is that suicide was definitely against
the doctrines well that's one question i
had was there any evidence of suicide
from my point of view no uh i don't
believe in suicide it was not taught by
david or any of the other no suicide
pact no no meetings talking about
no
nothing um as far as
the fire starting and how it started i'm
not going to speculate it
certainly didn't start in the area that
i was in i saw no one else
lighting it in the chapel or anywhere so
so the voices that at 6 a.m that were
heard
saying spreading the fuel spread the
fuel around uh the comments about hey
you you don't
nothing you saw would indicate i never
heard those statements no you never
heard those statements no
i will admit there was hay in in parts
of the building
you'd like me to explain that sure
um
as a result of the initial raid the
front of the building was so shot up
especially the women and children's
quarters
that we some of the men took boxes of
potatoes out of the
kitchen area and put them all around the
windows to kind of block up the holes
from the weather
over the 51 days of the siege the
potatoes sprouted and eventually went
rotten
because we couldn't cook without
electricity
and so on
so they were removed and i think in some
of the women's rooms there were some
bales of hay put around the windows
to take the place but no no passing hay
on top of a fire
no
i never did what about children and your
process you said you got out of the
building with four people and the way
out did you see um any children at all
no they were at the other end of the
building
center of the building if you can uh and
let me just ask mr cheryl and mr
quittier and mr gray is there a four and
a half minute
gap on the uh career tape between 11 30
and 4 and 12 o'clock
i'm not aware of any uh i didn't focus
on that part of the tape the tape that i
looked at was mainly could you check and
get back to us to see if there is i'm
not even sure if i have that part of the
tape okay
um i i guess
uh
if i may say yes the copy of the tape i
have does have a gap in it it does have
and it's four and a half minutes
approximately
just uh you you've heard we've heard
some conflicting testimony on the fire
and and you have some strong feelings
just if you can in in less than a minute
tell us
in a summary where you disagree the most
uh the main thing is uh
i don't discount that the fire was
started uh inside by the by the people
inside it could be well have been
what i do have a serious problem with is
the government's refusal to provide
material under the rules of disclosure
and the complete destruction of the fire
scene
without letting independent
investigators examine it
well all right i'm going to ask you the
same question asked mr doyle and i'll
let mr doyle answer after you've had a
chance to answer
um
and and you've saw you've you've seen
this thing this is two years ago we've
gone through criminal trial we're in a
civil trial uh you've seen all this week
you've seen all the comments about the
fact that nothing new is coming out of
here uh what we're trying to do is all
anti-law enforcement all that kind of
stuff uh we're committed and i'll stand
on the record that we're committed to
getting at the truth and we make no
apologies for getting at the truth just
uh both of you just any you've watched
now eight nine days of this uh you've
heard a fbi you've heard atf you've
heard mr potts
uh you you've heard the two guys that
got fired and rehired
just your reactions each of you in terms
of what you heard this week whether any
new information got out what information
we need to still get out if you think
somebody ought to be held accountable
who do you think that should be what are
we missing what have we got out at this
point first you mr cheryl
uh yes sir i do believe quite a bit of
new information has come out i believe
it's been very valuable there's still a
lot more to come
as i said earlier on there's some
outstanding law enforcement agents that
need the tarnish taking off their badges
if it requires criminal prosecution for
wrongdoing
if the courts find that if uh
hearings and investigations find that
that's what we need to do we've got to
get the confidence of the american
public back in law enforcement it's
there but it's been diminishing we've
got to clean that up these hearings are
really going a long way and the one
question i did ask and i just restated
is there anything that we've missed that
we should go after in the remaining two
days
yes sir i think we've uh missed some of
the uh
questions as to as i mentioned earlier
why
items of evidence have disappeared
why the crime scene was destroyed before
it could be evaluated
these areas especially the evidence
disappearing mr doyle i have a chance to
two people so you're my second one i
have to admit that i have not followed
these hearings
in every detail we can't get c-span
where i'm from but at least we don't
have it
um
i think that a lot of things have been
brought out from what i'm hearing and
seeing
uh that weren't brought out before i'm
glad that for once
the president made a statement a while
back that we've already had a bunch of
hearings already and he saw no need for
this one
i don't believe it there was ever any
witnesses
excuse me survivors that were witnesses
in those hearings
so i'm happy for that reason
i do feel that
the issues that
mr cheryl mentioned need to be addressed
for the sake of this country
and i would especially
like
which may be beyond this committee i
don't know but i would like
the situation of the nine
that are in prison to be reviewed as to
why they're doing 40 years when a jury
found them innocent of the major crimes
were you guilty of any crime no i was
not thank you very much mr doyle thank
you mr chairman mr thurman you're
recognized for five
many minutes my colleagues
on the loss of your daughter and
certainly your friends
do you remember at any time at the very
beginning um when the fbi actually took
over the compound or
actually became involved in this
and evidently mr koresh
at that time had said that he wanted to
talk to
a dr philip arnold
okay um
doctor i don't know if you know this but
dr arnold actually had an opportunity to
speak before this this committee
i haven't seen any reports or
you know
well he did and and he was very good at
trying to explain
um
your beliefs and i just want to kind of
go over something with you to maybe help
clear up this issue on the fire a little
bit
and and i'm going to read actually from
a statement that he made
so that you'll understand that it is
from him
it should be understood when discussing
the fire and its origins that if the
evidence shows that the branch davidian
ringleader started the fires this does
not
prove suicide was the reason the fbi did
not believe that suicide was an option
for the branch davidians also the bug
tapes recorded davidian telling his
fellows
not to spread all the fuel now but to
save some for later this indicates that
the purpose for spreading fuel was not
suicide because there would be no later
it suggests a motive more in line with
their religious beliefs against mass
suicide and compatible with their belief
that god would protect his people from
harm
this motive is consistent with another
remark on the tapes which seems to say
so we don't light it up till they come
in if the branch davidians started a
fire it would be done to provide a
defense against a penetrating assault by
the tanks and troop support
they seem to have regarded it
as a last resort to be used only if the
tanks come in as a last resort they
would light up the firewall to halt the
tanks from advancing on their women and
children hiding in the walk in the
middle of their sacred center their
religious faith in god would have trust
him to protect them from the fire
getting out of control but when it did
get out of control some were overcome by
smoke others were burned and so on
he has suggested that is from zachariah
chapter 2.
could you tell me about this particular
belief in your own words
there are references to
god being a ring of fire around
jerusalem
it's in reference to god being their
protection
it is not it has nothing to do with
human beings lighting fires
uh
and i never heard david make that
analogy or comparison
[Music]
always our trust has been in god
even if he allows us to die
there were times in the old testament
in the old testament where people went
through fire or went through
being in a lion then or
under siege and so when god did
miraculous deliverances
but we also have the early christian
church of the first century who believed
in that same god and were allowed to be
eaten by the lions and so on
so
we were prepared
you might say whatever god allowed to
happen to us to accept it as his will we
didn't lose faith in god or the people
that we felt that he had used such as
david
and others in the past
um but we certainly didn't believe in
suicide because i
and and it suggests that they that you
did not believe in suicide never in here
does it mention this but it does mention
the idea of a suicide is
an unpardonable sin because you can't
ask forgiveness for once you're dead you
know
but the ring of fire was meant that was
god's protection
and basically it is
literally what it says in the scripture
god will be a ring of around jerusalem
the literal city of jerusalem not mount
carmel
or whatever
mr doyle there also
evidently during your testimony with the
fbi there was a question about the fire
um do you remember giving um i guess
with your attorney present any statement
um to them about the fire at that time
to the fbi
or texas rangers i'm sorry the texas
rangers came to me while i was up at
parkland hospital in the burn ward
uh i think
the initial contact was through one of
the hospital personnel asking would i
give them
an interview and i said i did not feel
up to it
they eventually
made their way to my room and
basically
even though i said i wouldn't give them
an interview they said well can we read
the questions to you
to which to my recollection i remember
saying no comment no comment all the way
through i i did not answer their
questions
since then i've heard that i've been
quoted as saying certain things but
i would deny them who are the babylons
in your mind everybody
all mankind we're all in babylon that's
basically confusion starts in your head
and it affects families and it affects
countries and
this whole planet
thank you very much and thank you for
being here thank you and i believe that
everybody has had their time except the
chairman i'll yield five minutes to
myself
uh mr doyle i you've had a long day but
i do have a couple of other questions
and then we'll wrap up i just want to
clarify something
did you
light or start any fires on april 19th
1993 thank you
uh can you explain in any way why you
might have had two different fuel part
on different parts of your clothing or
body that mr gray was alluding to a
minute ago
i have to admit that i had a cigarette
light up
on in my pocket and
as a result of the
initial raid
a lot of people reacted through
nervousness or whatever and
i smoked not that i am a smoker i don't
i haven't smoked since coming out
uh many many years ago i gave up smoking
back in when i was 20.
and so but i smoked because we were i
was very nervous i smoked and i ate
and you think that some of that
fuel from the cigarette lighter somehow
there was an issue made of that during
the trial that a lighter was found in my
pocket
i'd say that it probably could have got
on the coast of microphone what about uh
any lighting of kerosene lamps or other
kinds of i don't know what kind of fuel
you had in there for those lamps in the
morning did you do that
um
i can remember women bringing their
lanterns to be refilled in the chapel
from time to time but i don't recall
lighting them did you refuel refill them
that morning
not that i recall on april 19th in fact
the only woman that ever came into the
chapel to my knowledge on april 19th was
jennifer andrade who came down fairly
early in the morning asking were there
any gas masks because the women in her
area did not have any and
i indicated that there was a
black plastic garbage sack there
in the pews uh with some gas masks and i
just go ahead and take them have you
heard anybody who was there either
during the course of your stay
in the compound uh
before between the 28th of february the
19th of april or since who survived with
you say
that they
believed or that they saw
anyone
making or lighting any fire that day at
all on the 19th of april 1993.
i
i don't recall any of the survivors or
especially the guys that i was in jail
with uh saying they saw about any plans
anybody say or discuss any plans to
lighten anything there's no points
discussed with me to light fires or
anything no no discussion of anybody
saying they might do something like that
just to protect themselves to barricade
the kids to return to return uh
something and throw molotov there may
have been some discussion early in the
siege when the tanks were first brought
in well how do you cope with the tank
you know and there may have been
statements like well you can't shoot it
with a rifle or a pistol uh
and references may have been made to
molotov cocktails none that day or none
within the close proximity
not to my knowledge
what about sanitation we've heard a lot
about it being very very bad the last
week or two was this unhealthy it was no
no worse on the last day than it was
throughout the 51 days what
was my job basically to dig the holes
that we
we had outhouses at mount conwell due to
the fact that we were in the process of
building and indoor plumbing wasn't a
big thing at the time and uh
once the
we came under attack and siege we were
not able to get to the
outhouses and the
actually the tanks bulldozed them over
anyway
so
we were using a bucket system on the
various levels
we had little areas marked off for
toilets and
every day these would be taken and uh
emptied i would dig a hole and empty
them fill it up and was this unsanitary
in your opinion for the kids or there
was a disease potentially there that was
greater than it was not a great
situation but i don't think it was
potentially i should say it was taken
care of every day and it was it's not
getting worse it was not imminent that
somebody was going to get very ill
because of this if there was any
there was any human waste
found or spread over the building i
would say it was because tanks maybe
went through the area
on that day but
as far as on a day-to-day basis they
were taken care of and disposed of
i would like to know what the attitude
of the people in the compound was your
friends the people who you associated
with in the last uh five six days before
the 19th were they upbeat uh were they
down
were they was it any change from the
week before
was there any sense of hope greater or
less than there had been in any previous
time and if so or not why i think there
was a kind of an upbeat uh having heard
that
god had indicated to david that he was
to write out the seals and we were told
the negotiators had given him the green
light that whatever time he needed
uh he could
spend writing them and so on i think i
think we were looking forward to
that it was going to be over
did you have any sense of how long this
might take or any sense of when you
might come out or if you would come out
there was the possibility it might take
him a week or two to to get them all
written
i don't know
whether he discussed that with the
negotiator but i was told that they said
whatever time it he needed would be
granted did you believe that he was
going to do that did you believe that
you were going to come out yes i did and
would you have ever come out had david
koresh not said it was all right to come
out
and uh if he'd indicated that um
you know god
wanted us to just submit to to the
authorities of whatever we were willing
to do that uh
he didn't tell me to escape from the
fire i came out i think that over a
period of time we were all planning to
come out let me ask one last question i
know i passed my time but i've got to
get this out you're the only davidian i
know to ask this to layer in the
hearings and and that is do you have an
opinion based on all your knowledge of
of your beliefs and the attitudes and
and beliefs of those who were inside
living at mount carmel before the
february 28th raid of the atf
had david koresh been arrested outside
the compound had he been arrested no if
he had been arrested if he had been
arrested outside the compound if he'd
been taken
away from you if you will uh
and then somebody come knocked on the
door to do a search warrant would they
would there have been anything different
would you have
how would you have reacted to that would
probably
especially if they'd come knocking
whether he was there or not i think they
would have been admitted in if they'd
come
you know regularly and just knocked on
the door and said we need to see your
guns or whatever
david crash had been arrested along with
some friends you know some of the church
members back in 87
and nobody reacted violently or made
threats of revenge or anything like that
so you didn't you would not you would
not have anticipated a an excessive
reaction a negative reaction in such a
way as to be violent against anybody no
and last and last but not least were
there any plans because we've heard
somebody say there was a mcdonald's that
somebody was going to go out and kill
everybody at mcdonald's some witness
here said that came out after the fact
were there any plans that you know of by
anybody in the compound at any time when
you were there
uh to go out and and injure or destroy
property or injure people in the local
community
no
all right thank you mr taylor mr
chairman since you you went over you can
ask a question or two if you like okay
because i know that someone's gonna
answer differently than some other
people have but i would like to ask the
exact same question this panel
you know have you heard of anything have
you seen anything have you read anything
that in any way justifies the murder of
those four atf agents by david question
as followers
and the wounding of 20 more and
or absolves david koresh
from the guilt of having those 80 people
die
with
mr quintin
no sir not in my opinion mr gray
me neither mr chair
mr dora i don't believe they were
murdered i think they were set at risks
by their own agencies going ahead
knowing that we in all likelihood knew
they were coming
i think that they went against their own
laws
attacking a building no knowing that
there were women and children in there
if the officers exposed themselves to
fire by stepping out and emptying their
magazines into the building and someone
did shoot them
uh i would consider that self-defense
not murder
i don't think anybody is justified in
doing murder defending yourself is a
different proposition and we don't call
it murder if we go and shoot people in a
wartime situation and that certainly
looked like a battle to us
you had one follow-up and i will permit
it
i really do appreciate that but mr joy
david koresh would not have been able to
physically to escape because of his
wounds
but he his body was found
with a bullet hole
through his mouth
and the barrel of a gun lying next to
him not the belt the yes
and
uh which would certainly have indicated
that david koresh and others did indeed
commit suicide what what is your thought
about that
i am not aware that he had a bullet hole
in his mouth i understand he had a
bullet hole in the head all right now
whether somebody else shot him i don't
know apparently you know it's possible
um
i can only tell you what i was told it's
hearsay
rennes abraham told me he was sitting in
the hall upstairs
and uh
at one point in the in the morning and
he went into the front room which he
ended up exiting from
retirement renis abraham went into this
room that he ended up exiting from and
in the room he said was david koresh
steve schneider and mark wendell he said
they were sitting on a bed talking
he says and he went in and was listening
to what they were having to say he said
the next thing the room filled with
smoke
he says and he walked over to the window
and trying to get a breath of fresh air
and he said the thought came to him why
am i standing here sucking air through a
broken window why don't i just go out so
he went out on the on the roof
and that was as i say the last time that
he saw david uh both steve schneider and
david have bullet
now whether
somebody shot them to put them out of
their misery whether they ran out into
the hall and found they were in the
middle of the fire instead of escaping
it i don't know i don't know what they
went through because i wasn't there
i
figured that if somebody did
what found themselves trapped and was
were burning and suffering if they asked
for somebody to put them out of the
misery i wouldn't condemn that person
but i don't know the i never there was
no one in our area that came up with
bullet holes thank the lord and uh
so there was no condemnation in that
area for us that escaped
but i couldn't speak for the others
thank you mr slaughter well we we've
certainly been a long day today i want
to thank all of you for being here in
this panel i know miss joy has been
particularly tough on you but we want to
thank the professionals are here for
helping us walk through this fire it has
been one of the great uh i guess
discussed
parts of the entire waco affair and i
hope that after this we can assess
better with your help what happened on
that final fateful day we will be in
recess until monday morning at 10 a.m we
will reconvene
in room 2141 next door the judiciary
committee room these subcommittees are
in recess
come on
now
oh
this concludes day eight of the house
waco hearings tomorrow see the ninth day
of the hearings witnesses are fbi
special agents and on friday the tenth
and final day of waco hearings will hear
from attorney general janet reno
each weekday for the rest of this week
we'll re-air the house waco hearings at
10 a.m eastern time here on c-span